um yeah oh okay but there's always some
latency so i was i mean i wasn't saying
anything crazy okay
okay what up guys welcome back i know
you just saw us live everyone left um
except for you it's just me and you me
and you
yes
me and you just just me and you yeah
pearl and rolito just just me and you so
i hear that you got banned off of
instagram i did my page got shut down in
june i had to appeal like
i think i appealed like three times a
day for two weeks
before i finally got it back wow it's
like
i just got banned off tick tock we have
so much in common yeah yeah
it was a hard two weeks
and like it's connected to my facebook
so that got shut down too
but um yeah i got it back they emailed
me and said they'd made a mistake
and
lo and behold everything came back you
know what post you got to like got taken
down i think it was my i do you know
what i don't actually know because they
never tell you the one i thought it was
is still up
so it might have been an old post
but they never tell you
so you never know which one
is the one that
but obviously whatever was reported
wasn't actually right because they say
they made a mistake they banned me for
no reason too right did they call it
hate speech
well
they're just mad because i said to send
baby mamas back to the streets
that's where they belong that's what
they call it they call it hate speech
and you know the whales too you can send
them back
where we send you them to the streets
they're calling
the water yeah the ocean
there's been a lot of whale sightings
especially in shortage lately wow
yeah yeah i mean i had a whale attack
yes
tell me more about this what was the
actual topic
so um we were talking about so i went
with my friend jesse okay
and he would ask the question is it
harder to be black or white in 2022 okay
and he's black so that was like he's you
know that's he's so i'm i'm i'm
the girl right so i say is it harder to
be a man or a woman in 2022
and these the whale thought it was
harder to be a woman okay and i'm like
okay if you lose 100 pounds then it'll
be a lot easier to be a woman
i didn't say that that's what i was
thinking
but i didn't say that but what happened
was they were saying well like
first
how would you describe how it started
first the the whale was trying to attack
me
because they were calm at first and then
got into um
protection and
uh oh no i said they're acting crazy
because she was going around to the guys
and saying are you wearing a t-shirt
saying you're gonna grate me saying
you're gonna grate me are you wearing a
t-shirt that's it and then i'm like why
and i'm like and i started laughing
she's like let's massage the man's ego
and i start laughing and then like the
the sister because like girl the one
whale one future whale but not a whale
yet
and then the the whale was like why are
you laughing and i'm like because you're
acting crazy yeah and then
and then she's like crazy and i'm like
yeah and then and then
like i forgot what she said she's like
why do you think we're acting crazy like
i can't walk home alone at night without
being scared i'm gonna be attacked and i
said you're not entitled to security
you're not just because you're a woman
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime you're not entitled to
security if you're a guy you can't walk
home alone at night either you just
don't walk home light alone at night in
dangerous areas yeah the entitlement
entitlement oh no boohoo poor me i have
to stay in the house that night
because i might get robbed because i
chose to live in the city of london when
i could live in the outskirts and be
cool exactly but i i mean i made a
conscious choice to live in the a
dangerous area and go to dangerous areas
at night
it's like
exactly i'm not telling you how to live
your life you know you can do what you
want and then she attacked you she
knocked the mic out of my hand and then
like people had to hold her back because
she's like i'll have you you slug first
of all i don't know what a slag is you
said so you're good yeah i know
if you're going to insult me please use
the word i know right because i'm not
with it
i'm not with the tart like
excuse me
yeah
so
all in all 10 out of 10 experience i had
a lot of fun yeah um and then
she was like i'll have you you slag and
i said you're a whale you're a whale
you're a whale will sighting
and then i'm like you're 35. you're and
then she's yelling oh you're a slag you
smell like fish you slag and then i'm
like and i'm like first of all
rude
second of all you're 30 you look like
you're like 35. how are you 35 and
acting like this
you're too old for this
is this my sister's like 15. it was on
youtube before it was yeah and then she
got it taken down somehow it's still on
my friend jesse's channel okay and i
still it just motivated me to post it on
instagram okay because
yeah is it the latest post
um let me see if i can find it i want to
check it out
um let's see
let me see i post a lot on instagram
like every day okay so it'd be i don't
even know where it would be amongst all
this videos
oh here it is here i'll send it to you
what was your instagram name
rolito r-o-w-l-i-t-o
here we go anyways
you could say the hoes love me
something like that this is in shortage
yeah yeah okay so i can see the
suspected whale
whale attacks is the is the title as
well
she looks very angry
oh wow
let's massage the mandy girl
you're a whale yeah you definitely
triggered her
yeah damn
the mic didn't break did it no no well
that's good
she was definitely about hurt by that
everyone said i should have punched her
but i'm like i have more to lose why on
earth would i punch her
you didn't need to do that
she lost as soon as she hit them as soon
as she hit the mic she lost and i'm like
plus like if i really wanted to get away
i could just light jog she'll be too
tired
[Laughter]
oh man
hey good luck yeah the wells ain't gonna
like this
whale attack
what's the passport yeah so the thing is
the authorities have said to be careful
of land whales right they're angry um
they don't
they're a bit
they're hungry clearly
and so and so like you got to be aware
steer clear of them
because
they might get you right as yeah so
they're becoming more and more dangerous
and more and more
more and more aggressive the older they
get
this is your first attack
um this is my first i've had some like
minor incidents where
i felt like they might attack you know i
i've had a couple of non-whales you know
just um
i don't know what should i call the
other ones feminists
yeah i've had a couple feminists who
they'll be like you're disgusting
i'll be like and you're average at best
we had one we had one girl come here
and she'd been messaging me all week
just like and i said come on the show
let's talk right
she comes in sits down and then leaves
like doesn't even say a thing yeah she
like came on the pot i'm like ma'am
ma'am
speak your piece you've been in my dms
all week
this oh there's another girl that
threatened to come here and beat me up
with her cousins oh wow yeah that was
another one why
she was mad
that
i used clips from the show okay um
and i said you
ish told you before you signed a consent
form there's nothing you can
it will say yeah and like because i'm
like the entitlement you want me to not
do clips when i pay a produced like this
show costs money right and she's like
well blur on my face i'm like then pay
my editor to do it pay me a thousand
dollars to go through every single clip
and blur out your face
yeah do you want to do oh no no
okay
so you're coming to my business and
telling me how to run it
because you there's a million people on
here just how many people have not gone
viral how many people have gone on here
had no attention at all
um
a lot a lot
a lot probably more than half right if
you say dumb [__] and people think it's
dumb that's not my fault i didn't make
you say [__] straight
so
yeah so then she like threatened to come
here
with her like cousins or something
mm-hmm
and beat me up right but that never
happened yeah i just said pull up or
shut up
and i swear to god i'll sue you
i started out touch me touch me
yeah i'm not i'm not playing i'll call
my dad
i don't think she'll be turning up
no so you could sam hard you know you
could say i'm like in the trenches yeah
yeah the trenches super like tough right
what would you say jess like i'm
trenching it
right
yeah
for you hard for you now i wouldn't say
hard
you're trenching it what do you mean for
me
for you
for me
the audacity there's nothing better
nothing against you
demoted demoted
all right demoted you do my job third
favorite
issue second
oh second let's not get too excited
i thought i was full
i didn't even know it
it was a favorite
no it's like a competition every day
oh shoot
every day she said
right now
[Music]
you know no
no actually blessing got my phone lines
working this week
so he's number one
[Laughter]
full time
he might if he keeps getting my phone
line
he actually actually he's number two you
could be number one if you get the audio
in the headphones
[Laughter]
let me think and and [__]
you know there's another there's another
guy right he does a great job okay he
does a great job
he's not around at the moment
no no
no no he'll never be here he'll never be
here yeah right
that's good
yeah there's it sounds like there's a
story behind that
i just don't like people stealing
wow
no no like my workers like people that
work for me okay so there's yeah if
they're not here i don't say their names
okay cool yeah right no problem
it's just like yeah i know there's
certain people
that try i'm like no
i got you
anyways so now that you've been demoted
from
where were you today
you might have been number one we were
vibing earlier you might have been
number one i want to hear it
[Music]
fourth fourth you're gonna put me at a
hundred
i don't care
wow
go change into some comfy clothes
okay mom
yeah that's the reason why i'm not
yep
okay
i'm number one
if i'm mom i'm number one ain't nobody
take my place that's on period
oh my goodness you're sticking around
still here for a little bit
i didn't even get a chance to look at
your instagram
go for it look to see what
what got you cancelled see what got me
temporarily cancelled
all right
is a rolito your
government name
no but it's close okay
the first three letters are the right
ones railrol
r-o-w yeah is that nickname you had
growing up row row
not just row just one row yeah
just the one
[Laughter]
no just just the one just just
yes
i'm done this one
[Laughter]
oh man
90 days
for that wow
crazy that's the delusion right there
that really is what's the
craziest thing
a woman has
made you do
or like
said to you in a relationship
um
i had i had a woman tell me that she
finds doggy style disrespectful
so she doesn't do it
she was dead serious how so
she said that she just finds it rude
it's like why why would you want to put
me in that position
why wouldn't you want to look at me i
thought she was joking but she really
wasn't
she must have some insecurities she must
be flat as a pancake in the back she
actually wasn't really no
that was the thing that's what i
couldn't get my head around i just could
not understand it
she said disrespectful she finds it
disrespectful she doesn't do and she'll
never do it
she's missing now that's all i got to
say
now
i'm playing y'all i've heard people talk
about it
i have no clue what it is yeah that's
the wildest and vice versa
the craziest thing
i don't know
what's the craziest thing
what do you ask
i asked him what's the craziest thing a
woman has said to him in a
relationship you want to tell her yeah
so she says she finds doggy style
disrespectful
and she doesn't do it
and she feels like
you shouldn't be having sex with someone
and not looking at them
[Laughter]
horrible
it's the worst it's the world the worst
it's the worst isn't it yeah yeah just
so disrespectful god i i i hate being
dead i
never want to be put in that position
don't do that
dog is out
that's like the worst the worst you're
just gonna leave the water running
see this is what mom does
well you don't pay bills around here
neither do i but
[Laughter]
you just can't leave the water running
but crazy and he asked me what's the
crazy thing
a guy said oh god
i know there's some
i'm trying to remember
i don't know
look
on my head he was in the room yeah
why wasn't you listening
you tell a mom
and i was like yo
you are making he said um
[Laughter]
hey i'm just here i'm a guy
smiling you didn't answer auntie's
question earlier what was the question
well
you didn't comment when she was talking
about yeah yeah that's crazy i i don't
know what the question was it wasn't a
question it was a comment what was the
comment she was talking about how um
she um
dudes that
are in your position
what's my position oh yeah you're gonna
stay you wanna you wanna take it
we're here
um
that are sustaining from
sexual intercourse yes
yes
is that
yeah
how about it that's the whole thing is
that sort of thing
okay
you know you know how you know it's not
it's because he keeps repeating the
question to you no no no that is not
i um
it's like when someone says did you
cheat did i cheat
hey hey that has changed
i'm still here
so you're practicing celibacy
saturn like
intercourse it's practicing and
no no no
it's a celibacy i don't know i'm good
you said something like that
yeah so auntie thinks you're weird yeah
yeah for that i respect it yeah at least
no i couldn't see something's wrong with
you no but more so i think if if she had
had a conversation with me i appreciate
it and i could she'd understand then i'd
underst i'd want to hear a point on it
but
well you could ask
i was a little busy but okay i get it i
could have
you had a mic like what did i get your
camera for yeah do you know i can't lie
that i'm packing that on live
yeah not my portion i bet i could have
clipped it
i know
yeah i know
you can just clip this and stuff yeah no
take it just clip every moment with
auntie she was spitting right she was
just she was
that's just like i would drive to his
work i got a card
i can't wait to start her channel oh my
god that's gonna go huge it's special
ellie i'm about to put you back in the
cage lock your way in the tower
about to be fiona up in there
so what's the main difference between us
and uk dudes
um
i think uk guys dress a little bit
better right they're a little bit taller
i think
this from where you're from from chicago
anyways
i'm from l.a so um
and they have accents right
a knit
in it
yeah i'd say that's the biggest would
you say
i'd say i think drought like i think
british guys dress a lot better than
americans
for me they they dress similar oh yeah
um
the guys in la
i would say it's
there's some that dress
more casual there's definitely a uk
aesthetic i would say
but it's kind of similar
um it's more
flashy in l.a
um
as far as
dudes there's a
out here there's a different array in la
you get your
a large majority of cookie cutter dudes
where
it's like what's a cookie cause dude
sorry it's like i've seen i've seen this
type of guy here i've also seen the same
type of guy here but they're two totally
different people really i feel like i
see the same people in different bodies
all the time yeah it's like the same
stories but like different people and
the more i do this and the more people i
talk to the more it's like weird you can
read people so much better and you like
know what they're going to say before
it's like it's a weird phenomenon but i
understand how kevin samuels could like
break people down so quickly it's
because he's like i've talked to you a
million times right yeah that's like
when the girls get like i'm like i've
talked to you like 500 times just in
different women women
i would say the
men here are
not more approachable but they approach
more okay than in the states from
what i've experienced right
like they're more willing to approach
somebody
whether in the states it's like
you got to look a certain way yeah yeah
ain't got to be a certain way for them
to even
bat an eye at you yeah yeah well i feel
like here the girls are uglier
i feel no i'm serious i think like when
you come from america you get a point
a whole point you know maybe two
honestly all right
look i'm not
do you mean that like
as in enhanced or just
no i just
when i'm in the u.s when i walk around i
see more like beautiful women okay like
beautiful where here it's like i see
girls that are pretty cute and like even
when i see girls here
that are like arguably eights like i'm
like um if i was in like when i was in
l.a i'm like maybe like a sixth there
but i mean
you know chicago does okay with the
women
but i would i'd say from la you go up
two points from chicago you go up one
right
well okay
i've been tonight oh you said from l.a i
go two points no like so if you're a
five in l.a you're a seven in london
if you're a five in chicago you're a six
in london
okay you do have five times the
population of us that is true i was
going to say that
so it's it yeah
you get all the beautiful people in one
condensed city i can't tell you why
there's a bit you also this is like the
biggest city
like one of the biggest cities in the
world
in terms of population diverse it's so
diverse it's very diverse
me too that's what i like that's why i
started the show partially
because i had never been in a place
where
i'd met so many like i could meet
someone from nigeria i could meet
someone from italy like
when elsa when else am i going to run
into a girl from italy yeah whose
self value has to be
for everything and it's not like like in
the u.s everyone's from different states
so that's a little different but
in
here it's like like the cult like if you
go to chicago and you go to l.a like
yeah they'll have different cultures but
they're still american at the end of the
day but here if you're in london and
italy like it's two different worlds i
would say if you go to the coast
i would say if you go to
florida and california you get the
biggest mixture of people like libya in
california i've met people from
the islands from hawaii from samoa so
samoa from honolulu from all the islands
over there i met people from the
philippines
um
uh what's where is her family from uh
cambodia i've met people i've met people
from that side of the world so
but here it's like more of the culture
that
i've wanted
to know
and it's just like oh just like to see
a ray of black people but they're not
all from
atlanta or
florida or kentucky or all the populated
like areas they're like oh no i'm from
here my bloodline comes from here and
i'm just like
you know where you're from it must be
nice but it's cool to
to see it and experience and just see
how hard y'all go for
where you're from i'm like
i love it
yeah now the debates get heavy you know
you speak to nigerians and ghanaians
especially those two about jollof and
football and who makes the best and then
lot can go on for ages i mean they can
stop this come on
what makes it different
duress
we use basmati and they use like bullet
rice
fufu or panda damn i ain't a fan of
either
i love me some foundation
ponder jump is nice
okay question have you guys ever had a
girl stalk you
yes
i um no i wouldn't say still
i mean okay
maybe lightly
like i've been told of fake pages
following me so like i've been made
aware
of this is this person's fake page
that watches everything you doing
and i've had people come up to me
and basically tell me about my life and
they've like never once dm me never once
commented on a post anything but they
know everything i'm doing just from like
my stories and stuff
i don't know if there'd be a stalker
yeah i don't i feel like if you're
putting it out there for people to see
it's yeah that's what i'm saying
stalking is like showing up to your work
literally yeah so nah
i haven't
you ever been stock dish yeah
yeah yeah um
what happened
so
i was doing uni events
and
one person
would turn up to
the events
every time i was on
like shift
and
it was like how did that person know
but then i was like okay there's a
there's a schedule and then they'd
always message me being like
i'm here oh like i'm i'm here are you
coming
hey i don't know
no fool i am coming but
i was like yeah i don't know i'll see
so yeah
i won't go into too much diy but yeah
that was an interesting one have you
just
no i have
no glory be to god thank god yeah yeah
no
i'm not at that status yet
that's not a status that's just an
unlucky
occurrence alpha with the words
[Music]
out here
yo
he said that
so i'm guessing you're going to say you
ain't never thought nobody even no i
haven't been easy
no i'm not crazy okay so
no i don't think i've ever done that
nobody got time for that i really got
time to
do better get my life together
don't think dudes are attracted to crazy
girls
oh no i do think they're attracted to
crazy girls okay
they just don't know that they're crazy
until they get into lies
they don't they know really they know
like
okay i have a question for you all right
i hear you got some interesting stories
okay where do you get them from
all right so like
basically
a mixture these stories come from life
experiences
from my friends experiences that i'm
aware of okay and then i may add a
little twist on it
i like story time
so so
this is just i was just told okay that
so it's on your your instagram stories
is that what do you do you post so like
do people submit them
no no no no so essentially the way my
answer is set up is that i might see a
meme or a real
with a caption or a picture
and from that i can make up a story
from the story there may be truth in it
and there may be fiction okay so you you
kind of embellish it
yeah so i make it as general as possible
and then yeah people over the years it
just sort of got
people enjoyed reading it what's the
craziest one you've
embellished or or maybe it was true are
they explicit that's another question um
no wouldn't it
yeah i mean yes or no yeah like
it depends what you consider explicit
i've got
sexual content
let's say i've got single mother type
stories um
going up north you might not know but
the women may be deemed a little bit
easier up north when it comes to getting
them
for a certain demographic of mail
is it your demographic
is my demographic of me
um what else
um
cheating men
cheating women
you know
um
all types if i mean if i look
it could refresh my memory i'm just
wondering if you got one you want to
read or something okay i just i was told
let me
let me see
is it like similar
so i've never seen your content before
right um
but is it like similar to young philly's
sunday stories
um i wouldn't i wouldn't know actually
i'm not too sure i haven't heard it so
okay so like just show me just showed me
this post this was one of my recent
posts so you've seen this right yeah
yeah
so you can see
the at the arch or lack of arch right
yeah
so
the
the caption on it is women will make you
wait 76 business days for this bs
right
okay yeah
so
my caption is literally a story
based on this
so do you want me to read it yeah okay
cool
so you're on your third date get closer
to the mic okay my bad is this better
yeah all right cool so you're on your
third date listening to her
um
tell you why she hates her ex
and how the girl he cheated on with her
was fat and ugly for the third time
as if it as if that stopped the man then
before
you continue to look like you're
interested as you ain't beat
as you ain't beat yet and you throw in
some oh my days swear downs and what no
way mad ting for decoration
another three figure bill has landed on
the table and all of a sudden her phone
is
is out and her bladder is loose
her
i'm just getting toilet babe
hold on
you
yeah yeah cool now you're watching us
way towards the lavatory and she has the
audacity to take her empty purse with
her
your bank balance and your crypto wallet
have decreased significantly in that
space of time but the bill is settled
and now you're both in the back of the
uber getting touchy feely her
oh my god
are you hard you what do you expect
you've made me wait 76 days
[Laughter]
well you ain't got away any longer
whispers i'm already wet and my [__]
shaved you damn her yep it's bolder than
tyrese
you ao boss man i beg you pool i bet you
put your foot down boss man obliges with
a smile and three minutes later you're
back at the estate in in your room
her why do you have two single beds
you
i shared a room with my little brother
still
her okay and where is he
you at his dad's her oh you don't have
the same dad you no
her okay where's your mom
you at her boyfriend's or something
you oh i thought you live with your mum
and dad
you i do
a loud these questions and bend over in
it
i like it when you're aggressive you
bend like this her
like this babe you nah just arch it a
piece huh
okay like this baby you
know the other way her oh like this vape
aggressively tries to put
her in position
are you thumb
arch your back
oh like this fake you
just lie on your back
oh my god are we gonna make love
you you know what just put your pant
back on her why baby oh your willy's
gone soft you mumble should have stayed
with my girl
shaking my head
so yeah that
that sort of stuff
that i do
or i can just give my own point of view
about you know
like i think you saw the one the longer
you stay single the more they [__] your
future wife
that one is definitely one that hurts
you know yeah hey the game's the game
game is the game man
charge it to the game people charge it
to the game
okay have it okay question good have you
ever had a girl cheat with you
as in she was cheating on somebody else
yeah yeah yeah what i've heard from guys
is like
that
getting women kind of ruined them
because they saw the awful things women
did with them
exactly that is probably the biggest
factor and it's always the girls like
you wouldn't expect is what they would
say but that's the biggest fact so i'm
curious because guys always say you can
tell if she's a hoe but they'll also say
like it's always the ones you didn't
expect so
what what's which one's true
um both statements are true okay
definitely but
i feel like people get into stuff
you know
alcohol being a social lubricant
and
people just
really wanting to do bad stuff
you know
and like we were talking about earlier
men and women both like sex
so
when you have that dynamic
whatever can go wrong will go wrong
but
again
women like to
be held unless until it's accountable
so
when you're dealing with
certain women who
cheat again they've already made it so
it's happening because of somebody else
it's not happening because they want
that's what girls always say whenever
like you say she's not having sex it's
like why is just she having sex or if
she cheated well why didn't she cheat
when it's like does it matter yeah who
cares yeah unless you got like unless
you're with the not having said unless
you're sick or something but like like
sick i'm talking like
yeah like terminal yeah right
so yeah man they always need to be like
heard out but it's like well for why
it's crazy because it's like you may
approach a girl
who
tells you she's in a relationship and
she seems like she's a loyal good girl
and you still talk to her and even like
a part of you doesn't even want her to
to slip
and then she does slip and give you what
you want and you're just disappointed in
her for doing it
and again that again causes trauma and
because then it's like how would you
trust
exactly because one day that's going to
be you
yeah i mean some guys kind of
it's weird because
i i almost think once a guy has slept
with a like a certain amount of girls
like it kind of ruins him too on some
extent because he can't look at women
the same yeah
and
like it's almost
his lifestyle doesn't really match the
woman that he would want you know
this is why i was saying earlier that
the whole sort of
rate in good and bad sex is not
something i do because it's like
i feel like you you just get past all
that once you once you've had a certain
amount of women
like your objective is more
ego based than
chasing this sort of so-called good and
bad sex you just want to be like yeah i
managed to get her
as opposed to looking at this amazing
woman who's
backing it up like nobody else and it's
like
you know
but it's kind of it's kind of like a
double-edged sword because if you view
women as special
they don't want you
right
and so
it's like a double-edged sword okay but
then it's like the things you have to do
to not be a woman is special it's like
then
you almost don't want that anymore
yeah
that's right i see a lot of like
playboys get older you know like
like and i'm just like
are they winning hugh hefner was he
winning kinda yeah i mean i would trade
my life with the life he was having yeah
do you think like who actually
questioned would men prefer that or like
a family in general
um i feel like i know i know they'd
prefer in between but if they had to
pick one if we had to pick one i
honestly feel like we would pick hugh
hefner yeah
i do i think
that i think the family thing is
wait sorry can i just add a caveat so
you wouldn't pick the idea of legacy
like your your lines being passed down
being able to kind of
have
i don't know yeah honestly bro i do not
know many people in happy relationships
and i know people in relationships so
cool you've made kids
whatever but
you're
fundamentally you're not that happy
and the thought of that legacy is not
what's carrying you life is literally
carrying you you understand you have to
provide and you have to look after your
family but you're genuinely not happy
now
living that hugh hefner lifestyle
there will be moments where you think
this might get a bit boring
but then you will get strong again
and you'll have an abundance of
beautiful women to deal with
and you'll start feeling happy again i
feel you'll have more moments of
happiness than sadness
in that situation than in a family
oriented
i guess like i just always had a really
good example of like marriage and my
parents and like the families around us
but i'm also a woman so i know like we
view things differently yeah but
i don't know like my parents my parents
were always like the cute ones growing
up like they were always the ones that
were like holding hands and like yeah
like i don't know like doing like cute
[__]
but you also know that
that is very rare like you not really
where i'm from no
like i can think of like three four i
mean i wouldn't say it's like the rule
i'd say it's like 50 50 where i'm from
or like what is
like families being like happy and i
mean happy's relative so i'm not like
they're not teenager puppy like you know
like first
year of dating love but
it's like
like overall i'd say they like each
other they're happy you know that's nice
yeah
no but it's it's not the norm
yeah that's my point it's like it's
really not
you know
so yeah i'm i'm getting huge
ish
again you have no family legacy
i'm going playboy bunny yeah yo i can't
lie to you
i'd pick family man yeah yeah cat
i'm playing on point
no i picked family yeah but maybe i'd
say i date a virgin
no but that's probably on the basis that
i
you have not i have i've never
experienced having my own family in it
and i think ideally i my mindset would
be
to like have the nuclear family and try
and see where that goes
um but
hue having a lifestyle
yeah like
like i've seen it i do you know what i
mean i've seen it i i know what it
entails i know what it looks like at the
top right not personally but i i've seen
it i've witnessed it i've been around it
it's like
okay i know what i'm what it would look
like yeah i have an idea okay and
therefore i'm like you think the family
would be better yeah you think the same
vagina for 50 years would be better
i think the same
nagging mm-hmm
the devil you know is better than the
one you don't i struggle to believe that
man
i feel like
i don't i see the two and like i said i
i don't see many i mean
we look at all the debating we've done
today
and these are from single people
apparently you know yeah like to even
find people in relationships who could
come and debate
they
will not really tell you anything
positive about their relationships i beg
to different we have a lot of people
come on yeah yeah okay what do they say
there's not a lot of them but we have
had people yeah yeah come on like
recently we had like one girl who
when she married her spouse they were
both virgins okay and
she explained that they're pretty happy
in their marriage i think they're
newlyweds okay
like it's been going really well for
them right um
[Music]
i don't know like
we've had a variety of people we've seen
people that are quite happy in their
relationships okay well that's good man
long may that continue but don't then
again there are people that you can tell
they ain't talking too much about their
relationship yeah i'm in a relationship
but it's not
there's there's some girls that like
they'll say they have a boyfriend
they'll look at their instagram i'm like
where is he where is he
yeah yeah
but
i don't know the
you know what we have had what a lot of
girls
that
i don't know you can tell they've
settled right
like
you they speak about their boyfriend
or
they're in that age category where we
know that
they're going for the mating strategy
we've had a lot of like
baby moms come on right
and they've got their
guys and
you can tell it's not the guy they
wanted or like their baby dad's not in
the picture anymore
and you're like this guy doesn't even
know what's going on exactly
no clue it's funny you say that because
like i
at my place of work i've there are some
girls who are in relationship
and just the way they talk about their
partner like if he heard
he would leave them
woody though well maybe he wouldn't but
he should
just based on the way they talk about
them so it's like yeah there is a lot of
settling there is a lot of i
probably couldn't survive financially
without him
you know therefore he stays around but
i always feel like you know when you're
talking
about your partner like that to other
people it's crazy no i head up
crazy
but it happens a lot
what's up funny girls she wants to tell
the child
let us
know makes sense
pearl out here playing captain sabo
you can't save these hoes
you can only
what
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
you meet a girl you really like
ish would you get married and have kids
now
if i met a girl i really like would i
marry
you we did
zoom in
yo
if
yeah wait rephrase you met a girl you
really like did you get married and have
kids like now like next like three years
yeah yeah yeah what about do you want to
be married yeah that's the ultimate goal
okay but like you want side chicks
that's what i'm hearing
i would never cheat
black men black men don't cheat that's
right
anyway this is like
girls i don't need a man yeah okay yeah
okay
i miss italia she don't need nobody she
don't need no man he wants to be seven i
saw i saw the death in your eyes when
you said the same funani for 50 years
how many side chicks you need
how many wives do you want i said me and
jess are looking to be sister wives just
you know i said it is unrealistic for a
man to be with one woman uh-huh i feel
like it is
yeah people find that controversial
but it's like you know he didn't catch
it okay so your ideal are you having
like more than one wife one wife bunch
of side chicks you want sister wives
yeah yeah sister one exactly your
situation at the moment is your friends
i have friends exactly else
yeah
sister wife he's avoiding the question
oh sister sister wives sister wives be
good we're gonna we're gonna do a dating
show okay sister we're offering since
we're getting close to 30 we're 50 off
so we're in a two-for-one special okay
so what is this in tape
okay so we want bunk beds right yeah
yeah and we really just want to hang out
with each other yeah yeah and
like we want to split the household
chores you know
um i'd like a house at some point yeah
yeah at the moment i'm just not sold at
all
we would okay so essentially
yeah
you would have no drama from us you
would be able to
whatever day you needed us call us boom
i need you here this time blah blah blah
okay bet if it's if it's me or pearl
whichever one you need it we're at your
disposal yeah
yeah we're just there we'll do the
cooking the cleaning we'll be the
typical housewives and then i gotta
trust them would be good money-wise yeah
would you do stuff together
what do you like
oh would you say
you see i'd rather i'd rather just take
turns
i'd rather just take we could be like a
schedule you know
jess you go first and and and we're cool
with one more sister wife as long as she
has to share the room with the bunk beds
we're big under the bunk beds okay yeah
yeah but he didn't answer the question
though
i said i said no i said we're taking
turns it's just like haunted it's like
taking stuff together no i just you know
yes
she's happy people
[Laughter]
yeah no honestly i'm not good with
sharing okay if we can
if i'm gonna do it's gonna be
me i'm gonna be the all-star of the show
can we like we could give each other
like pointers
i mean
she couldn't even imagine it
no no pearl arch like this pearl
leg up like this there you go coaching
yeah yeah we're doing it
yeah pearl
all right
anyways um that sister this is the new
version of the bachelor
like two like
first season will air like december you
know yeah yo they should do that
but sister wives that's what i'm saying
like because i just feel like we're
we're hitting our walls you know
so speak for yourself
right i'm 23. yeah i'm 24. i feel like
it's a good offer
two for one would you guys would you
guys accept that sarah if you're still
in the chat would you want that yeah the
two for one special saurus
yeah it's like it's like you know it's
the best of both worlds
chocolate and vanilla guys guys be like
i don't have a type well great
unless unless you want a short girl
that's out i'm sorry but the great thing
is like we raise athletes here
we don't we don't we don't raise kids on
jv
so that's okay it'll be great because
i'll coach the kids right so i'll be in
the backyard from like the time they're
five being like making sure they know
that their love will only be given
if they can learn how to dribble right
yeah i like five i'll be like you you
want you want attention
follow through
sweet makes sense yeah
that's an interesting one
bulletproof plan
what
shut up yo
eddie said he's accepting sister-wise
[Laughter]
oh okay chat eddie said he's taking the
offer oh the sister wife yeah the sister
wife off her
i was chatting [__] i didn't think
we'll have our people talk to your
people we'll send you the paperwork and
everything
see that you knew right that could have
been you right now
could it negotiate
okay here's the thing i want bunk beds
okay but i'd also like a second room
where i could play my guitar in good
question does this come into play
next year
because you're definitely moving
i mean we still have the plays yeah yeah
i just
yeah foundation yeah yeah
i just i mean if they if they act up we
just go back to our place yeah right
it doesn't sound like i'm winning here
anybody else what what would y'all just
adding to the rotation right wait
someone said my tic-tacs back in the
comments but i feel like they're playing
with me
ebony and ivory
yes
90 frito pie you
[Music]
put up or shut up exactly
we we've been offering this to people
for a while now oh yeah they don't jump
at the bit
yeah
we go to your room sarah
we're not our room isn't for that that's
why we have bunk beds we're just there
to sleep we go to you
i thought we made that clear yeah like
because we gotta we gotta follow they
lead we follow yeah exactly
you come to room
pearl
jess okay how does it work there's seven
days in the week we know we could do it
could be like a competition
and the person that like could i put it
does better each week can get the extra
day you know what i mean because it's
not an even number of days i'm sorry you
ain't about to get that extra day
yo i'm
yo
let's talk about your knees yeah my
knees are perfectly fine
really because you don't have an acl
i didn't have an acl one two years ago
and it's still work
you don't need an acl
yeah we could we maybe we could like
offer to the highest bidder it could be
like an auction yeah yeah
do i want to get auction off that's a
little
mad do i want to get auction off i mean
come on go back to them
can we can we stop can we stop acting
like we're above it we're on our wall
i don't want to get auctioned off
i was born in 1994 not to get auctioned
off so
legit i mean they can send me money
send peas yes nps
what does sarah say
sorry are you
speaking mad in the chat
sarva said we're making him reconsider
sarah
someone said a super chat they said yes
you better start making more money to
pay for those bunk beds
yo
yo i don't [__] where i eat
i eat here so we ain't messing around
with this i'm good i'll pass off on the
offer not that it was even off
sarah sarah says he says no or he said
i'm fine with that
fire said
pull me in coach
what guy
the legend
sorry man come through no he said i'm
working
you work from home i'm kidding
real sister-wise of the red pill someone
said
look at it look at it
you two gonna make a name for yourself
when someone said more nagging two wives
i said they said the crap
that's what i said to my dad i was like
dad
everyone in the manosphere says you're
cheating
because my dad my dad's in like top one
percent of earners and they're all like
oh they have side chicks and i'm like
yeah where are your side chicks
and then he's like yeah
um
[Music]
deal with one woman before you've got to
deal with multiple that's too much work
you ain't lying
i put in my bed
someone said he's putting in his bed
okay how would okay hear me out
two for
read the terms and conditions
yeah
the red pill sister wives
someone said one of the members said
please title this
the better title is the red pill
sister-wise
i'm putting my bid in i need both of
y'all every day plus i need my songs
dunking in the sixth grade i'm telling
you we could have a whole training camp
oh best believe we could
i know how to do i do biometrics i hop
out
should i make this happen are you so
you're you're trying to be the like the
third sister
i work here so
just it just i'm just here oh someone
said oh 90 free to pie said i'm 6'4 we
can make some sport legends together are
you athletic you can be 6'4 and
unathletic
huh you got to be athletic
nope someone said go to dubai got off a
bid
[Music]
show my chest
could that be you
huh
you know what it didn't dubai oh
we can make sports legends together
heck no
yeah let's see let's see let's see your
offers guys um
one day
someone said
nightingale 21 said
two for one special each girl one day
date night saturday saturday night movie
night on sunday night monday night
chilling with drinks with
but pearl
with
yeah how would date nights go would you
want to okay would you want to share the
date nights or would you want to be like
special like each of us i mean sometimes
we can share it yeah we get along but
sometimes i'm like i don't want to oh i
don't want to talk to you pearl okay
how would you how would you feel if you
felt like he was giving me more
attention than you
that would be cool honestly i'd be like
okay
no i would be i'd be like okay cool from
your so-called man
we're sister wives i get it but he's got
a favor if
if i if i was first and then pearl came
in the picture and then he started
giving her more 10 then i would feel
away but
so what's the difference of you both
coming in at the same time and then
because without more attention he's just
giving pro more attention
that logic makes no sense whatsoever he
just i i can't explain it he just he was
just like pearl moore there'd be
something that pearl has that i don't
have that he likes to be around more
and i would i wouldn't what about if po
came first
you came second and he liked to pull
more
is that a problem
because pearl came first but if you're
first
per comes second and he likes per more
there's a problem
it's not really like there's a problem
it's just
it would suck
i'm kind of a jealous [__]
[Music]
yeah i don't
but i feel like if we went in knowing
we'd be sister wives like i could come
at it because
we're the wives you know like i come in
knowing
yeah
but
ain't nobody bidding in the chat so
let's see let's see
let's see the where's our um
i mean once you go puerto rican would
you go puerto rico puerto rican
look at it yes
okay let me know
if you get bunk beds or two rooms we're
okay
we're okay with two rooms i get bottom
bunk though
i when i was in college i rolled off my
bunk bed and i separated my shoulder
and the thing is my my bunk bed was over
like it was taller than me so it was
like over a six foot drop yeah i do the
hospital that night yeah
alex was sleeping and then i woke up and
i was on the floor i was like this is
not good and you had like no barrier
yeah
you have to see the way we set it up it
wasn't a smart way like i wouldn't
recommend it
um
yeah let's see
we got
um lol i'm bald too you like your sims
california how do you feel about bald
man
back up ellie i don't want my toes leg
not by you
[Laughter]
i want to know more about your personal
life let's talk
yo
ask away okay so where the hell is that
i ain't got one
no dressing
is that different yo he ain't got mike
chill out yeah yeah he ain't gonna
and
he's smiling right now like as if it's
just hiding something why would i be
hiding anything i'm here
five times a week like okay would you i
wanna hear yesterday uh mike oh [__] yes
or no oh yeah you're right we gotta get
this in the mic
um
would you would you ever um eat ass
we are at that point in this live stream
ladies and gentlemen yes
are you a feet type of guy
i'm getting this from the chat
bald men are sexy sarah
there are like bald men when they can
pull it off for the right one
for the right you doing whatever
what about that girl that was like i
want to be his piece cam newton's girl
what you doing for her oh yeah she was
good
she was saying all the right things give
her that she says some people said yes i
have
eaten eating the groceries
i ain't done that yet
my girlfriend and i took a political
alignment test she feels like i'm very
right-wing
kim came out i'm a center libertarian
and she's an anarch socialist makes for
interesting discussion
someone said zentian said training is
sharing correct as for as for who comes
first i think as long as they do it's
all good correct i'm going to work just
showing some support
could be that could be the he would be
the highest bidder i bet
yeah yeah
he's the one and he's the
member of the week yeah is that
sentience
going once okay if you guys could either
have one of the two you could either be
taller
or
better looking facially which one would
you pick better looking facially yeah
same i feel like my height is cool
really i'm good
you both are good looking though thank
you
could be better
okay if you could pick fate like
improving face or body what would you
pick
body blade wait no jack to like get more
jack i could get more jacks though i
can't improve i can't change my face
i agree with that that's that's what
i've picked yeah i would put face
because i could i can jump i'm content
with my face so
i'm getting buddy
what do you think so when you're trying
to hook up with the girl what's the
hardest thing
for me like like what what gets this
um what the hell what is the hardest
thing
what's the hardest noise what's the
worst objection that you get like the
most common one from girls probably that
they don't believe that i'd be a fateful
guy
i could see that
i mean i did come in here said i have a
girlfriend i think to be fair i think
it's based off of the words you say oh
okay
to be fair like i think you say things
that imply you couldn't be a faithful
guy
so like if you're saying
yeah i can't be a faithful guy
[Laughter]
and then they're like they're like you
know what i'm not a detective but i
don't think you could be a faithful guy
it's like are they like definitely said
that
marriage is the ultimate goal and i'd be
a one-woman man
so yeah but that was after you like
looked with like pain in your eyes and
thought of sleeping with one girl
and also and also said i have multiple
girls they're friends though they're
friends
no no hate you know don't have the
player hate the game like i feel like if
girls are offering [__] on demand like
why would you not take it i get that
okay it's like based on like the things
you say you know well
i feel like i i struggle before i even
say certain things so uh-huh yeah
they just seem to feel like i will be a
cheater for whatever reason i could see
the reason okay
but see you say i can see the reason and
then you say that is my words so do you
see it or is it based on what oh sorry
i'm sorry i could hear the reason you
can hate it right yeah okay like based
on that
i can accept that more than i can see
the reason oh okay yes
sorry i'm i meant you meant here that's
cool if we're being technical here all
right so that's your biggest biggest
objection you're like baby come home
with me
i don't know how the guys do the game
you know or maybe like maybe you're out
she's out of your place she's like you
know what
but girls love cheaters that should help
you get into bed
i feel the problem is is when i actually
want to be serious um
you know i mean if i love being serious
with cheaters
they love getting cheated on you would
think so right they do listen you're
here on the couch but maybe the fear is
oh
i had never cheated no not you
the girl
yeah
maybe maybe the fear is that i'm i'm
actually not going to cheat therefore
they're not going to get to enjoy the
toxicness of a relationship um
so you think they think you're too
stable and really they say
that you're gonna cheat but it's like a
[__] test and really they're like he
wouldn't you wouldn't cheat so it'd
probably get boring
what about you ash what's the biggest
what's the biggest objection that you
got with the females the ladies
the biggest objection i get with the
ladies yeah
four
um
communication
you don't communicate yeah
what about it you like ghost them
oh yeah
oh yeah you go
hey hey or but like if you like the girl
then you communicate with her now yeah
so then you just like that the complaint
would be like
you don't like them no i no
i i just i tend to ghost from time to
time but it's just because i get busy
but then but if you liked him you
wouldn't ghost right it's just like you
didn't like it i'm just i'm i'm not
you're not meeting like a girl your
dreams and like ghosting her of course
you're busy no
you're not that busy
i mean you could like you could send a
text during the show it's just like not
i'm not there yet you can definitely
make it i'm not gonna do one hey you say
this but right now if i put i see i see
you chatting with guests you could like
pull for a second you know text her hey
guys right now put my purpose first
you feel me
yo
check the phone
there's nothing there
a purpose first
yeah that's what i'm on can i read this
next super chat yeah
seductive voice reuben i don't know if
you wanted me or pro to read it but
i'mma read it
rubin reuben i just wrote that so you
can say my name my life is complete now
keep up the good work and i hope to see
you in a new venue soon watching from
orlando florida
okay someone needs to pay her to do
was it asmr asmr asmr
would you guys watch it if i did it
of course they would
put a w in the chat if you would watch
jess we'll get you set up put a drooling
emoji we'll get you
hi guys
welcome back to my channel
it's that time
[Music]
welcome back to just probably things
what's the best pickup line you guys got
that like works the best like if you're
gonna cold approach a girl on the street
what would you say
oh
i want to see if it'd work on me okay
wait i'm gonna i'm gonna pretend i would
be like ha ha pretend walking in
a minute oh man
like okay so i wouldn't use it but i
mean okay i could say it to you okay
yeah so like do you believe in what do
you believe in love at first sight
or should i walk by again
asmr
that's clever that's clever
what about you um
so you wait would you just say that if i
was walking
like like that's how you'd approach a
girl no
how would you approach her if i was
approaching a girl yeah
i just say hello
and if she says hello back i'll start
talking
okay where are you
pick-up line yeah i ain't done this in a
minute
have i ever got one
oh gosh um
pick up my pickle and pick offline help
me
i got one you know
come back to me
we gotta work on that yeah i know oh
what about you blessing you gotta pick
up line
[Laughter]
he didn't make
he said i'm legally blind
i'm about to be illegally sleep here
you can take a nap i'm feeling good no
i'm feeling good you can get me tomorrow
no no i'm gonna okay are you sure i'm
proud i like i need you to take a nap so
i can do it
no that makes sense
i don't got any pick-up lines i don't
think
the only one i can think of is when my
brother told me but it was more to be
funny i don't think i'd use it it's gone
it's like not good oh it's like baby did
you fart because you blew me away
[Laughter]
that's what i said i was like my brother
i just thought it was funny
did it hurt pearl
when i fell from heaven
[Music]
and said it did
yeah it was like quite painful actually
let's look up some let's google some
oh here's one
no i've got one i've got one
you remind me of the six letters of the
alphabet
u
r a cute
you forgot one letter i'll give you the
d later
but just finished it
oh yeah i forgot i i listened to that a
while ago but i forgot about the ending
yeah
good one
i need to be more creative
yeah let's let's
let's see
oh that's cringy
it says i wish my pillow was as huggable
as you hmm
it's cringy that's crazy
unless your mama jokes you remember
though what about you yo that show
you're trying to eat out
no
yeah i was gonna end to that i didn't
have anything
wait what
you trying to eat out
yeah what were we eating
you
one of those is good i didn't say it but
yeah
why do you want to say you didn't want
people to think you actually did it hey
hey hey
let's not jump to the conclusions here
okay
um groceries
fish that was grocery shopping
they just been talking about a lot you
know
okay
have you ever talked about you know have
you ever hooked up with more than two
girls at a time
i've heard a lot of guys i've hooked up
with two i've never heard a guy that
hooked up with three at one time
are you going
are you talking about like a snapchat is
over suffering like no before because
they're being like you can't get one
i've never i've never met a guy that
could pull off three with one we have a
new
trap
i feel like two i've heard a lot of guys
say that
not yet
drop a package of sugar and then say you
dropped your name tag
a member sent that one
he said drop a packet of sugar and then
say you dropped your name tag
you dropped your name tab sugar
that's a cute one i'm like oh it's cute
creative i like it yeah i've never heard
it before
what hour is this for an hour
13 14. yeah roughly
only 11 more to go
i think yes
karaoke time
i'm kidding
in the arms of an angel
that song is too high in the someone to
ruben it says in the bible to only think
about what's pure and lovely so i've
been thinking about you all day long at
least one hour
ah
question for pearl some contraceptives
like the pill don't stop fertilization
it only stops the womb being receptive
to a fertilized egg if you think life
begins at conception then how are you
okay with that
guys i don't
know plan b's and like other types of
contraception confuse me because i'll
talk to some people and they'll be like
no it's not
an abortion that other people feel like
yeah it is and honestly i don't know i i
just don't get it if i'm not okay with
it if it is but i don't get it like i'm
not a science person
so
yeah if someone that like knows [__] and
there's like a doctor wants to like
explain this to me but i've goo i've
looked up youtube videos and like i've
googled it and stuff but like
there's i'll get conflicting
bounces
hold on real quick
pearl where's your other phone at
um i don't know why
um is it charged
um i don't know why i was going to
create a google number
oh google number oh yeah
send us food
uber eats us food we're hungry too
she said we'll send daddy
yeah
have you ever had a guy
not finish on purpose on purpose
because homeboy today that came on
earlier
said he's not there on purpose i said yo
what i said
yes he was practicing i said okay
yes i've had a guy not finish on purpose
because
they wanted me to finish first before
they finish no i mean like not finished
at all on purpose
uh no never had that yeah
interesting because i think i was
reading or i think i was having a
conversation with paul i don't know who
it was but they were saying that there
are certain guys no
i was um
i think it was unethical
reddits reddit threads unethical things
to do and they were saying like don't
finish
on purpose and it will [__] with a girl
and i was like that is so wrong
i can't believe it
ellie what's good
i'll drop some ice
what's up
someone said told jess to answer
uh
her dms
just answer your dms my phone da
you're a chocolate actually i don't know
who sent that my phone is defoe there
there's no way
it's
it's green i don't see nothing just
kidding other than something else
does the atom um
do like can i get an app on my ipad and
i tried to find it i couldn't find it
yeah
i can hear my friends yeah
that'd be
ideal you out all right calling me i
woke you up
it was nice meeting you sir get home
safe
all right
portugal
all right while we're we're waiting
should we have
what shall we do guys what shall we do
what should we do
i was gonna do a calling but i don't
have
we don't have another phone right now
what does sarah say y'all always saying
sarah
sorry let's cap
i have
chili freeman i have no clue what dm
you're talking about
i'm about to do it
just us and jess
yeah have a good creeping i'm kidding
just the two of us
we can make it if we try
just the two the ones
just the two of us
my karaoke partner
yes bye
blessings dropping in the chat
oh your wife has to be red pill to be
married just give us update about the
guy from all my days
still my friend
um
yeah that's the update still my friend
last live he said he was going to come
out here in september i knew
i knew it wasn't going to be a thing
because i just know him
um but yeah so my friend
nothing
nothing has
uh
changed pro will be back
she is she stepped away for a second
uh
i can't i can't do that sarah
cause i don't have my state number
oh do you have oh you have your
your um other
phone here don't you
okay
yeah
auntie went home y'all well the
questions y'all got for me
the sister wife thing
we just
where
question mark
how much are your nails
um
i get my nails done every so often so
probably
40 pounds
i think
sarah no need to call that out look here
sir you're not here so you have
nothing to say about tiredness you're
supposed to be right here tired with
this
but all i hear is excuses sarah
i'm working life is laughing no i'm
kidding
but it is i am staying strong sarah what
do you think of the nurse oh my gosh
doug
that
so for people who don't know i'm from
california and there was a really really
bad
um
accident out there
and doug just asked me what did i think
of
the accident and that accident was crazy
doug
like
i watched it i the thing is
i know that that road can be
dangerous um
because i've driven down that road
before and it's just like i go up and
then it's a steep hill down and so to
see her flying i was like
my goodness
it was crazy
yeah sorry you missed out
you missed out this would be the only
time you'd get to sleep with me and
pearl on the couch
but you missed your chance you missed
your opportunity
we've been live for
how long now ish have we been live
almost 14 hours almost 14 hours
oh is that what she was doing
doug
what is a cali girl doing in london i've
always wanted to come over here
and i had the opportunity to and so
i hopped on the first
flight out of there and i'm studying
sports psychology and i played
basketball yeah
uh windsor hill
the audio made it worse what happened
and someone said the audio made the push
oh and the accident yeah
marco
i'm i'm so happy
no someone's name is marco marco i'm so
happy
i'm so happy
stop it
stop saying his name
i'm so happy you slept in three times
get some sleep for us please
no i haven't seen that doug
you know
okay is it charged
yeah okay give it to oh no just kidding
i need to make
your google number
[Music]
have the spoon in it
yeah that's mine
it's just cookie dough
uh
boys google.com
okay nicole milano
jess i don't care what people say
oh thanks
thanks for shouting that out i
appreciate it
y'all are funny
um the topic of my dissertation
is
researching the effect of a physical
activity
researching the effect that physical
activity has on
adolescents
in
psych wards that have mental health
mental health issues
number one
your favorite sibling and your mother is
in the journal
just you're no longer number one
blessing number one
as long as she calls me mom i'm number
one just would switch if you switch your
religion if you met a guy
how did you no
i wouldn't oh am i unsure
no you're not oh
take him out
she's jealous don't worry about that nah
do you want me and is
or do you just want me hey
you just want me
we all want jess in the shop
come on
but you guys are gonna have to suffer
with me in it is what it is do you want
me to love you oh they're gonna i'm i
forget to still they got jess they got
me a camera
and that's not the camera they didn't
get you a camera i didn't need a camera
because i was on this side
yeah that's how i know i'm not even
second who was here who was here first
oh it was you you've been here from the
jump i've been here from the jibbedy
jump responded all right
that makes our first episode so much
more special i know
just rape people's instagram account
curious what you think smash your pass
am
not volunteering mine
that's long oh special pulse
sarah you're supposed to just say me
sorry my g what'd he say he said jess
and ish oh je oh no
just kidding sorry sorry sarah okay it
says your favorite sibling and your
mother is in a burning building you can
only save one who you saving
i know your favorite sibling and your
mother is in a burning building
you're her mother
so in your life
so that's my life oh kick me to my
favorite sibling i'm a mother i bet no
you already answered you already
answered i don't know what you well jess
what's going on you're gonna kick me to
the curb
hey i'm i'm getting my sister caller
i'm guessing i'll probably get my
brother
yeah
i shouldn't have answered that
love my mom i love my mom to dad i love
him i'll be that but mom you've lived
an amazing life yeah you know i'm just
so irritated
it really does sarah
don't you dare
i'm gonna irritate if there
raft between me and my sister and i had
to give it to her
like i would she's a kid
i might just be irritated like my god
um where's your
she's always joking about wanting to die
there's no need to get the the other
chairs if
if it's just just they want to see
jesse's face you know what i'm saying
someone said 500k the next 24-hour live
stream courtesy of
the jess
what's happening in that 500k nothing
no you don't promise something uh who
promised i promise
they'll pull it up they'll pull it up on
stream and i think it was you who said
it
sitting in that exact spot it wasn't me
there's a lot of hostility in your voice
and
once we got 70 000 subs in the last
month
sarah said at 500k everybody plays truth
or dare sorry you're here for that so
things he can't commit to
true foreign
we can't do it pearl it's not supported
here
guys
wrote to half a million
we've started it
look at you
i said right to half a million you're
you're advertising it now yeah that's
what i said wrote to half a million like
i don't know what you said well you're
advertising
go subscribe try to play a video like
you said
through the headphones
so this is what it looks like no it's
not christmas yet oh
what's everyone's favorite christmas
song
mine what's your favorite christmas song
ish
we wish you a merry christmas and a
happy new year
whack the basic
mine is uh
um
that can call the christmas song
does anyone know that it is or is just
just making up words no chestnuts
roasting i don't know
yeah i can't hear it i can hear it i can
hear it really i can't
well i can hear something
you can't hear it i can hear it why
can't pearl here i can hear it
i can't hear it i'm not not well but i
can hear it everyone quiet
i can barely hear it
[Music]
is
last christmas i gave you my heart and
the very next name you give it away
use me
to save me from
[Music]
y'all know the business y'all know what
it is
matt king cole
we should do a christmas party
make sense
oh yeah and that place i would decorate
it
yeah this is why i brought her
oh my god we can hear it it's a bit
muffled right now but yeah it's not loud
it's getting a bit louder than it was
best hoop game
it's just muffled yeah um
actually
i would say it was here a
close to a double double
and like
three four blocks
well
you an elite shot stopper yeah oh that's
the one thing i will say yes chase down
noise oh yeah um room protector oh yeah
all right
all right guys we want somebody so loud
with my headphones is it super loud for
you the video no like my headphones
no just the headphones i can barely hear
the video but the headphones were like
sorry you ain't said number two baby
yeah no the headphones did go up but i
think you like have a master on your
headphones like
next time you come sorry bring your hoop
shoes
actually not next time because
yeah i can't i just won't play because
one time we invited jess to play
she never came
didn't we paul oh yeah yeah like yeah
we we actually moved she was a flake
yeah
we were actually disappointed yeah i
thought just just be giving all this
talk about how she plays and how she
good but
[Music]
no you didn't actually
i did all right paul came i said oh
where's jess oh she's not coming oh okay
that's what i got
i didn't even you didn't even tell me
you were coming
oh i just i organized this game
pokemon pulled out of all you invited
pokemon
yeah
if you really wanted us to come you
would have been like hey yo
we have a scrimmage every week
this is the week you guys are oh hello
that got really loud
this is god yep my headphones coming off
um
if you would have planned for us to be
there be like hey we got you down as a
number but you told us last minute so
paul was just talking about we all know
as ballers you get told to come through
bring your trainers you're comfortable
yeah that's not how we're doing she
lives next door to the place i mean i
tend to give people a heads up but you
know yeah exactly that's not how we do
it in l.a don't give it
that's not how we do it at least i swear
it was like two days heads up nah it was
last minute for two days last minute
day off now yeah i like the video guys
like it up like it up plug it up like it
up oh it might have been day off yeah
no no it was the day before because we
had a show that night and i said oh guys
girl's got scrimmage and you're like
yeah come and come in no sure jess what
are you gonna do
when i'm in the in the in um
the apartment next year doing my coffee
thoughts
i'm gonna have to do it in the kitchen
i'm just letting you know
okay
dude
trust me in the morning
i do my own thing so this is long it's
like noon for me yeah i know so i'll be
i'll probably be up in politics
oh yeah the same could be said of uh
bertrand russell and his and can we put
the volume down landmark works on
mathematics and other people in other
fields i can hear loud and clear though
and when you step outside your level of
uh specialty sometimes that's like can
the chat hear this video too
can we put the volume down that
intellectuals that is to say people
whose end product is ideas huh should
succumb to that ellie that the dog's
name is
for doing absolutely nothing more than
winning chess tournaments
and making
displays as many of them do of playing
uh five chess games uh simultaneously
while blindfolded that's not bad uh so
bobby fischer had no need to opine on
the politics of the day so because he
was so they can hear the video too
famous yeah
would you be able to hook this up to a
tv he's one of the world's authorities
on iq and the new place there's a tv we
can hook it up too people you know in
india know about jim flynn people in
england he made a world tour
hey john gonzalez
thanks for becoming a member um you
should go learn what he did
so you know how to do it it is fairy
i'll have to let him finish though
because oh is that done
um
oh the air through is that all done
can i come
guys i'll be back soon oh my tummy
it hurts i need food
oh here you can order food i'll get you
guys food okay
hey
someone said can you hire me please i
can be your chair
pearl if you ever got to that point
where you were hiring people just to sit
down i'd be like pearl has made it
i wouldn't spend money on that
no someone would pay you
like the thing i gave you earlier the
splitter the one that was just up there
there was one up there so i like the
split about just normal
no not the trs one because these ones
are like the earphones one yeah but
because the other side so i know
that means they want you to sit on their
face what
yo
we are in
where's everyone from put in the chat
where you're from
brian which was gracias
i couldn't remember danny
for coming becoming a member
yo
read between the lines
zara look if you gonna send this man you
must not be working that har sarah if
you send in things in the chat
el paso texas tejas las vegas portugal
canada
westchester new york
h town
honduras
phoenix quebec
philly puerto rico
fly them out
uh mark
fly them out and they'll help you with
the technical stuff
atlanta new jersey atlanta canada
new york city new york sydney oh buffalo
bermuda
sarah sarasota
egypt wow
chile
zimbabwe we have a zoom in here
what do you think okay what do you think
what'd you think of the freaking live
today
yo you guys can see our post thoughts yo
it was uh it was interesting
oh no the
the group the preaching show
it was interesting because
you ever notice how girls like you say
something when they make it about them
i'm like i don't know you i wasn't
talking about you yeah
i've i noticed that about people and
i've noticed that like just throughout
my life
with friends and whatnot and it's just
like i brush over it and i'm in my head
i'm like i wasn't talking about you but
you clearly don't understand that so and
if i try to explain to you you're still
not going to understand it because
obviously if you knew i wasn't talking
about you from jump you wouldn't be
saying the stuff that you're saying
right now
and
it was just interesting to see excuse me
it was interesting to see
just the reactions to certain things and
the
how they would how people would say it
they would say their things and they
would
hear other people react but they weren't
listening it's like people weren't
listening and so they say their thing
and they already have their reaction in
their head so uh the other person is
saying they're not listening to what
they're saying so when they say their
reaction
it doesn't even make sense to what the
person would say and it like would help
them understand it better
so it was just like
yo just listen please
just listen
and it's like
okay um
and i
i said this to
the one on the couch
i was like yeah that may be the
exception that may be a minute
thing
and
like i don't mind if you if you don't do
it intentionally yeah but it's like when
you when you've done it like four times
in a row i'm like shut the f this isn't
your show yeah when you were i was out
there and i saw your hand going
somewhere
oh yeah someone's talking and then
they'll be like well you interrupted and
i'm like because it's my show i can
literally you can interrupt anybody you
want
because some of y'all i have to
interrupt because you go on tangents
like
i will let we'll let you talk i give
people a lot of air time question
if i'm
if i'm talking yeah and i'm uh
giving a point blah blah blah and i
pause for a long amount of time
what is your natural reaction
you're done talking
that's all why
that's all
no
what
oh
do you not do not understand why i asked
you that
i didn't know him
because
the one that was sitting on the other
side of the couch she was talking
and she would pause
and it it felt like she wanted other
people to react and then she kept saying
i'm not finished
and i'm like no it was like a power play
because she was mad that i told her to
shut up
that's what she was like she was
triggered so like she wanted to do it
back it was like a power play i'm asleep
yeah like that's that's why like because
like they're both pretty girls and like
pretty girls have gone through life and
they've never
they've never gotten a push back for
anything because they're pretty girls
i couldn't believe she was 35 though
yeah she said thirty-five she's out i
said wow i said you look a lot younger
than 35 but
i thought she looked like late i thought
like 28 to 30. yeah that's that's that's
accurate i just didn't think that i had
30. if i was like
how many of those
she looks so fine i was like i'll give
you 30.
five years younger like you should
still
i'm like you don't look 22 like sure i
just i mean it's not i'm not saying
you're not attractive like you're
reckoning she had a kid
you think she can't no no i don't know
oh no she did say that she um
she was
alluding to the idea that it wasn't on
her cards or it wasn't something she was
doing but what happens is girls
they want kids and then they don't find
the guy they want to have kids with yeah
and then they pretend they don't want
kids but they want kids
because if they were barren tomorrow
they'd be devastated
[Music]
what i don't understand is why when
people are arguing or
arguing a point they go to the extreme
where it's like
those are a rare case and you go to the
extreme to make a point
and it's like do you realize that that
may happen one in every million people
and that's going to be your argument
point like
what is that
that doesn't make sense
jesus
arguing exceptions to rule can allow you
to win an argument in most scenarios
you know with stupid people yeah that's
something yeah
and it's only when you call it out then
it's it can't be argued because you've
i'm starting to get better at like
calling people's arguments out when i'm
like um shame and solid guilt need to be
like because that's what they do
yeah when they'll be like i'm not
shaming men i'm like you you literally
just did
like
when you say things like oh
i don't know what she said there's
something with shaming men for liking
younger women i'm like like anyone with
that mentality and i'm like yeah
she didn't talk to me and it's just like
well like you're implying you're better
than them
i mean i don't know what you guys were
arguing i forgot what earlier
yeah you came and stopped sitting yeah i
just i just remember it's like
it's like
was it between like a cow and an anima a
baby yeah he said something wild so i
tried to put him in his face i'm glad
you stopped yeah i was just no i was
just like okay no no
no we're not arguing about this he was
cool though though i'm excited about the
book i hope i get it
yeah
so here's my question
you questioned something and i thought
that was really really relevant but then
after that you're just excited about the
book um
you said
you questioned what it was about and
then you realized it was like it was
four kids but then
in the context of what he was talking
about it didn't seem like the themes
should have been for kids after you read
it you felt a bit more
i don't know if that was i don't know i
was because it it seemed like dark
it was just
informative but then he said it was for
kids and i was like
well it just depends how we do it i'd
have to see but
um
his wife was so sweet actually he was i
was like you're a little sweetheart
she really was
yeah
i'm a nude
would it go against your nature to
settle for a man that can't measure up
to your father
no
would it would it
would it go up against your nature i
would say yeah
wait read that again like i do i think
it goes
depending on who your father is to you i
think he's talking about me
oh yeah yeah
i'm sorry no i'm saying like
i think it does go against your nature i
do compare guys to my dad
so it's unfortunate because my dad is
really great
um
so yeah no i always compare guys to my
dad
um probably doesn't help me
oh my days
it's getting hot in here
so take off all your clothes i am
getting so high i wanna take my clothes
off
you're gonna keep going
it's getting hot in here take off all
your clothes i am getting so hot i'm
gonna take my clothes
a little bit
and a little bit
and like
and i like
[Music]
you can rap word for word motto
let's go
come on i can't do it without the music
everyday every day and we're [__] on
the kids i don't really play everyday
everyday
motto or what's another one
uh nobody [__] with me first degree
murder you can get your degree
[__] and you ain't gotta wonder
about me wonder woman team going paul
money tall paul bunyan real [__]
what song is that
um
sorry for the weight little man
do you pound good money everybody
go ahead go ahead go off go uptown new
york city [__]
got my spanish girl let me like
no but but my spanish girls love me like
i'm on a corner
come out man me too tell them uh club my
heart eliminate much to do yeah it's so
hard to do without the beast
tell me feel how you feel how you feel i
got 25 sitting on 25 million i'm in the
middle and i'm feeling myself resting
peak mac dre i'm gonna do it for the bay
okay getting paid
shout out to the
[Music]
how you feel that's really how you feel
in the pimp a nice cold and you just
want to chill and me and maybe she won't
then again maybe she will i can already
guarantee she know the deal real what's
up
oh no you don't really know though you
only live once
every day every day every day every day
every day every day but when anybody say
can't see him because the money in the
red room what's up huh
one time one time i'm caught [__] i
think me and she's got to do a thing
again seven
grand
almost drowned in the [__] so i swam to
her butt
east
go down
[Music]
driving me crazy
to tell me that you hate me
that you won't leave lately
baby i don't
know
why i'm so emotional
i feel like i'm losing control
now i know
baby
baby is come on
i'm passing it
come on i know you can
we just
said
i'm playing all right
i just did a beat
we setting something up okay sorry sorry
i'm a little nervous it'll get picked up
by copyright i'm a little nervous
[Music]
that was off the dome i'm so talented
sometimes
look
i know that you're talking to other
girls
i know that you're promising them the
world
[Music]
always losing control
what do we do now i know
[Music]
okay
i'm from
chicago
i'm from the city my man
i don't think you really
[Music]
understand
where i'm from yeah
we run
oh wait wait for what what are you
talking about
eight four seven
[Music]
what are you talking for what
oh
baby the comment section is driving me
crazy
they tell me that they hate me
oh
they told me that they hate me tell me
that you hate me
i know where naperville is
she totally ripped off my song and
composed what
[Music]
give me give me something to write about
give me something to sing about chat
give me something to sing about
[Music]
three or four
these girls there at the club
yeah they're on a couple drugs
they're chasing a couple thugs
and
undercover
and you've sung from
so they're in the club what do they do
next okay okay
a couple shots there at the bar
[Music]
talking to a boy it goes too far
and he's got a brand new car
and he's damaged got a couple scars and
the red flags looking real green right
now
taking me back to his place somehow
and then everything it goes down but i
got a boyfriend and he's downtown yeah
oh
i'm remembering ooh
remember
[Music]
only fans girls okay okay
okay three or four us
i'm a three or four to call me a hoe
all the boys say i'm emotional
and they say that get down i know but i
shouldn't be
swearing hold on
[Music]
okay yeah i got an only fans but baby
please it was just one time my friend
baby can you please understand i'm a new
woman now yeah i'm so different and he
slams the door and goes out
oh it's gonna end oh wait no
wait
okay wait give me give me something else
that one didn't flow that one didn't
flow give me another one
okay wait sing about where you want to
be in five to 10 years
[Music]
the shot's outside the club give me give
me another one give me another
[Music]
boop give me give me
family portrait pink
no not someone else's song
calm down sing at your place
give me give me give me another give me
something else
[Music]
did you say something okay
hold on i wanna okay
delusional simps okay hold on
delusional steps let me pick a new beat
it's about to switch let's see the next
one that comes on if i like it
[Music]
playback pause because your account is
being used in another location
what
okay
[Music]
okay what's the chat say
lonely feminist
[Music]
okay so what do the lovely feminists do
yeah i'm drinking a glass of wine
by myself i'm taking my time
i got a dog and a cat that's fine but
i'm lonely all the goddamn time
and yeah i got two ex-boyfriends
and yeah maybe i
left them
but now i'm 30 times running out and i'm
alone in a big ass house
okay give me another one
it's echoing on my headphones
i don't know if it should be or not
[Music]
this would be
okay okay
sing about boxed wines and cats
okay
it's 2 a.m on a saturday
and i'm alone with my cats today
some box wine yeah it's today
[Music]
i got i got it okay
and i got two girl best friends
none of us got a man damn
oh land whales land whales
[Music]
hmm
lamb oh
wait where's the speed
put
the fork down
[Music]
land they will see how to avoid how to
handle how to survive
how to
whales and fails
okay
lamb whales how would i do that okay
[Music]
oh [__] there's a whale sighting
a big [__] that's what i see
and yeah that [__] eyes on me oh [__] i
think she's about to swing
because i'm skinny and pretty she's not
she's just a big ass thought but nobody
wants to hit that no more
cause she's not even a four
[Music]
oh she can't fit through yeah we can do
that in a sec we can do that next
[Music]
okay give me give me something else in
the chat
we want more whales fine fine fine fine
someone have a good bar
that [__] at three can't you see i walk
into the club all eyes on me
because she's so ugly
sing about a girl in her eighth abortion
eight jesus that's a [__] ton
if a boy sees you he better run
[__] you should have stopped at one
boom
[Music]
there's a possibility we would get like
striked
oh i know we might
why
because of the music oh
yeah
i was like i said
we've got we're far gone we're on a
livestream there's not much we can do
now
yeah you can always just cut it later
oh yeah yeah you just cut it later
are you dying jess yet oh i've been
dying
neo nap i show peter on the couch man
i'll see you at like 6 a.m
if someone wants to come join me ellie
stop licking me ellie was coming to join
you what not
ellie back up please i need your lips
you know what they say
hatred is another form of love i know
she's kicking you but really she love
you
okay she's just saying what
no no if someone calls from america yes
i was thinking
it doesn't matter why we get judged
us
you're so good charge i don't mean that
sense
um
we're on a free trial on an app oh
oh that's good second number oh i i
thought it was just a regular on here
or on your you just give it up that's
why i was like you'll get charged is
that how um that's how phone works
yeah i put a price cap in my tank
can you imagine i said can you get me
guesses tonight she goes oh she's
texting me now two
two
who
was meant to go to an event after this
um yeah i asked the guest list and then
she was like well she's kind of going
for me now but i'm not good
good
no you're worth king
thank you paul
glad it fell through
don't worry thank you
ellie has water guys
i couldn't
oh my gosh i was gonna figure out why
there's water on the floor my room was
like did she pee but then i realized it
was like where her bowl was
oh is it is it skinny fat
she's not skinny fat
that's true she's
a little lean
okay
and you know how would we do this with
the reactions because i can't see the
screen from here
but i can hear it through the headphones
can you play it on
on that
on this can you switch the screens are
you able to
no
just look what we can but it counted up
now yeah
yeah i think when you have the tv there
though yeah yeah
um
we could do
i was thinking we could switch
the
camera and sit on chairs so we can like
see it there but then we don't have the
headphones
[Music]
i guess we could just listen
need to move so we can set up a better
setup um is it might be possible
could you put the camera on car please
oh no because there's two hdmi cables
on this one yeah i know yeah so i
wouldn't be able to does does it
just make it
out
oh we don't even have this little we
don't even have a spill because yeah
you have to come from here yes
and go
hdmi split off not that sounds tasty am
i split up you take a look
taking a piss bruh
all right all right
yeah thank you
massage the man's ego
let's massage the man's ego
guys what are your favorite moments
what are your favorite moments from the
shows
yeah from the show
actually my favorite was
the first video we did that like took
off because now i someone expect to go
viral but it was like a different high
the first video me and you did yeah it
went like
they said
yeah it's like that was like when i lost
my youtube virginity yeah i mean i guess
i did on music reactions but that that
was more viral than that mm-hmm
um my favorite moment
there's so many
um
[Music]
probably auntie i literally was sitting
here and i felt like that was so funny i
feel like i was meeting a famous person
i was just saying i was like ah it's
auntie she's just great and just
i'm like if uh
if auntie can go through all the stuff
that she went through
not saying like the years that she went
through
and just understand how simple it is
why is it so difficult for women
nowadays to understand it
andy like my man said he want he want a
little sunshine i give it to him
i feel like if you're dating if you're
dating like you should be sex on demand
i don't understand that's not
also guys join our memberships
yes
if you want to see our
new place
new studio yeah sign up for membership
some behind the scenes action you know
look
we've been holding out
these last
you've been holding out these last few
months
once we move
i'll be excuse me i'll be done with
school
and so
there'll be more things coming out plus
you can do a one-on-one call with us
once a month
this mess is so freaking itchy
on our fourth tier membership we you'd
be the first ones you'd be like first
priority yeah
ellie man
back up
ellie baby put the block under pressure
oh now you wanna now you wanna
freestyle
now you wanna freestyle i'm using other
people's bars i can't
i can't put that out i mean you can no
especially it's like my favorite wrap up
pot of paper
you hear me
what
i was just going to ignore it
nah
i'll let you know
and from the ends
guys let me know in the chat what's your
favorite moment from the show who's been
here since the beginning was anyone on
here i'm not going to believe you all
because there's only like 20 people but
who's on here for a show who's on here
for a show
there's 20 people
know that like watched first show like
it wasn't very many people
someone said jessica versus auntie
yo that would be bold
i'll die on it auntie said would you he
hasn't finished i will keep going till i
die on it i said i respect you i'm like
you are
you are inspirational
i once had a girl sign like that
fumble the bag
is what it is though we move
she's still in your head though no
really because you brought her out
yeah i mean she's still winning she's
still winning girl he's still winning he
fall he knows he messed up take him back
nah if i'm in the back i'm good
when we move
if she was still winning or the holiday
time ago
we never went
we never go back king never go back you
know what we could do what's up
can you see that monitor right there
someone said in all caps please pearl
take care of your bulldog and take care
of her checkups at the vet actually
she's due for a checkup you know we'll
go once a year
to go because i came here in october
last year
um
i was confused what would you put the
time stamps in the description i was
very confused earlier
you gave me numbers and i just put the
numbers yeah but i wasn't i was telling
the people in the chat not you
oh i thought you were telling
me i was i
i didn't say that i was really i didn't
know what you were like doing with the
numbers
like so you just i was just saying in
the chat
and then later i'm like why are all
these numbers in the description we can
delete them like yes
i thought i thought the time stamps were
there so that people could
reference them
and then when you said oh
when the video started working i
understood i was like oh we don't need
type steps anymore because people just
be able to
[__]
i'm so glad i got that window captured
to start working
i didn't understand what you meant when
you were talking about the sound because
i'd never done window capture before
yeah
and then i didn't because usually when
that happens right they it starts
echoing so i was like
oh it's not gonna work
but then
it worked
happy days
blessing
so you've done this for how long
um
i thought you said you've been doing it
since he was like a kid no no no i said
like 2016. i thought i thought five
years
oh all right yeah wait what did you
start with audio
okay
if you're like audio guy
now you're a video guy
soon to be a concert guy
festival guy
wireless hit up my boy
yes
media
yeah why common to change the game just
saying no i went to wireless this year
yeah everybody was like it's for little
kids i had a ball
oh god i went
the ninth
in finsbury park oh oh did you get to go
to the amma piano tent
no i know i don't know i'm a piano is
there any way i could put it so we can
hear it through the headphones
pause it and see the screen
is this possible
um
possibly tonight
let me know if you think it's impossible
it's okay
[Music]
we do have a longer hdmi cable
then we would see the screen on that one
can we do that
and then flip it and then we ingest
guys look at it
i know i've gained some comments lately
that i'm too aggressive
i i honestly think i'm very patient
and
sometimes people are rude they come on
it's like because people think they're
coming on to the the show and it's like
a normal conversation
but it's a show
you see yeah anyways
someone's been on here for nine hours
and 18 minutes thank you guys
guys
there's 400 500 of you in here sending
her memberships y'all
five dollars okay what would you guys
what would you guys need from the
memberships
to sign up if you haven't signed up why
why don't
why don't you yeah why why don't you why
haven't you
yeah let me what do we got to offer you
just do it
do it
have you seen that shia labeouf video
where he's like on a green screen he's
like just do it
because
gotta we know we tell them the rules
before the show
[Music]
i'm broke okay fair but it's like five
bucks a month though it's not it's not
make discord
open for all and i'm why would you join
it if the discord was free
is my question also they're saying the
link still doesn't work i don't i tested
it the other day in your world
um i'm a keeper 100 with y'all
if there's someone
in the chat
that can give me
a
head to toe run run down
run down of discord please dm me because
i understand it but don't at the same
time
dm me
and
we will
we'll get on a call and you can just
help me out with
everything
that is discord
oh we got one more another just pearly
things member thank you thanks ace um
okay if it's my show isn't an argument
you wouldn't have a show without the
guests and they wouldn't be on the same
respect as you yeah but you don't
overtalk the host so
look at it
i should you're right i shouldn't say
it's my show i should say stop over
talking me i watched a youtube video and
it didn't teach me
what didn't someone said youtube would
teach you you think i didn't try that
oh my knee jesus
yay
grover
and some
someone said only fans
is she another one wow are you sick or
are you a woman
base
all right i was going to move next to
jess in a second
because i think that'd be better
unless you you think it yeah you guys
are pretty sure tell me where to start
[Music]
i haven't joined because i don't like
being in groups that was standards low
enough to accept me
because they said get rid of members
only chat look i'm sorry this is a
business sometimes it's going to be
members only you want to be in the chat
become a member yeah it's not
i don't work for free respectfully i
love you love you guys it's not personal
um but it's five bucks a month it's
really not
10 miles you're running ten miles have
fun
what's your mile pace
seven
eight eight
six thirty
oh you're so smart
okay
aaron your mile pace
can you shout me out do you guys like
the
member of the week is that is that fun
to you
for real tell us what you guys want for
memberships yeah
what about reacting to videos members
only videos but we react to the videos
in our bikinis
i'm just playing
i'm just playing yo i thought someone
put in um
in the
the community post
for members what some like things we
could do and someone was saying like
reddit stories like red pill relation
reddit stories to read them on screen
and to like get our reaction from those
stories yeah so it's kind of like this
is your story another member no
thank you you guys if you're gonna do
the five you should do the ten because
our vlogs are fire and that's under the
ten dollar
yeah and i'm telling you
when once we move
it's gonna be a different a different
ball game you won't see us sweating in
here anymore yeah
we're just gonna it's just gonna
i think it's gonna be game changer
i i feel like this show is gonna be and
especially with the updates i have with
like recruiting like i think
i understand recruiting now yeah
i think it's going to be a really game
changer
you are not getting too aggressive
you're holding women accountable
i'm a public
lecturer you are doing a very good job
that's jonathan okay it says first level
it says first level doesn't even get you
anything okay it's then tell me what you
want from me you get the members only
chat right now and
you know you might say that's nothing
what do you to be fair it's only five
bucks a month thanks aaron but i
appreciate all numbers so i just want to
know what what do you guys want what's
the most
yeah cause we're gonna watch wow the
savvy ninja gifted five just pearly
thing memberships thanks savvy ninjas
there's another mouse over there if you
want to steal it from the other computer
yeah i'll tell him thank you gifted wow
yeah
the savvy ninja wow
we love the generosity
where do i get a hold of you to give you
um oh
my instagram name
thanks one regan one my instagram name
is your girl justly you guys i changed
it
it's just your girl justly it's simpler
now
i did
that's easy to remember i like this yeah
it's not it's
dot yeah dot
you should girl
your youtube too
i like it's your girl jess oh wait oh
that one doesn't have the it doesn't
have the dots okay you're good you're
good
um it says i'll sign up if you do a
fresh and fit collab with the chesca
yeah they they love me there um
they are pearl's number one fan yeah
they are dying to have me on but i was
just super
super busy
jessica um was
you guys bullied her she doesn't want to
come back
low-key i think that's the onslaught
um
if you find me
um just dm me
and
we'll get a run down next week
more convos with feminists
that's coming through i think we figured
out recruiting
i hope anyways i think i think this is
gay joe rogan on your show okay i can't
i wonder let's ask the chat
what um
if pearl did like a
a states tour of um
of the show
what cities would you want her to
hit you could look at the most
popular cities from the mm-hmm go to
miami look at my analytics it tells you
where everyone lives yeah pearl
pearl i've been watching you even from
before you've done the pre-game and i
was planning on it you have come along
right way wow oh
the for the person that said can i have
my own show i'm gonna start doing like
more reaction videos um
it's just right now i have to move [__]
to put
sorry if you don't want me on the screen
what are you you're going to be in them
too
can't get rid of me you don't like it
oh well someone said lay dallas portland
miami
atlanta
yeah that's my soda
yo andrew tate has been telling me he's
gonna come on my podcast since march
so go bother him tell him to come on my
show but
yeah he been telling me this
australia melbourne
get my second win
thanks making shane
been feeding the dog all all night trust
me she's
she's been yeah she's fine
what else what do you guys want to see
from memberships yeah i'm trying to i'm
trying to make memberships
you know we're trying to spice it up
change it up a little bit
so it's worth your while
to be you know youtube premium is only
10 bucks a month
okay look the reason
it's simply too awesome thanks i
understand upgrading i understand i'm
competing
i'll become a permanent member if you
give the dog a treat once a show
[Music]
i had an energy drink guys get my second
wind
and i'm starting to i'm starting to get
hot again
oh we can open the door we can turn off
the mosquito i know
already got so many mosquitoes running
around here
um can you sell me the benefits wait did
you say people could call in
wait wait p4gy if you want to go to my
instagram dm me i'll literally tell me
why i should do an open discord server
i'll put you on my phone
what do you mean by open like to
everybody
i'll become a member if you don't
we have another woman in the chat
why is pearl not married is it because
the men she wants
they don't want her yeah true i'm trying
to be what they want though
yeah yeah i'm trying to learn to cook
you'll see wife school is coming
why school is coming
so okay so i asked the members
um like what
um what could we do to make them feel
more um appreciated
and some of them were like
don't focus on us just focus on your
content we're here for like
you and your content like we appreciate
so you don't gotta tell me twice yeah
and i was like okay and some were like
uh i forgot what they said but a lot of
them were like we like your content
that's why we're here that's why we
subscribed and that's why we became a
member
oh so
love y'all
auntie's gonna run guys i have so much
con when we get this move done
let me get this move done
it's about to
be
changing
[Music]
i am in for several discords including
tribe
[Music]
oh
yes
um
the logic i can't i don't know how to
say his name
yeah
we shall talk
i have you down
and we shall talk all right
time may change me
um
yep
here you go
okay
um
i was singing uh
burn a boy last last
i don't know the words after that
oh there's a red pill let's finish that
the red pill
like cassie something
i don't think you are rude at all in
fact you're really good at communicating
with guests
the only thing i would say is calling
women
land whales
i'm sorry i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
stop calling them whales
if it looks like
if it looks like a whale
it smells like a whale
it has blubber like a whale that is a
whale
i'm sorry it's not rude i just call it
what it is whale anyways
marobe thank you for becoming a member
i guess so
all right
that's fine
guys we're finishing with cassie j
documentary when something takes care of
me
in a daze
you look so happy
suddenly
[Music]
suddenly i suddenly i see this is what i
wanna be suddenly i see
you're not gonna know this
she got the best of me she
don't know
don't do country
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i hear it in my head i can't sing it
got me every time oh that obviously
you're thinking a different song
yeah
pick another one i know he wasn't
talking to you but
one
side
only fools
um i don't know the rest of it i
can't help
falling in love with you
um it sounds like i'm in a tunnel
according to the chat because what about
now
turn pearls mic turn turn pros micah
give me another song
i'm trying to think of a
my mic is off apparently now let's see
let's wait
please
okay let's let me
[Music]
okay oh they can't even see us
oh
that should not happen
you should say window
[Music]
and
but it's the season of the sticks but i
know you're my
oh i heard a song
the other day in co-op uh
by amy winehouse one of my favorite
songs
sometimes i go out by myself
you know a song
okay i got another one um that's not the
part
uh what do you call it um i go out by
myself
and i look across the water oh i do know
that song
i look across the water
right right making up words
in my head i paint a picture
i want to come on over
stop
[Music]
i like amy winehouse
can you wait can you zoom in on can i
see the what the shot looks like because
i think i wanted it more zoomed in and
the reaction so you could see our faces
a little more
it's like that oh no because
it has to be in between us
i appreciate your platform random shout
outs if i
pop out okay let me see enough for me
pearl you're lovely
shaheen said
he's a new member thanks shaheed
get you
okay this person offered to work for
free
and then we're like okay we need this
done they're like
well what am i getting paid i'm like why
would you offer to work for free if you
don't want to work for free
how late is your stream
okay
sorry
it's working now my bad
um
how does that song go wait
and she got me on the counter it wasn't
me saw me banging on the sofa it wasn't
me even had her in the shower it wasn't
me even got it on camera it wasn't me
saw the marks on my shoulder it wasn't
me see the words that i told her it
wasn't me and the scream's getting
louder it wasn't me
i don't know the next one
and i told her it was over oh
call me button and
[Applause]
there's a
[Music]
let the man let the man get perfection
don't don't let him talk you down chase
excellence oh only you by 112 doug
doug you're the best i'm not rushed
right now we got 12 hours
jesus the notorious just please us with
your lyrical thesis welcome
i got no problem with you calling them
whales if it happens throughout the
normal conversation it seems like you
went on your way to call them that and
it crosses over as you being
mean-spirited
it might that's a risk i'm willing to
take to go whale hunting
i need you in my life
where do i go
what must i do
if i can't deal with them and die
[Laughter]
[Music]
you kind of want to finish it you kind
of want to finish it
i don't know tupac like that i know the
song but i don't
reid
oh she's real like really loud
you caught the whole reaction
[Laughter]
oh i think i always oh my headphones are
loud and hurt oh my super chat bring
back fat shaming
it might just be the headphones
did someone hold on what
jess
did read your super chat just a minute
ago
how does it feel
how does that start off oh um girl
there's only you
haven't joined oh
they said it's you you go okay no
have it your way
anything you want you
[Music]
and if you have me
and i swear
by the moon and the stars in the sky
i'll be there
in a nice way no i can't hear [__] am i
the shadow let's buy you who's that r
kelly
i'm eating it's the remix to ignition
hiding fresh out of the kitchen mama
rooted never they got everybody wishing
sipping on coke and rum i'm like so what
i'm drunk
she moved her body like a cyclone and
she makes me want to do
you switch quick it's like ah okay she
moves her body like a cyclone and she
makes me wanna do it all night
that's where his role comes from once
he's impregnated her oh grandpa she's
passed the mic to pro please faced with
continuing a promotion
that accompanied pregnancy
so
his rights have to be
uh exercised early but once because you
turn she's pregnant
uh
all decisions must be hers because
ultimately
um she is the most impacted there's just
no question and she ultimately has the
responsibility for that child
[Music]
so before we were married he promised me
we would have two kids and now he
doesn't want any more
my friends think i should trick him and
stop taking my birth control
men have never been in control of our
bodies we're the ones in control clap if
you think that she should trick him no
no
my people how would you trick him i'm
next to everybody
did you see that
wow
why was the whole room clapping
they were like yeah the two women in
front were like
i don't know
sounds like men's reproductive rights
are limited to the choice of whether or
not to have sex
and the choice
of whether or not to use protection
but what if he's tricked into fatherhood
or
what if he's not even the father
what does paternity fraud look like
it's ugly
it's extraordinary reality and we have
to distinguish paternity fraud and
wrongful paternity
what's the difference wrongful
fraternity can be innocent
okay we went to a party i had sex with
six guys i think it was when i was
hanging out the window i got pregnant
but i wasn't sure
but you know if anybody knows that guy's
name would you please have him call me
and then she names one of the other guys
and he didn't have sex with her
it wasn't malicious wasn't intentional
she wasn't trying to harm anybody
she was just trying to figure out who it
was
six guys in one night that's a lot y'all
what's she doing in these streets that's
a lot i mean at least limited to two
like at least then it's like a 50 50
shot but six
six six
and you don't know which one shout out
the club
bro okay well
i'm not going to tell you how to live
your life but you know what i might
today i i wouldn't do that
no yeah okay
wrongful paternity
more often and less facetiously
okay i'm married i had an affair
[Music]
obviously here there's all sorts of
problems because there are more victims
than the person who's named his daryl
dad who may be the wrong one
there's everybody involved in the family
like a situation in texas
where the family had five little toe
head kids all guys all little blondos
and all of a sudden one day one little
blondo kids gets in trouble has to go to
the hospital they can't get ahold of mom
they get all the dad dad wrestles the
hospital
needs to give blood
whoops
can't do it wrong blood what wow
all the kids look alike
turns out it was the guy down the street
you've heard of this case no it's a real
case
so what happens to this family
can you
fathom what happens to this
family how do you think the kids feel
when they find out daryl dad isn't daryl
daddy is the guy down the street and i
think dad feels
that these five little boys and he still
loves dearly when he finds out they're
not his bio children but he still can't
tear away bruh they should go to jail
i think a [__] who does that should
face jail time
i think she
she should have to pay some type of
compensation because that's
that's tough
jail for every year he spent raising
those kids she should put spend two in
jail make it equal
day
that was like honestly
i'm thinking like what's worse
if you raised a kid that's not yours for
three years or you went to jail for
three years and i literally think
raising a kid
is worse that's not yours because you
get attached to those kids you love
those kids like yeah that's like your
own that's worse
i'd rather go to three in jail for three
years and rate think kids like have my
whole world shattered
oh i don't i don't know and then men
have to go to jail for child support
they don't pay it so it's like
send these hoes to jail you all deserve
jail time
okay let's keep let's keep going
hey because he loves him he's devoted
himself to this how do you think he
feels
i mean it's
horrific
that's not wrongful that's deliberate
so that's paternity fraud that's
paternity fraud she knew who the father
was and lied about it
paul was right when he said trying to
understand the men's rights movement is
like trying to understand a snow drift
one snowflake at a time
there are unique father's rights issues
that vary between unmarried married and
divorced dads
but there are also men's rights issues
for non-biological fathers
[Music]
like this man who is facing jail time
for failure to pay child support for a
child that dna tests prove isn't his
carnell alexander still owes more than
thirty thousand dollars to the state for
a child that's not his because the mom
wrote his name down because she needed
to name someone
no
heck no no
so you can just
write a random name down so if i
got pregnant didn't know who the father
was i could write ronald mcdonald
i can write ronald mcdonald and then get
money from the ronald mcdonald
foundation
just because i put their that name
elon musk hey
according to this you can just put a
random name down i would put
bill gates
bill gates bro that's that's so [__]
up that's the most [__] up thing i've
ever heard what if i put down three
names like elon bill
elon bill and jesus
booyah
you can be like what
in order to get wealthy your benefits
and i had to put him down as the father
that was the only way i can get the
system i'm almost homeless i'm almost in
jail
i'm out of work
my money is being threatened to be taken
he says the law needs to be changed so
when this happens as it often does
other men don't become dad by default
[Music]
because there's no such thing as a
mother by default
like yes you're birthing it but nobody
can randomly put your name down so why
can you do that for
a random guy because they literally
don't care about men
they literally don't care
[Music]
a long
you shouldn't have stuck your dick in it
that's what they always say it's like
you had sex with him too you shouldn't
have bro
what have you been doing
also thank you for the five dollar super
chat i love how women act like this
never happened meanwhile 32 percent of
kids don't know who their real dad is is
it that high can you send me that study
if so send it on instagram
people wonder
about mris why are you guys so angry
and my answer to that is why aren't you
how can anybody look at this and not be
angered by it
and
the only answer to that i've ever been
able to come up with
is that people aren't angry because they
don't see men as human beings
[Music]
i continued traveling north america
meeting mras from all walks of life
hearing their personal stories their red
pill moments
i met a young man who was sexually
abused when he was 16 years old while
living at a residential home for people
with developmental disabilities she's
the only woman i've done anything ever
with apart because it just messed me up
so much
she continues working there
[Music]
she hit me in the face
she actually hit me throughout the house
chasing me throughout the house
when i reported my domestic assault to
the police officers i did not at all
bring up the fact that i was sexually
assaulted because if he wasn't going to
believe that i was a victim of domestic
violence there was no way he was going
to believe that i was going to be a
victim of sexual assault
i met the honey badgers
women who are men's rights advocates
[Music]
and then there was a 15 year old boy
there's a 35 year old woman and then
later on she came out of jail and she
was able to collect child support
from this boy that she raped
yeah
after getting out of jail so there's
there's lack of fairness for men in
do you hear that
35 year old woman 15 year old kid she
got child support off of him
and she did it yeah
she did it
what the
and that kid oh
oh
yo
what
you
what you have no you have no rights
after you do that to somebody and you go
to jail for it you come out you better
figure it out
you better bro she should be in in jail
forever you better figure the freak out
cause
no
and you
how how was the system that
i knew was bad but how is it that bad
they don't see men as human
that's
that is crazy
to
grape somebody
go to jail for it
get pregnant by the person you graped
and then come out of
prison
and have to pay
pay the person
that graped you paid child support
what um
oh my goodness no the court systems when
police officers were show up to domestic
violence case there was often men were
just taken away without asking what even
happened it's just presumed that men are
the criminals
i was assaulted several times you know
and and i never got any help i went to
the police still bleeding a couple of
times
and one police officer
said
uh i'll never forget this he said if she
starts hitting you again you better get
out of there fast because if she just
breaks a fingernail trying to hit you
we'll arrest you
i mean i can't tell you at this point
how many guys i've talked to who are
like
yeah you know she stabbed me and they
put me in jail
not only are there
endless studies that show women are just
as violent as men are when i would talk
about it invariably men would start
coming out of the woodwork with stories
beyonce snubbed cigs on me poured
boiling water on my lap and held a steam
iron on my arm i never hit bro hit these
hoes
hit these hoes
that is [__] up you can hit her but
then it's like they don't want to
because they could go to jail if they
even like hit like you know even in
self-defense that's that's the crazy
thing all this stuff has happened to
this man and if he lays a finger on that
woman
he gets charged and it's like women know
women know that women know the double
standards to where if they can do x y z
to a man if he lays a finger they know
that he will go to jail before they ever
step foot in that jail that is
sick that is sick it's sick
that the that women
are manipulative like that and it's sick
that the system is like that
it's stories they were afraid to tell
stories attacks with knives pelted with
heavy objects and alone with their abuse
their shocking is reality for male
victims of
they got laughed out for
stories that they got blamed for
it's
wait don't she threw a dumbbell at his
face
i would
i would chuck i would drop it drop it
right on the head
smash it from the top down
no
what
nah
this is not flattering to men to talk
about men's vulnerabilities no to talk
about the ways that they are not strong
and that they
they are well weak
um and to be honest about it's not
flattering
a solution
for both genders
is that we need to be able to recognize
how men
are vulnerable and we need to be able to
recognize how women are actors
because we have a huge blind spot
especially when women do bad things
[Music]
my best friend that i grew up with since
kindergarten was being physically abused
by his wife who he had been married to
for 20
years she'll break glass and throw it
out and punch him i've seen it just
happen spontaneously and
it was frequent
and he's bigger than her but he didn't
want to hit her
and he didn't want the children they had
three minor children he didn't want them
seeing this at all
so he would usually just go outside
because they would be glass breaking or
things being smashed or yelling and he
knew that the neighbors might think it's
him
so he would go outside so the neighbors
can see what's happening
eventually i said look you're gonna need
you need professional help and so does
she and maybe the kids do too
so i called a bunch of domestic violence
shelters i i just looked around online
and i called but every place that i
called said we don't help men we don't
help male men at all
and
i started becoming curious about why
that was because i learned that these
were state-funded shelters
and i know that men pay at least half of
the taxes that fund these shelters if
they're state funded and i just was
wondering why
so that's so interesting like it's again
men are paying
for women but they don't return the
favor
exactly
basically there was no place to take him
and it just continued the problem just
kept going
[Music]
in the united states there are over 2
000 domestic violence shelters
all of them serve female victims
and nearly all of them
turn away male victims
in fact as of 2016
there's only a single domestic violence
shelter for men
my initial reaction what'd you say i was
just saying
in arkansas like that's
that's crazy oh
was that there needed to be thousands
more women's shelters because that many
more women are being battered
but as it turns out one in three women
and one in four men will be victims of
physical violence by an intimate partner
in their lifetime
sure there's a slight majority of female
victims
but how can that excuse denying men help
couldn't this be considered gender
discrimination
[Music]
think of it this way
roughly 78 of all suicides are men
if suicide prevention services only
served men
wouldn't we see the gender
discrimination immediately
[Music]
if there are over 2 000 women shelters
that turn away men
and only one shelter for men
obviously the resources don't match the
need
how are you involved in the men's rights
movement
well from the very beginning when i
first opened the refuge which was in
in chiswick in london
uh almost as soon as i took the women in
i got a house for men
a voice for men's editor-at-large aaron
pizzi founded the first ever women's
shelter in 1971
and she is widely revered in the men's
rights community
because you see what i knew from the
beginning most domestic violence is
consensual both are involved
sometimes ones are perpetrated the other
place they think listen to this part
this
i was so shocked about all right you
hear her and then it crosses over
it's not it's not as though it's just
all men or all women it's both
an occasion the innocent victims very
innocent
[Music]
battered children grow up to better
that's what i learnt
whether it be a man or a woman and i now
know that if a woman comes in with a
history of violence in her own childhood
the chances are she will be probably
violent to her children and she will
want to live on this knife edge of
crisis and danger
i haven't been allowed to speak that's
the difficulty why is that because i'm
completely barred from all conferences
like i'm not allowed to walk up the step
of my own refuge i bought the bloody
building but no because this feminist
the woman who runs it is a very happy
family she won't have anything to do
with me
what did you say that made them hate you
that women could be equal
i said i'd take away that building so
quick i better listen here a little bit
isn't
you wouldn't have a job if it wasn't for
me get up out of here no i think it's
state funded so like she bought the
building with the state takes it over
the state ruins everything
i think that's what i am gathering but i
don't know
[Music]
aaron pizzi says that 62 of the first
100 women to enter her refuge were just
as violent as the men they left and
violent towards their children
that's the thing they act like women
like
i know half y'all hoes are crazy that
are in these abusive relationships like
i'm sorry y'all are hitting back stop
acting like you're victims
boo freaking if you're hitting him back
it doesn't count
it does you're equally toxic you deserve
each other
you should just go beat each other up
for life
but leave the kids out of it give them
give your kids to someone else
[Music]
you know very very easily and i've had
an argument but the feminists i've met
have an entirely different take on
domestic violence
[Music]
on the whole issue of domestic violence
that's just another word really that's a
clean up word about
wife beating because that's really what
it is or dating violence and it's not
girls that are beating up on boys it's
boys that are beating up on girls and
using violence to intimidate and to
control and we have very few
what's called domestic violence shelters
which are places that women can
leave their home with their children and
get a new start get out of the violence
but
they're not nearly enough of them we
need more funding and more resources
because it it is a
tremendous
disadvantage for women and girls
[Music]
in 2014 the cdc released a report
revealing
that over 5.4 million men
and 4.7 million women
had been victims of intimate partner
physical violence within the previous 12
months
but then why does the media paint
domestic violence as a women's issue
the world health organization says one
in three women are abused by their
partner one in three american women
experiences domestic violence or
stalking at some point in her life and
when it was addressed as a men's issue
the speaker's point was that it's a
men's issue because men are the problem
i'm going to share with you a paradigm
shifting perspective on the issues of
gender violence i don't see these as
women's issues that some good men help
out with in fact i'm going to argue that
these are men's issues why is domestic
violence still a big problem in the
united states and all over the world
what's going on why do so many men abuse
physically emotionally and other
verbally in other ways the women and
girls and the men and boys that they
claim to love what's going on with men
let's grant every single empirical case
as being true
yes it is true let's just say i mean it
is not true but
let's just assume that that there is
gender symmetry in gen in domestic
violence that women hit men as men as
much as men had women if
if i were to say that i would say and
therefore we need boatloads more funding
for domestic violence to develop
god
there's domestic violence hustlers
it's the same thing
that's why they have to hate men it's
it's a oh my god i just this just
clicked
that's why
that's why they have to paint men is the
problem
because remember they're they're always
selling a solution that's what they're
doing and so they have to keep saying
that men are like men men men are like
the
toxic this that because they're selling
you a solution
and even this that's why they paint men
as evil and the bad guys because they're
trying to get funding
and that
wow
i've seen this documentary before but i
i've never put that together as like
domestic violence hustlers
that's what they're doing
wow
that's crazy
it's like the same it's the same pattern
it's itches
what it is my burn
oh
you okay
because there's this hidden epidemic of
men who are being beaten up by women
or
i could say as the men's rights movement
therefore we shouldn't have these
shelters and we shouldn't fund them
because the women are all lying well it
seems to me that if you really believe
in gender symmetry it's not that you
want to surpr you're not questioning the
the number of women you're just saying
the number of men inside you would want
to join with women
who are anti-violence to say we have a
real problem here
you know it's not even a gender problem
it's a problem of women hitting men and
men and women we've got to get boat
loads more funding let's work together
that seems the logical response to this
but instead they're saying it's like a
zero-sum game if if we fund the women
then we're going to ignore the matter
well we're not ignoring we're not going
to ignore the women because we all agree
that the levels are as high as we say
but it does sound like a zero-sum game
when only women are receiving services
in domestic violence situations
and of all the men's rights activists
i've met none of them question the
number of female victims but they are
calling attention to the high number of
male victims that are being dismissed
so why aren't men's rights activists and
feminists working together
[Music]
michael kimmel briefly said something
that made me wonder
he said it would no longer be a gender
problem
if both men and women were equally
victims of domestic violence
is that why the number of male victims
are never addressed
[Music]
to me it's been fraud for all these
years why is it we have this enormously
powerful feminist movement and virtually
nothing for men
originally it was capitalism was the big
enemy in the 60s and 70s
and it was the radical feminists in
america
they moved the goalposts they said no
it's no longer capitalism it's the enemy
the enemy is patriarchy
more men
and that's how the women's movement
began
and it was enormously successful
the new mood in in the refuges
was going to be that no men could work
in refuges and can't today they can't
sit on the boards
and boys over nine or possibly 12 can't
go into refuges or you call them
shelters their mothers have to make
other arrangements for them which i find
shocking
and it ring fenced money
i think that
that particular time when the feminist
movement were desperate for funding
because they'd run out of of publicity
and they were desperate for funding and
they needed a just cause
and unfortunately it fell into their
laps
it's an enormous industry i mean
violence against women they get
something like what's a billion and over
a year you hear that yeah a billion and
over that's why
so they have to sell them that as being
awful because they're they're losing
their jobs they need they gotta get paid
that's sad oh my god
you're blessing you good
he's asleep
he's gonna see if he wanted food
an awful lot of that goes on
really supposedly rehabilitating men but
essentially punishing them with
something that's called the duluth model
duluth power and control will you guys
know about that no
i give you a copy you know in 1977 i
think a bunch of crazy women up in
duluth minnesota figured out they had
the solution to domestic violence and it
was all about patriarchy
and all about men
and it's a duluth power and control will
because men are all about power and
control
of course not you ladies
you guys you don't control anything you
have no power you're just sweet and
innocent all things okay
so this power
control wheel's divided up in all these
things you know about who does this and
who does that blah blah blah of course
it's all men
[Music]
hold on guys i'm gonna see what they
want to eat
[Music]
you can order something for him
the entire domestic violence industry
was founded on that i think it's still
37 or 32 states in the united states
that by law they have to use the duluth
model for battery intervention programs
and it's all shame blaming guild driven
if you're a man and you walk in you must
admit you did it up front or you're in
denial there's no debate there's no
discussion there's no possibility that
you could be what
only bought one falsely accused the
criminal justice system could have made
a mistake none whatsoever you are in a
state of denial and you will complete
that quarter you're gonna go to jail
you will be re-engineered
[Music]
frightening yes that's right i think
it's terrifying
absolutely
terrified
[Music]
all i had to do a simple choice i could
just say yes you're right
men are the enemy
no problem but i couldn't i absolutely
couldn't
[Music]
just getting overwhelmed
because
i don't know
where i'm headed
um with what i believe and
what is right and what is wrong and who
is wrong and who is right and
what do you say
i put my feet up there for a second and
chat was roasting my family okay i
walked outside earlier i'm sorry okay
the truth is somewhere in the middle and
that's why i'm feeling frustrated
because
[Music]
i don't know where the truth is and i
don't know
your phone
when i decided to make a film on the
men's rights movement
i never anticipated questioning my
feminist views
but the more mras i met
the more i felt compelled to remind
myself why i was a feminist
[Music]
i signed up for a women's
group welcome to our women on your power
workshop
only four percent of the fortune 500
companies are led by women
women only hold about 14
of corporate executive positions
and less than 20
of our government you see the cat ladies
here like they're all cat ladies
look at them
i can just see the cats
well physicians
[Music]
diaries complaining about how i had to
change what i wore to walk alone at
night
how much time it took me to get ready
for work
all the housekeeping that was on my
shoulders in comparison to other gender
issues these videos seem to just a
housework that you have on your
shoulders
like you're coming you you have to do
this [__] to live
yeah exactly like are you complaining
about taking care of yourself
after all this housework well if you
don't do it who don't get it done you're
just going to leave your house
like it's going to leave your house
messy yeah that's like
trivial but i made them nonetheless
i attended women's rights rallies
no to violence that's what we are here
for to say no more to violence in any
forms especially against women and girls
[Applause]
i repeated women's issues in my head
like a broken record
female genital mutilation sex
trafficking reproductive rights
maternity leave
and social media helped remind me of
women's issues
we
have
fought for everybody else's equal rights
it's our time
to have wage equality once and for all
and equal rights for women in the united
states of america
we are struggling
for a uniting word
but the good news is
that we have a uniting movement
it is called he for she
oh my god that was the most ass speech
emma watson ever gave oh my lord
oh my jesus
whenever i hear
the emory's point of view about how
difficult it is for them i immediately
go to
well
what about us what what is it like for
us and then i get on the defensive and
wanna
want to make sure that
women's struggles are also heard
and i don't know if that's
necessary because the mras are saying
that
the feminist
perspective is the mainstream
perspective but even when i hear their
issues i still want to speak up for the
women because i feel like
i don't know why i feel like talking
about one gender's issues now neglects
the other and i guess that's what mres
have been dealing with is always hearing
about women's issues and feeling like
their issues are neglected but whenever
i hear them talk about men's issues i
feel like i need to stand up for women
and say this is what we're dealing with
an equal opposite
[Applause]
i met with men's rights activist karen
strong late one night in a noisy bar
she became well known for her youtube
videos talking about male disposability
and other men's rights issues
and she's a honey badger
part of what i do and what i research
and what i think about is that
the reason psychologically
why feminism
seems to be such a comfortable warm
blanket emotionally for so many people
men and women alike
and
it
it's so comfortable that it will
make them
not see things that are right in front
of their face look at boko haram
hundreds of young girls fast asleep in
their beds are awakened by the sound of
gunfire armed attackers have stormed
their boarding school and set fire to
dozens of buildings nearly 300 of them
are dragged from their dorm loaded onto
trucks and carried away deep into the
forest from new york to london rallied
yesterday demanding that the terrorist
group boko haram why is it hotter right
now
that's the light
i think we could turn it
off it'll be dark in here oh how about
how about the lighting be if we took it
off
just like
should we take down the wall on stream
i mean if you want to
i went to the toilet after after this
video i kind of want to i went to the
toilet
because i feel like or if we don't get
an apartment now we'll get one in a
month
um
it's up to you
i'm i'm feeling like it's a weak moment
for me
bring back our girls they have yellow
patches on the wall and if you if we do
plan on doing
uh like shows
for ah [__] you're right you're right
this is why we have you here
it just gets to the core of you this
this unconscionable act was committed by
a terrorist group determined to keep
these girls from getting an education
and what happened in nigeria was not an
isolated incident
it is a story we see every day
as girls around the world risk their
lives to pursue their ambitions
i mean you must have heard that
right
that's being spun as
a fundamentalist islamic group that is
so determined to be misogynistic and
oppressed girls they want to deny girls
in education
but they are not against girls being
educated they're against anybody
getting a western secular or christian
education
the initial attacks there were several
of them there was one
there were over a hundred men killed and
one woman killed
and the victims were described as people
right or villagers
and in the previous attacks on the
schools they actually let the girls go
they separated out the boys and girls
and they let the girls go and they told
them
go home
get married see this is this is what the
media does the attack wasn't even
against girls and they were spinning it
that way but it's the funding
they're they're they're sexism hustlers
it's all an industry
it's so loud without that
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's all in industry
and once you see it you can't unsee it
wow
you get it right you see you see what
they're saying yeah
i'm like
the audacity
renounce your sins
and live a righteous life under allah
right
and then they burned the boys alive
there was literally
no outrage right it was barely reported
on it was one of those things there was
no opinion pieces on it no nothing right
until the girls
were kidnapped and look at it this way
because we played right into their hands
because they want attention
right and they weren't getting any
attention from the western media when
they were just slaughtering boys
right
they want attention
and what do they do they kidnap girls
and sell them into marriage or slavery
they're saying that the video is a lot
louder than the mics
um this is just what the chat is saying
oh yeah well if i do it on the screen
it'll make it better okay
right and
everybody the u.n
michelle obama barack obama the uk
government the canadian federal minister
of defense right they're all promising
aid and help and equipment and personnel
to help find these girls and bring them
back because this is such an outrage and
oh my goodness something needs to be
done
well maybe if
like last year
maybe if we did something then
all of these girls would be safe in
their dorms right now
but we didn't
and the reason why they kidnapped those
girls
is because we didn't do anything we
didn't pay attention and they want
attention
right
and they know that attacking girls or
women is going to get the potential
what are we going to do
start a campaign bring back our boys oh
wait they're dead never mind
right
the men that the people in boko haram
they're chivalrous
if those girls were boys they wouldn't
be getting education
they'd be dead
they wouldn't be sold into slavery with
the hope of this egg they'd be dead
[Music]
boko haram has been fighting for islamic
rule in nigeria
i'm just saying that's tough like
just to blatantly not care for
i think it's good
blatantly not care for
another men are seen as expendable
men are success objects women are sex
objects
that's sad
i love my means
i don't see y'all as expendable i see
you all as valuable
every last one of y'all
since 2002
its members have killed hundreds of
people
[Music]
i think the audio just cut
um
what do you just call it
yeah
yes
i just can't hear it in my headphones
anymore
which one does somebody get just i
wonder if ellie did it
i don't like coffee is it the video okay
we'll see if it's maybe it's a video
let's just wait
i don't hear anything
you can't hear anything no i can't hear
[Music]
anything yeah it cut
for them as well yeah
is there anything wrong with her
we're figuring it out
what
um
okay let me press play
no um
i don't think they can hear us either
yeah everything's gone
from the video from us
it just
no i don't it says they can't hear us
really
can you guys hear us or just the audio
from the video
high pitched sound at the moment
that's what they said
buzzing
i don't think it's the video they can
hear us
the mics are cool they say oh they can't
hear us the video just cut out i mean
here let me just go what what time stamp
sit on
so if i go there
yeah they can't hear it either
that was there's voice there
the no the audio doesn't work on there
it's that
yeah it's just a video the video doesn't
like that they can hear us they can't
hear the screen
no no it's not the audio in the video
they can't i can't hear anything
if i play it i don't hear anything
now
guys we started at 12 today we just
broke up the stream because it said
youtube only takes up to 12. we're not
three hours in
three hours into part two
what's
up be
thanks chilly
the members go to bat hey what are they
saying
oh never want whenever anyone talks
online they're like chill out we
appreciate you members
oh my days
i wanna oh
[Music]
is there so high-pitched noise folks
okay
video still isn't on
i need five minutes
give me five minutes five minutes
play it again okay
nada is it turned up how low is it
on the video
can you turn the volume up for me
on the video yeah i got you
give me five minutes
five minutes
and espanol por favor or someone
translate it for me
spin doctor don't act like you know me
don't give out my secrets
no
not um
it's not the video
extra credit x you know would be extra
credit for memberships
yeah y'all what's up what do i got to do
to get y'all to sign up for memberships
for up i'll shake hello
guys i just got my i just i just lost my
tick tock account
[Music]
i used to make money off of that
so that's another revenue stream down
the drain
now this isn't your fault you didn't do
this people that can't handle the truth
did this
but if you want to support your girl
make up for that revenue that i lost
and help pay my rent
and this hopefully sick apartment that
we get center for memberships i know
it's only five bucks a month and you're
thinking that doesn't help but each and
every one of you contributes
if we get to
a thousand members then rent's paid for
and i'm chilling i don't even have to
stress
but
right now we're at like close to 300
which is cool you guys are killing the
game yeah
but
yeah we're trying to we're trying to get
to a thousand
just because i think
anyways
someone asked if i was red pilled yet
i'm gonna keep it behind with y'all
i'm not sure if i'm fully red pill but
i'm
i'm scared to be fully red pill because
i'm like what will this world be if i am
so
that's it
um pearl once we're done watching this
video
i'm a
cut for like 15 minutes i'm gonna go
home
scrub a dub dub and then
come on back
i don't believe you she's not coming
back
i promise you i'm coming back
i'll be like 15 minutes tops we'll see
how
fast i can walk
actually be like you guys what
members
scrub and dub dub dub if you want to see
just scrub a dub dub sign up for our
memberships
only fans
you're welcome pilp
guys ask us questions in the chat we'll
give you exclusive questions
i'll ask juicy stuff thank you for
signing up for our memberships thank you
oh wait we had another
thanks
joe
maximum play it okay
thanks joe nasty
definitely not i am coming back
i'll be back i'm not gonna go to sleep i
promise
i'm coming back they said cat it's it
sounds like it's this
this is off
yeah let's see
something clicked to my ears i did do
the entire thing last i'm coming back i
promise
i just need to get changed
okay they said probably you got to do
dude yeah i'm probably not what they
want
yeah
i'm working on it though um
how do i find a good woman they don't
exist
i do have a tic tac
i don't but i don't really post it and
i'm not posting it my backup tick tock
is pearly reactions
watch i'm gonna go i'm gonna prove oh
i'm gonna prove you lot's wrong i'ma
come back
i'm gonna be better than ever i'm gonna
have energy i'm six foot how tall are
you jess five ten
five nine
5 10.
um
okay i'm dead
i'm five nine and a half last time
um
jessica would say her head hurting she
can't come back nah
that's a that's a whack excuse
anything i say my knees hurt in um
why are you still i must be too
hypergamous that's why i'm single do you
think we're too hypergamous
i i don't know
someone said i told a girl i'd be back
in 15 minutes that was 10 years ago
okay
let's see
um
no
i i can't dunk on a nine inch rim right
now i know i wouldn't be able to i asked
for your number doing street interviews
i got nervous he was actually
he was good looking too could it yo
who was it pearl look
i don't i got nervous
yeah there was one dude oh in your
street interview yeah yeah yeah i saw
that i said pearl
i don't know i got nervous
he was fine i was like
don't [__] out
you can't hear that nothing
yeah just played basketball that's how
we met
i remembered her name which is like a
big deal for me yeah i was the only one
she remembered i did play sports growing
up i played
i played basketball ran track and cross
country
you're you're a runner yeah she's a
runner she's a track star i really was
she gonna run online
[Music]
um would you quote what you're doing for
a man he says you're done you're
cooperating
um
yeah if i liked him enough
who giving away 250k
i mean i'm saying if he is if he's
multi-million i mean i don't i don't
think i qualify for that i'm gonna be
honest but it says echo
reverb says
oh cause annika has his headphones
plugged in
[Music]
and he was so funny when like
she was like 15 you slept with 15 men
i'm like auntie
most
that's not even that bad nowadays
oh there we go like auntie you don't
even know what's out there
um
we can watch andrew tate in a second
yeah okay it's a video that cut
let's back out
the video like the actual video cut out
not like on the
there's no sound in the section
oh for real it was actually the video oh
my bad sorry guys
um
okay
what the okay
look at that look at that family
my family is fired
so we'll just keep watching it
fast forward to see if it comes back at
all
because if you go back here
okay i'll just keep watching hopefully
i'll come up
okay
wow
oh 10 dollar super chat you ladies are
doing great you're cute as hell
and your attitude is on point if i find
a girl like you she's getting the ring
within two months and i'm not cheating
i hope you do i nick
hashtag
bring back our girls important things
the men's movement is doing is being
able to say
men
need compassion and men deserve
compassion what was that again
bring back our girls
it was the afro the nigerian girls
what girls
it was that movement
that happened
like years ago years ago and they were
like bring back our girls bring back our
girls
and i remember seeing that i'm like
what do you mean our girls they're from
africa they're not even from the united
states
who
oh
and i was like
why
i don't remember that
i remember that okay
and
to have that happen
i'm not expecting it in my lifetime
it's an ocean of pain out there
this
stuff we're talking about has been going
on for so long
and
nobody listens
nobody cares
it's one thing
when you
look at
what happens to women and you feel
normal healthy outrage about it and that
should happen
but when you can look at what's
happening in our courts to men in our
medical establishment to men in our
schools to men and yet we remain so
cerebral about all of it yes well that
is certainly something to consider
what if it were him no i was just
looking at the chat
was paladar was paladar
chile was polidar i think to any other
group
we would be having protests from coast
to coast and the fact is that it is
happening to men every day right in
front of our eyes and people will get
angry at you if you try to talk about it
that's how deep the prejudice runs
[Music]
but there have been protests
i don't know who else would be calling
me this late hello
hi flat 4 galley house
[Music]
while we're waiting on the food y'all
can either
ask me questions or
tell me a joke tell me a funny joke
a geeky
what is a woman
is it a video
8 p.m oh it's 8 pm in phoenix right now
i mean it is 4 o'clock in the morning
why am i single
i often wonder about that i don't
i don't know
i'm not crazy a lot of people say are
you crazy
englishmen like brits
i don't have a preference if i find you
attractive i find you attractive
best pickup line
i don't know
we did that earlier
i haven't heard a pickup line in years
i've heard like bible pickup lines which
is
interesting
i might be
i play a forward
but i'm moving up i played like a small
forward like a four but i'm moving up to
like three four
because last season i played like a
little bit of three four
and then actually last few years i
played a little bit of three four
[Music]
look if you don't have faith for us i
can leave we gonna make it
[Music]
um
when you ask me what's my ethnicity
all i know is i'm black i've heard that
i have
indian
and
irish and all that other fun stuff and
my family don't know for sure i knows
i'm black mom is from ohio that's from
michigan
that's all i can tell you about my
ethnicity
um i've never turned on a proposal
haven't even been proposed to yet to
turn one down
a detroit into his house
thanks sarah
you should be here but you know what i'm
not gonna be upset anymore
my second worst date
um
all right y'all about to eat getting a
freaking argument in the middle of
a park
after he left me
not like broke up but
okay
a tiny bit
[Music]
basketball yeah
[Applause]
thank you
yeah that's why i'm just waiting
p4gy
just waiting
don r thank you for becoming a member
you know what
this man is still awake
we're gonna give him a call
who
you'll see
sir you better answer you know who i'm
talking to
i think i'm at that camera
da da
you're you said i'm working i'm working
it is dark there
all i can see is your teeth sir
okay if i explain my job you'd
understand
are you a male escort
no
something like that oh
you're working the whole stroll right
now
i'm like why are you up this late
working
ah
you on the blade right now
i have no clue what i got i got a greek
salad and a chicken kebab
let's rise
yo sarah mr garvey
i heard you're a bitter
for our 241 special i heard you're a
bitter for a two-for-one special
yeah
you guys uh you guys are making your
reconsider
my options now
[Music]
yeah
okay yeah is it like because guys would
be like i'm gonna type so then you get
like one of these
you know both of you want sex on the
same day
you know
we gotta work
yeah
one will get breakfast
and then
breakfast or dinner
i mean it's all up to sarah if he wants
if he wants a little bit of chocolate in
the morning or something sweet at night
or a little bit of
vanilla in the morning
in the morning some chocolate in the
afternoon
and then we can mix them both at night
you know
like five minutes ten minutes go back
and forth just
boom boom boom
little neapolitan sorry everyone thinks
we're dating
[Music]
did you hear pearl
i'm eating salmon sarah you hear me
everyone thinks we're dating that's like
the number one chat
yeah i know everyone thinks that was
smashing or something yeah
wait are those
[Music]
that should yours
continue like should we break their
hearts or should we just like you know
or maybe should we start
you know
it's like we're getting closer to 30 so
we're 50 off
i'm turning 26 soon
no
i'm 25 how old do you think i am
i was i'm 28.
you were close yeah you were close i was
in my former life
[Music]
um
auntie auntie she gave us some
prime
sex advice
yeah some prime i was like yo
i'm inspired she was just talking about
just
when you like if your man wants it you
give it to him no matter where you
are no matter where he wants it she said
if he's at work
you give it to him you drive there
if you're at the store
they have toilets if you're wherever if
he wants it you give it to him and what
if you're on a podcast and she just
started laughing and then she was like
you don't stop until
she said you empty him and then there's
like she was like there's females that
just just leave and
they're just not shaking she said no you
need to have earthquake sex and i was
like i aspire to have that one day
auntie and she was shaking she was like
you need to be shaken five minutes after
he leaves
i said auntie
you have lived darling she said if
you're not feeding me
[Music]
yeah
i said
she was like
she was like if you're on your period or
if you're not feeling well open your
mouth
she said that
yeah she said all these all these women
got big mouth fill it
she
said that auntie went in
she was
yeah she was the probably the best
tonight
she was the best
i know i'd fall asleep if i got pizza so
i got wings and
you're keeping track of your hoes oh we
know we have a couple bitters though
honestly we have a couple people
interested so let me know like how good
our bunk beds would be yeah there's some
there's some bidders yeah
we got a few
i'm sure you ladies will have some
bitters sarah talk to me
[Music]
put in your offer
offer
keep dying
can't believe it you're not looking
right here
like one
yeah excuses
the gray areas canceled this week
i swear i don't finish until one
cancel
people have been in the comment section
though they've been like asking a lot of
questions they have been i can't see the
comments i'm not texting right now
i was like
i might as well have hooked up with him
because everyone thinks we hooked up
sorry it was like the top comment it's
like
you guys are dating you rather than like
you guys smashing with all right guys
let's run with that i'm sorry i'm gonna
stop stop chill out chill out
chill out
we're gonna run with that
we
going around with that and then and then
it's gonna be and then it's gonna be i
had sex with jess
you know and then i'm gonna start
[__] everyone in the office yeah i'm
gonna fight everyone in the office
and then there's going to be a rivalry
between you and jess that is going to be
like a love triangle
and then
you know lover squirrel
you know the whole thing there's a whole
story behind it i'm here for it
[Music]
let's
you ever see people us on the tvs on
people's like screens mm-hmm
[Music]
this is our second mukbang of the day
what did you guys eat before
um
oh no we did a mukbang for members only
yeah
did you guys wear um
and stuff
not this time
next time though
all right well you've got what's the
time past four in the morning
oh [__] man
like
eight hours yeah eight hours
i'm gonna make it
i mean look
i'm darren's spirit
[Music]
since you're an actor can you cry on
command
um
i used to be able to
you do it let me see
i used to be able to see do it again
i don't think i can do it
it takes time it takes time
act like we just broke your heart
yeah i'm sorry you can only have one you
have to pick
i think i'm numb from heart right now um
don't say that
i don't i don't think that would make me
cry anymore
why would i do that
yeah what i'm fond of yeah but he's got
a whole
yeah a new girl can't find me
i have a question
that will make it even more like spicy
um i have a question why do
why do women
say they're buyer lesbian one moment and
they'll date a woman and the next moment
they'll date a guy
because
women don't know what they want we don't
know this
you're right
women don't know what they want
they say they do that's what i said two
people stop listening to women
so stop listening to pearl
how dare you
listen in general women
so i don't know what i want half the
time
that's sad but true
you know like i said women don't know
even they don't even know how to order
for men they take like 10 years trying
to decide how they want the menu
you know
and then when it comes they're like oh i
want some of yours it's like what the
[__]
um
like we couldn't have the same thing
it means she trusts your judgment yeah
it just means like i want what i had and
what you had
you see they want it oh they don't know
what they want but they know they want
it all see that
see these modern women
chat what's the proper way to eat
chicken
um
let's see what the chat says
you know you're definitely filling this
i will happily fill that stereotype
i will fill it
that's easy
look at look at this i mean let me
introduce you to someone
let me introduce you
this is blessing tell tell them what you
did for me come on
yeah he he got him he got him and he got
it so we can listen to the videos
through the headphones
yes sir
he's doing he's doing tuesdays now too
so he's going to be here on tuesdays
[Music]
oh my god that is gonna be amazing
i hope you don't get any crazies you
know how the internet is already
you know you guys in the comment section
who are
crazy please don't call
no they gave me all flats actually first
of all all flats are the best
those are the best wings flats
are really not the best they are though
you get more juicy meat in the flat
look up
what are the chaps right
now now pelt is devouring that seminar
right i'm hungry
i'm hungry
look at i'm not a perfect person when i
get real hungry i just i'm pearl eats
pearl don't care
bro what they think you're [__]
everyone on the show do you think i'm
why the [__] am i [__] everyone you
should think it is a compliment you
should take it look at this but the
thing is why am i to 304 on this show
i don't know i don't know sarah speak
for yourself what
what what are you the 304 on this show
i'm just saying i'm just saying
it sounds like you're the common
denominator in all these
situations their minds are in the gutter
constantly yeah i mean that's part of
the space the red pill
but
like like people are not allowed to have
like friendships with people would be
cool
no they they think i'm effing everybody
every time every time i talk to a guy
it's like they're sleeping with him you
sleep at the site
like what i saw earlier there was that
big dude that you had on right
yeah
um
sometimes i'll be making jokes
and it's just like i'm just
well i think i think sexual repression
is part of this i think
so what is sexual repression people are
sexually repressed oh so they're not
[__] anybody so they're like hoping
we are yeah exactly so when you're not
getting sex you know everything's sick
and everyone's having sex you know
someone said it's not it's not sarah
garvey it's sarah tyrone
money he's excited i can see it in his
eyes
um
guys
um someone said hey just pearly thing i
wish i could have seen your videos years
ago i've been wrong by my baby mama and
a lot of your videos describe her great
videos and i wish you success cheers
from mexico mexico mexico
mexico
hola como estas we have viva mexico
sorry would you ever do polygamy
um
it would have to be very easy
yeah this
i'm trying to handle all this anyways
yeah
i can't handle that plus
i think i'd be like discriminated
against so
here um
no discrimination you're part of the
family now
no no no you said you said black women
feel like home you know in that lab
i know i know so i'd be like i'd be like
the like the
redheaded stepchild
you know
i think i've seen this film before
and i didn't like the ending what
he'll be like here's the other wife and
then like pull jess forward and be like
oh yeah and her i'll be like
somebody in the chat says
[Music]
on single mothers
listen i got stories about singing
mother's name
y'all don't know
what what's the worst thing that's what
what's the worst thing that a baby mama
has ever done
oh she's how
[Music]
your baby mom
yeah
oh yeah so
you know
this girl is for the street i want to
make a song that's like
this girl is for the streets
thank you i can't i want to do a show at
some point i play guitar
thank you
i want to
but i don't think they'd like the music
i release i actually wrote a song you
want to say hear it
[Music]
it's not what i wanted but you're no
good for me
i wrote one
[Music]
it gets good wait wait the chorus is the
best part this part
now here here oh you gotta listen
cause you're addictive
side effects include
of appetite sleepless nights and trust
issues
your high risk
i'm a love addict
feeling
fail mentally unstable ready you should
have come
[Music]
with a
warning label that cover look at that
with a warning
[Music]
last boyfriend
it was before i came here
we broke up
and i was like this is crazy and i was
thinking about like damn i wish i was
warned about this
and then i looked up like the warning
label like things
and then
yeah and then i was like oh i could make
a song out of this and like like you're
addictive side effects include and then
like missing you loss of appetite
sleepless nights nights and trust issues
you're high risk i'm a love addict this
feeling is fatal mentally unstable you
should have come with what a warning
label clever
you know what does he know it's about
him yeah i mean because we did get back
together after that so i guess i was
warned that i still you know
i was like i guess
yeah yeah but then then we broke up
again so like then yeah so when we got
back together i did show him that song
but then we broke up again
and then then we didn't how many times
three two
one
i mean we there would be like okay
would you count does a breakup count if
you get into a fight you break up for a
day and you get back together does that
count as a breakup
for a day you count that
because you if you guys decided you
broke up then yeah
i feel like it doesn't count for today
it counts
what
okay okay
listen if i break up with a girl at 12
o'clock
by 205 i'm single
yeah but i was like i didn't do anything
you know if you break up at 12 o'clock
by 1205
i'm back on the market
okay well
it wasn't you
he broke up with me like twice early on
um
when we were yeah but
we get back together like a day later i
mean he just got mad and then like i
feel like why didn't he break
what did i do
um i don't really talk about that on
live i tell you i can tell you some
other time but
um
it was
leave me alone dog but
and then
the last time i did but
we dated for a year
and the first two times we broke up were
like pretty early on
it was like one time
i'll tell you one of them
i made a joke about
i mean you know joke about his family
no no no i mean do you know mark demillo
okay he's like this tick-tock right and
he we like both knew him and i saw a
picture of him when he was like younger
and
i'm i've like
i don't think mark i don't okay
welcome i like don't think he's
attractive like like mark he's just not
my type but i saw a picture of him when
he was 20 and i was like oh
damn
okay okay no i saw mark emilia i saw a
picture from when he was like 20. and i
was like oh my god like i was like oh my
god like he could have got it back in
the day like i didn't mean actually i
just meant like he looks so different
because like he's kind of ugly now you
know and i said he was like 20.
and he got so mad he broke up with me i
was like
yeah yeah that's how i'm like
but then it was like a day so we got
back together i'm not saying it was like
i just thought it was like stupid so i
was like does that count
i mean
and i'm like i i didn't mean it like i
didn't i didn't mean i'd actually like
do i just meant like
yeah yeah like
i'm not
like
how did i put it um
stop
stop child
yeah
yeah i don't know
but
yeah
as i'm watching these comments right
the majority of your audience
i'm thinking at some point you're going
to get married yeah
where are they at
i'm watching that
i think they say i'm too hypergamous
maybe i am
i do like guys with jobs
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think actually what [__] me up is i'm
tall
because i don't really like because i
don't know
what
is the guy i have to get
yes yeah like within like an inch like
if he's like i'm five eleven and a half
he's like five ten and a half out of ten
it's like
chilling but
i i don't know i'm just not really
attracted to like guys that are a lot
shorter than me
[Music]
of course
like six six three six four
okay
okay yeah
i'll see him
maybe i'm
maybe i'll be i'll be walling soon i
don't know
but
i don't think you want your choice
that's not my choice
hmm
are you
offering that [__] again
[Music]
[Applause]
let me know when you yeah send them my
way
no send them
i'm so
how would that work
i see a guy in my chat i'm like
it's the guys in the chat you know like
uh
okay yeah job is important i'm
hypergamous
just describe your type
my type
you now have
000 followers
you telling me not one of those guys
would fit your criteria i'm sure one
would
but it's like the
i don't know
i guess i i guess i could put it out
there
okay my my type let's see
shouldn't you not mix like business with
like that stuff
listen girl you have to get love and
find it nowadays
[Laughter]
my my my type is um
six to caribbean none
um no actually my type
let me see
i like guys with jobs
um i have a thing for firemen i don't
know what it is and coaches
firemen
okay
or
or a police officers
over six foot over a quarter million a
year but divorced with a child i guess
i'll just have to settle
lucas okay see the kids thing
my dad's approval my dad's approval is
like very important to me
he might have
it's not i like i like kids but i just
ain't yours
yeah like i want i just okay i've never
i put this i feel like
i really want to give a guy his first
kit because i feel like there's nothing
like your first like child
you know and so like i really like want
that moment to be just be like ours you
know
maybe maybe but maybe maybe
maybe that's too high the standards
i don't know
30s early 30s no kids
um
i have dated some white guys
but not really
i haven't
so
listen you'll be there
well should i should i not have said
that well it's out there i didn't know
i've dated like
i'm not actually a couple years ago i
had a huge crush on this white guy i
worked with but he put me in the friend
zone and it wasn't even like
like i know some girls get put in the
friend zone where they're like
hooking up
but
nah he just he was like not interested i
was like
yeah
that happens
if somebody
[Music]
i thought when guys put you in the
friend zone they like try to [__] you
first
i was a little offended oh you know
whatever whatever
hold on
yeah like
yeah a little bit offended
um
you know what i think i like that i
don't like that i like i like guys that
are [__]
oh god i gotta sneeze hold on
bless you
no doesn't your americans say because
i'm
tight i do like guys that are like
smooth
but i think that's bad because i think
they have to practice to get there
i just feel like i'm kind of i'm kind of
funny i like people that can match it
you need to go to church
to church
i thought there's like no men in the
church anymore
right now let's be honest the dating
pool is a little bit [__] right about
now let's be honest uh-huh
but we're in the dating pool so does
that mean we're [__]
yes okay okay
okay
okay no one trusts anyone anymore
everyone's like what's going on here
you know she's a little bit
[Music]
i mean i've been single for three years
i i said i give myself
five years of single life
okay
because i've never been like single for
this long in my whole i've spent like
literally half of my life in
relationships
like seven years
two and a half years and ten years
i'm just like
man you need to just chill the [__] out
for yourself like who the [__] are you
you know mm-hmm though i'm taking time
out so how have we been singled out
um since
december we broke up we were gonna get
back together in february but
yeah that didn't work out so like
february was when i like stopped talking
to him
would you get back with him no
[Music]
no oh god no
is everybody that
bad yeah
okay fair enough okay so he's out of the
picture nah he's out
we need someone
me
i just i don't know
i don't know where my date and then
where my next date is gonna come from
but
i'm enjoying singledom
yeah
yeah i'm actually enjoying it
i'm finding out who i am
that's like what the women say
no but the thing is i've got time
because i'm a man yeah i know but that's
just though i say like i'm finding out
who i am
but the thing is if you spent your last
10 years in a whole relationship
you'd probably mm-hmm some time to
yourself
oh i'm sure it would
you know
you'd want some time to yourself 10
years a long time
taking care of children
like paying for everything doing the
whole quote-unquote
that's what i was saying that this is
what i was saying right this is a
question for the audience right yeah can
you be
a high value
man and you don't have any children
because
men
are natural born protectors
and they should be protecting
family structure
but
can you be can you know what it is even
to have
to know what manhood is
if you don't father any children
that's the question guys well if you
look at kevin samuel's definition i'd
say yeah
but
but if my
know i hear thing is
but when you get to manhood i'm telling
you there's something in you as a man
that switches in you
you have a child
there's a level of manhood that you you
have to adhere to and i think a lot of
guys that don't have children
they don't know what that's like man
they don't know what that's like
sarah
okay keep going keep going
what was that
i know i said keep going keep going so
you think that if a man doesn't have
children he doesn't like grow up in some
sense
yeah you need to have children to grow
up you need to know what it is to
protect you need to know what it is to
actually provide because when when you
realize life
is not just about yourself
it's just this is a switch that flips on
in your brain
you know like and i think a lot of men
don't get to experience that a lot of
men do because a lot of men do become
fathers but a lot of men don't
experience that and it's like
do you know what it's like to do you
know what this manhood thing is really
like
if you don't have a child
you know that's a question
interesting
it's a question
it's a good question you do show it be
the gray area
like
manhood fatherhood
because okay
so when you talk about like war times
right people meant protecting women and
children right
because that's what brings out men's
protective
um
capabilities when they have to defend
and go to war for women and children if
there are no women and children to go to
war for then what is it to be the man
what is it to provide
can you provide them for yourself
you know it's like
that's just selfishness
that's not
if we're building if we're building core
family structures here
you know
you might need to have a child or two
huh
interesting i have to think about that
you know i'm not you know like trying to
shame men that don't have children i'm
just saying
[Music]
when when it happens to you you know
i'm just saying when it happens to you
you know
i i want to be a mom
it sounds fun
i want to be a mom yeah like there's a
level of womanhood that you'd level up
into when you become a mom right yeah
you're not just living for
[Music]
living your yourself life you're
actually living for somebody else so
[Music]
you know
so someone said in the chat sorry
now so man yeah have some children guys
[Music]
do you think me and jess are too
hypergamous
i don't know i don't know what you two
then okay interesting
i actually don't know what youtube's
types are
i don't know i definitely don't wanna i
don't know what justice type is we have
the same type which is dangerous
oh really same type yeah
if you're gonna fight over guys
nah i don't think so
but
interesting you got you got any friends
looking for wives
let me think off the top of my head i
keep a very small circle of men and
they're all married
i've got like three guys that i know
that i roll with
and they're all partnered
[Music]
what type of guy do you think i'd be
good with
you'd be good
with a guy who's kind of laid back
chilled
he's gonna have to be laid back chilled
he's gonna have to understand
the whole youtube thing that you're
doing
but
if he's already established himself this
whole youtube thing cannot take
precedent
over his
mission
you need a man
[Music]
um
what do you mean by a man with a mission
can you explain that more
like
a man that knows what he wants like he's
doing his own thing
and you're gonna have to slot into his
whatever he's doing even though you've
got your own thing doing mm-hmm you're
gonna have to slot into what he's doing
hmm
because essentially you're gonna need
structure because essentially you're
gonna need you're gonna want children
right yeah
exactly so you're gonna need to slot
into his program because you know you're
doing youtube for a while blah blah blah
but when you start having kids that
shit's gonna slow down
yeah how how would you do that
how would i do that
how would you do well um
you said that i would need a like i
would need to go into his world or
something like some how would i do that
got going on so yeah
because eventually you're going to
become a housewife girl that's just it's
done it's it's already pre it's
pre-ordained for you do you think i'll
be a housewife
i don't think i qualify to be a
housewife oh my god
what
pre-ordained okay
i'm not clean enough to be i'm kind of
messy
like
it's pre-ordained well the thing is once
you start having children
except your mind might change
look at i'm
i'm not saying like
i'm not saying i'm i'd be down
but i feel like the guys that can afford
housewives like i don't think i'd
like i don't think i could date a guy
that makes that much money
because like okay i rate myself one
no no okay i'll i'll explain like one to
ten i give myself like a five like i
think i'm just like a normal looking
girl maybe maybe six but i feel like
housewives
like that's top 20 of females i wouldn't
put myself in top 20 of females i think
i'm a cool chick and i'm not saying that
like to be ragging myself i just think
it's like it'd be unrealistic of me to
expect to be a housewife
no i'd be a wife
but
i'm saying like
who who's
like most people need two incomes
okay yeah i get that okay yeah
yeah okay yeah does that make sense like
if if i could sure but i'm just i
wouldn't
like so i thought kevin samuel said you
had to make like two 300k a year to be
housewife so i'm like
well
okay if some dude that makes that much
wants to marry me look i'm down but
i'm telling you you've got you've got
255 000 subscribers
i'm sure there's a man there right now
that you're just
you're bypassing
um
hold on i'll give you a deep dive into
my dms
okay so
like first there's so many
and a lot of them don't have profile
pictures
i don't know
or like they'll send me a message but
i'll see they're in like a different
state or a different country so it's
like
when am i gonna see you you know like
it'd be
uh you know i i'd like someone's from
britain to reach out to me you know like
i'm here i'm here but it's like how
would you start a relationship
if you're in two different places you
know
yeah it's true and i think i think
because my plan right now
is i really i'm trying to be more wifey
this like next six months i'm trying to
be more wifey and i'm trying to learn
how to cook better
and i'm trying to learn and i want to
lose 20 pounds
and i know i've been saying that for a
while i've been stuck but i'm gonna do
i'm like the type of person i will get
there and that's like my goal the next
six months is i'm trying to be more of
like what men want
but
yeah
that's
and i'm trying to do it before my
birthday that's like i'm trying to
but the then the next thing i was trying
to think of is like where who are the
men i want where are they and how do i
get that like we're like that was that
was like my next
like first i was thinking like you have
to become because i've been doing better
i used to dress like a homeless all the
time
and i i've been doing that no i used to
do you remember these streams
and so i was like first i'm going to
learn how to like dress a little bit
better and i was like next i'm going to
try
to lose weight and i used to have a ton
of acne and i cleared my skin this last
six months like look at it go me and i
was like then the next thing i want to
do is learn how to i'm probably never
going to be that neat i'm going to be
i'll have cleaners
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry and then i
was like the next thing i'm trying to do
is like learn i've been learning how to
cook but i was like once i move into
this new apartment
yeah it's we're ramping it up we're
ramping it up
though the best thing you can do
yeah
oh man
like you said is to become the type of
woman that you know men want
right so
once you become the type of woman that
you know men want you know you now know
your worth i think the the problem is a
lot of women out there
that are not the types of women that men
generally want which is why they stay
home and they stay side chicks and they
stay
and i'm trying to figure out how to give
guys peace because that's the thing i've
always heard is they want peace you know
all right and um and that's something
i think i could probably
be better at because sometimes my
ex-boyfriend would tell me shut up
he's like i don't care i don't i don't
look at me
i don't care stop stop yeah like and i
was thinking i was like i probably
couldn't
[Music]
and i heard guys like girls that shut up
and give them sex i mean like like i
said before many times
there's nothing wrong with being a
talkies got to talk to your girlfriends
like guys
like
minimal
minimal talking but it's just like if
you're gonna come to your guy with like
all of that oh my god babe you know what
happened with yeah i do that
yeah i do do that mm-hmm i don't care
[__] that she wore a dress that
made her look fat or whatever i just i
don't i don't care
but essentially
yeah become his piece
you don't cook for him
i cook i do cook
i don't know
[Music]
like you know be a good mother yeah
i mean you grew up in a house with a lot
of siblings you know what it's like to
be around i guess children yeah
no that's the one thing i think i'd be
really good at is like
culture and like family i know how
to do the [__] my mom did when it comes
to like family traditions family culture
like because i think traditions and like
culture is so important to have like
your own like i really value having like
family traditions that you do every year
i don't know
like yeah
yeah
because that shows that you're dedicated
to the family structure it shows that
you're dedicated to you know raising
children you don't want the girls who
[__] partying every weekend
no no we don't know
that that woman that gets partied every
weekend she becomes
we already know she's for the streets
you know she's around a lot of guys
she's gonna get a lot of attention from
guys and
in this in the way the world's going
right now everyone's just trying to [__]
everyone
so my dad told me so my dad told me i
asked my dad he said for
six months figure out like like get this
[__] going
and then pay someone to just like pay a
matchmaker that's what he told me
oh really okay okay that's what
i don't know
because i don't know if that's just what
my dad told me to do he said for six
months get this because i'm gonna like
everything blew up so fast
it's been a lot the last six months i'm
not even gonna lie this has been like a
lot
i failed out of school
failed out of school yeah because of
this
i definitely did i mean i can retake the
classes
um
because now i have to be like actually
even though i don't care about this
degree because
i need the visa or i don't know i'm
meeting with a lawyer this week to see
if there's a way around it we'll see
but
yeah i have to
damn
you know i think jess is falling asleep
yeah i think so too she said she was
coming back i was like
she
[Music]
everyone's asleep but meme
oh [__] yeah
blessings sleeping there i think it's
just sleeping in the hallway i think
jess is sleeping there i'm the last man
standing
where's um where's ellie
um she's in the room she's being
annoying so i like moved here earlier
and your audience how many people
like 500. nothing crazy
how many people are watching
500 yeah
yeah
last man i got
seven more hours
dang
like i said i wish i could be there yeah
you should you should match make me you
could you could find one you could be my
matchmaker
uh
you know
don't say any number because the
internet's listening
okay okay
the big
the big bucks
someone said
they bet 500 people watch you if you
sleep
i'm at 300 would watch me not five
i mean that's still part of the stream
if you sleep
yeah yeah i just feel weird having
people watch me sleep
i'd be afraid to snore
when people have access to you and they
shouldn't have access to you
very true you know what i also have been
trying to work on okay
i also realized i was like i can't be
mad that i don't have what i want like
dating wise if i don't go after what i
want
but i always
get scared to like
tell guys i like them
um
so i don't know or like how did i put it
i was like if i see a guy in public i
should go say hi to him that if i think
he's cute but i can never get myself to
do it i'm always like ah
as women um
women
don't deal with rejection very well no
not well at all
guys are used to that [__] um
girls aren't used to it but then what
you have to work on pearl yeah if you
like a guy you have to work on your
uh
you have to work on your maintenance
strategy
[Music]
okay let's practice let's practice
let's let's hold on
at it
wait i'm in the supermarket
oh okay let's try again let's try again
let's show you
okay okay
okay
[Laughter]
that wasn't smooth
are you saying that wasn't smooth
no
okay let's try it let's check out the
show again okay
oh okay god
sorrow what is she trying to do
oh okay okay they're saying be regular
be really good
okay okay
okay okay okay hang on
is that is that a chest next to you yes
okay jess listen pearl needs to work
on the way she lures a man to her right
you know guys
guys recognize
a smile they recognize okay
i gave you oh [__] i gave you a smile
um
okay let me try again let me try again
okay
okay so imagine okay so imagine you've
just seen a guy
okay
that was good
okay yeah we're getting there we're
getting there okay
okay
okay so that i'll twirl my hair i'll
touch my hair right
i'll start shall i start that's what
you're supposed to do play with your
hair
[Music]
why not why not that looks like why not
that look what's wrong with my look not
that look
nah that that was a creeper look okay
this is what you said
yeah don't be creepy
okay okay what okay what do i do
okay so that okay so you sit
so you if you if you're around him
you sit in a place where you know he's
gonna see you you know he's gonna notice
you okay
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do i work on my looks
no i mean looks as in the way you look
at people okay
[Music]
you need to learn
how to smile with your eyes
smiles you gotta smile spiral banks
[Music]
make eye
contact cross your legs you give him eye
contact okay
smile with your eyes
it's like a quick little like
i look away okay okay okay
god damn
i think i'm doing good
i mean
if you say so
quick little
boom
i think we we need our own company
okay okay
no i'm telling you you could when we
move we can you can come through
we can't we can do that
we can we can do like a video on it i'm
like trying to
yeah
i'm i'm a smooth cat
you're really nice
she's single too she's older than me
[Music]
i've never really enticed a man as
always i've met him
we've hit it off and then we
just
go from there yeah no see me and jess
were raised to be boys that's our
problem
we're like raised with brothers it's
like i always i i always know these type
of girls because they're my favorite
but yeah i like the
people
sarah thinks we're gonna fight because
we have the same type
[Music]
it's slightly different
is our type slightly different i think
so
i don't think it is i think it's
actually quite similar
yeah pretty much she thinks it's
slightly different but it's like the dis
it's like slightly different but the
same
but trust me
i won't fight nobody for nobody
listen you're gonna have to start
fighting soon
paul's getting smaller
hey
they either
they'll either swim or sink
we'll figure it out
you know what's interesting i feel like
guys can be friends at like i feel like
a dude two dudes can go after the same
chick and date x's and like kind of
share a chick and be friends still
but like girls can't
um
like dudes can kind of like one doodle
date the girl and another will date her
after and like they'll kind of be iffy
for a little bit but they kind of get
over it we're like girls will hate each
other forever
it was like oh [__]
i dated her too bro i was at what
i didn't know that [__] but if i knew if
i knew he had
dated her i wouldn't go that i wouldn't
hold on i won't go anywhere nearer
no [__] way
did you date her after
would i date her
oh and like she wanted to get married
no she um
she like she was a language student
so she moved to colombia
colombia
do you still keep in contact with any of
your ex's other like other than your
child's
like other than your baby mom yeah one
one other
but it's very sporadic it's not like oh
i speak to i probably speak to her like
twice a year
would you ever go back there
no
no why not
um because we broke up for a reason have
you ever broke is there ever a girl that
like got away
for you
why why why did she get away
oh that girl oh so you really you liked
her liked her
so
oh but she so she ended it though
yeah
i feel like there's a lot of guys that
like have an ex that they sort of
treated poorly when they were younger
maybe not you personally but i've like
run into the same store where like
guys have like a one girl that like got
away when they were younger that they
just met when they were too young
[Music]
what's my biggest red flag
yeah what's my biggest red flag
um
wouldn't it be a green flag because i
don't know how to talk to other guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's very true actually
um i don't think you could
you can be honest it's okay i'm just
wondering
mean you're a good um i don't think
there's like
if you're 25 right now like seriously
you're 25 you're single
you've got a good head on your shoulders
i feel like the youtube channel is a red
flag a little bit
oh that could be it
investing all of yeah time in that when
she's gonna have time for the
relationship et cetera et cetera so yeah
that may be a red flag yeah i think
i'm a really hard worker and it's very
hard to turn off
i feel like i have a very hard time
relaxing
and i know that's that's very like
masculine i guess
but that's just how my like family is
like everyone is just hard working like
people you know
like you don't understand our vacations
aren't even vacations like we work on
vacation like you you have to see the
whole country and like the limited
amount of time like you don't sleep
you go for the cracking on to like see
everything in the country like it's just
how even our vacations you like are kind
of working in a way
but
let me see what they said in the chat
what's a red flag
um
yeah no i think this is it they said you
need to read if i would say i think i
lack femininity i think that is like
definitely
like again i think i've always been like
a tomboy so that stuff's been like hard
for me
feminine women out there but it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're gonna be
great wives
what's mine sarah yeah
um
just his red flag
see i don't ask i don't know i don't
know what your team's dating history has
been like
you know
you both
[Music]
what does it say you give the
someone say you give up you don't you
aren't giving off the settle down but if
you're getting the get [__] done by
yeah i know
i know but like i always wonder like
but i'm just saying like that's kind of
just
it seems
no that she does
no they're talking about for me
and i was like i just don't think like i
think it'd be like kind of false
advertising because like i've always
just been the type to like try to like
if i have something i want to do i just
go after and do it and i don't know how
to like
change that about me you know
no i dropped everything i was doing to
help him actually i didn't even
yeah no i was actually i spent a lot of
time on him
so
no that would not be always voted
i know
i am i've been i've been wearing dresses
you've seen my dresses
yeah i see it yeah
yeah try to be less tomboyish what what
career path like what where what
industry should i go after like dudes
and what job
that's an interesting one
um
you can change everything about you it's
not that hard
that's an interesting one
maybe
but the thing is i could say lawyers i
could take doctors
i mean
look at things
[Music]
for for him like a career path that
makes it feasible for me to be a mother
you're saying a rancher tech industry
a carpenter
um a tech executive
you could be one of those
you know
the world's your oyster yeah i'll be
i'll be looking let me let me know if
you if you got any takers
i was about to
yeah let me know if you got any friends
looking for what
we were supposed to deep dive into your
dms
oh here
casino
let me show you i'll show you my d here
these are these are my message requests
okay
mention you in your story
here
has anyone said hey how you doing paul i
think the show's great
blah blah blah
are they hitting on me i thought they
were just telling me they like my show
oh come on
i would say
yeah but no
well some
i think it's easy to tell if a guy's
attracted to you but if he likes you
it's like
that's a little harder for me to tell
um
let's see
what do you think of this one
okay
all right so what you don't want also
you don't want a guy who like stares in
the mirror too much
so so no to him yes or no yeah you don't
want to die not this one okay
you know what i mean like guys that do
that [__] i'm just like just stop being
a [__]
okay how do we feel about
oh no kids okay
um
okay cool you got a nice body but you
don't want to be [__] staring me all
the time and
oiling yourself down like a [__]
stripper and [__]
[Music]
it's private
and these are the hidden message
requests let's see these
oh [__] so it's kind of i got a message
request and then i got hidden message
requests
it's like
how you doing jess
there you go
yeah i'm doing good this guy says marry
me
went home and washed my bits
and i'm refreshed now this is his
profile
you see
no she's on instagram
instagram
yeah
someone thought she was using the dating
app
no no
foofoo
when did we start talking about nigerian
food
i thought you'd i thought you weren't
coming back jess
no i told you i was coming back yeah i
thought you'd fall asleep
no
um
i thought yeah
yeah see how how have these dms look to
you so far i'm showing you them
so this guy was gonna go on a date
sometime
the fact that you agree with auntie is
proof enough that you'll be a great
woman find a man that respects
you that you respect and lay it down for
him
if you're attracted to him in the first
place
i'm not i'm not attracted to that guy
um
i'm not attracted to that guy i'm sorry
i can't
i have a type he's just not my type
okay let's see what he said
okay why does he keep sending me
[Music]
no that's another thing like it's okay
it's weird dating someone that watches
your content because it's like one-sided
like they have all this information on
you and you know nothing about them yeah
and it's like i don't know how to just
like you probably had it where they like
they're like oh i saw that you did this
this and this and you're like huh
yeah
that's very true i get the same thing
sometimes
but
is that are you trying to date for the
clout you trying to date
someone said pearl don't like beards or
muscular features her words
shrug emoji
i do i have been told i like more
feminine like faces lately
no not feminine feminine features like i
like pretty boys
but i think
i don't know i like
i don't know facially i don't really
have a t like wouldn't you say facially
i don't really have a type
hmm
[Music]
i'm trying to think
so hold on hold on
no
let me say this
okay first of all
those two are
uh
anomaly
okay
those
i would say okay okay yeah yeah yeah
okay okay i could see that
okay i do have a type
yes
of the two
yeah okay okay fair yep yep
lead attorney out smash lead attorney
i don't know if he's straight though but
like
i think i don't know lead attorney i've
lo i've shot my shot at leech attorney
he turned me down i'm so offended i'm
like i'm 25 and single and childless the
audacity
there's some k-pop members i've
absolutely shot my shot very nice
but no for me
it's like manosphere gold i'm like
you're like whatever
i think his instagram got banned so i
don't still have the messages
i absolutely did though i'll i'm uh
because my thing is i kind of look at it
like say
sale
what did you say
[Music]
i don't know because i'm telling you he
doesn't have like his instagram got
banned so like the thing is gone
[Music]
no i was probably more like
i think i probably should be like
what did i do i think it was
no no no no i think i i was like i just
sat like it was something direct that's
all i remember just being like yeah i
was shot down like it was something it
was something
like about either
why would you go in so hard
i should have gone hard i did because i
just feel like why play like
it wasn't like super crazy i can't
remember what it was
it might have been hard i'm kind of
directing
about women
you need to learn the art of subtlety a
subtlety so be subtle
yo
so don't be because to me it's like i
just i feel like why are we playing
these games if i like you like here like
i'll just tell you
okay cool
the chase was part of the actual
excitement
um but then like okay you chase then you
get her then what
no but it's part of the whole thing it's
part of the whole
fight
it's like it's part of the whole [__]
like look at me i look at you
basketball i meant pro basketball at u-o
my
jesse williams or michael b jordan
see those are my two types i would say
say it again jesse williams michael b
jordan like walmart versions of those
i mean i mean 99 cent store version of
those you haven't i would say
you've dated more dudes on the
michael b jordan side not jesse williams
okay yeah fair fair
it wouldn't be like sexual or anything
i'm just like yeah okay
sorry keep going okay so
those are your crushes yes here's your
hollywood crush
i don't know if i have one
i got asked this last time
denzel i don't know is
it what's his name
no no
um
uh
he's the one sorry i'm like kissing my
teeth in the mic um
he's one of you lots he's from here
uh desmond
um
desmond he's from snowfall
from snowfall
okay
franklin
sorry when i tell you i would have been
a ride or dive for franklin where you
need me to push these drugs at baby
where you need me drop them off i got
you i would have been a rider die for
franklin
okay
okay so you guys you ladies like quiet
i mean
that says holly no no
jess isn't like
no like i would say like the guys she's
dated haven't been like
no they're like they're not like this is
just celebrity like obviously the celeb
like that's why i said the walmart
version of that because
i mean i'm not like someone could say
i'm like donna from that 70s show but
i'm not i'm the walmart version of that
like you know what i'm saying so it's
like i don't but it's just like yeah
like quote unquote i you know
but i don't we don't
wait so why i can't why can't i tell
guys i like them thanks for the
membership
so you have to make them chase you i
just feel like
sorry you don't you tell me why why do
you have to make him chase you
oh no lucas okay girl
listen men men that are hunters
uh-huh
lucas
you don't just give him
don't just say here i am look okay oh as
a matter of fact i'm i'm a piece of me
uh
do you like me
oh i don't say that word for well
or anything
no lucas we're gonna read it i'm gonna
find him
don't give up lucas
don't let don't make it too easy
like
no oh don't do that all right i like you
i think you're great just like
all right
great
busting
you know
where's your laptop at pearl the
charging no
easy
petey pablo french montana
okay i'll
i'll be like never mind i take it back
no don't don't like
don't
[Laughter]
once you've said it you've said it you
know okay okay
for the future
you know you're gonna want to lucas
right it doesn't matter where he's at a
low-value man high-value man doesn't
matter
he still wants to fall like a man
they're like and they like to chase
they see something that they like
and they want to go for it so that's
just the nature of men generally once i
got checked out sometimes i do it in a
creepy way
and you know it stays a lot of women
off but they still want to be able to
say hey
and chase
but you know a lot of
yeah yeah you could be like my dating
coach you could teach me you could like
i'll like i'll give you my phone you can
just text for me
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh okay okay what do you guys think of
sarah giving me good advice let me know
in the chat should i listen to sarah yes
or no
let's see
traditional chases nonsense silliness
don't listen to this chase money not
women
guys don't listen to this chase money
not women
i'm not telling guys to chase women
goodness gracious people so do you know
i've noticed with somebody they're so
[__] triggered uh-huh
[__] out man oh now you got some yeses
yes maybe yes yes
no
no no
yeah 50 50.
listen
i'm at work
so
i gotta
do some work [__]
okay well
thank you sir i appreciate you thank you
[Music]
i this actually did i was falling asleep
this woke me up a little bit thanks
sarah you're the best
thanks for calling jess you're welcome
continue ladies and you've only got what
how many hours
like six
there you go
almost there
you go
oh my gosh
i'm an athlete
i mean one special
two for one special
you girls are in shape yes you're in
shape
we sure are
all right
[Music]
yes they do
they sure do
all right peace out folks bye sarah
lucas i found your i found your super
chats i told you i was gonna find them
all right lucas has
one oh my goodness
thank you 20 50 and 20.
and there's a 10 one uh
just takes all the chicken off a single
wing and see what happened
oh
i didn't see that
i was too busy killing
my wings
um
lucas says pearl
want a christian
want a christian gray type
a master i'll ask her when she comes
back
lucas
0 to 18 boys our children
18 to 30 boys are boys
if they did the work
and self-improvement they become men at
31.
interesting
lucas okay dm
rape me
not a brit
but a global order but it's a global
order okay
my phone's about to die so let's see if
i get to you lucas
see lucas i told you
i told you what i was going to do and i
held my end of the bargain we'll wait
till pearl gets back
how's everybody doing in the chizzy yet
thank you michael for becoming
a member
sup just woke up thank you for joining
awesome
you guys want to see ellie
but you guys can hear her in the back
just pan away
[Laughter]
we still in this b
i'm the only one i don't know where ish
went i don't know where pearl went
um
is it karaoke time where's doug it's
doug in the chat
this is
ellie that's who's breathing like that
ellie yo
you always breathing hard like you just
ran a mile you just walked across the
floor
question
sorry if i speak a lot of spanish guys
i do that on a reg
okay she's chilling out so she might not
pant as much
it's worse now because she's going to
tell me
oh thanks
thanks guys
you guys want asmr
i'm just here to entertain y'all cause
i'm the only one
um
i would
zoom in i don't know how to work these
cameras like that
speak that spanish
so the story
the story with my uh
friend back home
i mean we're still friends like that
wasn't gonna change
but
i didn't when we had that conversation
the first time i was like all right yeah
okay come out here date whatever
back my mind i was like it's not gonna
happen because i just know him and i was
like he was like yeah i'm gonna come out
there in september i was like oh all
right
after we got off the phone i was like
it's not gonna happen
he's not coming out here in september
it's not gonna happen so
all you lots
got excited for no reason
puppy asmr
i'm not about to go through pearl's dm
yeah y'all can puppy spanish
um
nationality
american
ethnicity
black
that's all i can give you
sorry i said i'm a sigma
so no alpha beta just sigma
wow lucas
you're the best i hope you
get better lucas
because that's not good
y'all i i can't speak spanish fluently
so i only
know
certain things
free spanish lessons will it help me to
stop will it help me to talk fluently
i know it's not september yet but
i'm the one that usually helps him
gets flights
get flights
and
i haven't he hasn't been like yeah like
help me get a flight i'm coming out
there so
although it's not september
it's not gonna happen
my phone is not charged
um
and i don't have a plug by me
uh
yeah no
okay
um 90 frito pie i
uh yeah sure we could do patricia
[Music]
question
um
yeah
[Music]
i feel like we can sit back
relax um
uh me maybe uh thank
[Music]
shoes but rather with the goal of
silencing any discussion of men's issues
like at ottawa university when professor
janice fiamango attempted to give a
lecture that questioned the feminist
narrative
so you think this is a victory
yeah why are you so frightened of
hearing an opinion different from your
own
then there was the first international
conference on men's issues in michigan
where even ms magazine urged its readers
to protest the conference in hopes of
shutting it down
it's blue
it's
[Music]
highlighted but perhaps the most
well-known protest of a pro-men's rights
event happened in april 2013 at the
university of toronto when the canadian
association for equality hosted a
discussion titled from misogyny and
misandry to intersexual dialogue
[Music]
um
[Applause]
our member of the week hello sentients
listen to sarah because he actually
stood for his viewers views about
genders on the big last big podcast a
man who's confident and knows where he
stands can guide you
it's up to you if you want to follow it
okay
i'm sorry i just when i like a guy i
just try to make him obsessed with me
okay let's continue
a feminist group protesting the event
illegally pulled the fire alarm and
successfully shut down the event
[Applause]
once outside the lecture hall feminist
protesters and men's rights activists
got to speak face to face
shut the [__] up for a second
feminists do not want you to lose
custody of your children the assumption
that women are naturally better
caregivers is part of patriarchy
feminists do not like commercials in
which bumbling dads mess up the laundry
and competent wives have to bustle in
and fix it the assumptions
a list of the things that we're working
towards now if you would shut the [__]
up for the 50th billion times what did
we agree on these are things that were
really wrong
and these are things that you've
actually all got skewed [__] views on
you think that feminists are trying to
take away your [__] rights but as a
matter of fact what we're trying to do
is we're actually trying to work on the
same things that you're working on but
accept the fact that you're so too bit
you're just too busy hating women
i'm lost for words
she seems like a fun girl at parties i'm
like if you're trying to if you're
trying to communicate with someone
and
yeah just how how do you think you're
going to properly communicate to someone
if you're
coming at it that way like if you want
to get your point across and prove a
point and say hey this is actually what
we're doing
and they're not listening okay cool but
you don't have to
approach it like that
that's my thought it's like
you want to make change you want to
talk to somebody like talk to them like
a freaking human being are you saying
screaming in someone's face isn't the
way to
get your point across
you know
not at all damn it i was gonna try that
[Laughter]
work on those same situations are you
conflating feminism which is an ideology
with women which is a demographic of
societies okay
are for dummies okay
you're still hanging an ideology yes
okay i hate a lot of other islands so
you admit though racism
[__] [__] [__] you hate
sexism but you're an mra okay no point
take it we
yeah it's because i wish i was there for
this
i'm just in like one
you're like a four
she's this girl's like red has like
three um this girl's like a four she
probably could be a six but like i don't
know why do feminists make themselves
uglier that's why i don't get it
because the only reason
women say the only reason why
they do things or
they're sexualized so if they're not
pretty they can't be sexualized hmm
beating the patriarchy i think maybe
they make themselves ugly to say like
i'm not trying to be pretty
yeah they're like mad
so they can't say i'm not being pretty
for a man i'm being pretty for myself
anyways
um we'll continue
do not want you to have to make alimony
payments alimony is set up to combat the
fact that women have been historically
expected to prioritize domestic duties
over professional goals thus minimizing
their earning potential if they're
traditional marriages
oh my god
okay y'all
boo freaking who you make less money
but like
i don't understand oh no
you didn't have to work
i'm crying a [__] river jesus christ
like
oh no oh no i got to not work for 20
years
and now i have to get a job if i get
divorced yeah
you have to get a job just like everyone
else has to get a job
literally
well i i wouldn't earn as much because
you made the choice to stay home
yep
anyway
oh i have to get a job
they're lazy everybody has to get a job
i'm reading [__] face
i'm trying to [__] i'm letting
everybody else hear it okay
it's not just for you mr entitled
the assumption that wives should
why do you think
the men's rights move sitting there
trying to understand what you're saying
from what i've seen and you're
shouting over him talking over him but
he's the one that's entitled i feel like
ugly girls shouldn't have an opinion
dang
yeah same with fat chicks dang
i mean they could have one but does
anyone care like literally no one care
it's really sad but like
no one cares if you're like ugly
what you say it goes for men too that's
true
like people get treated harsh yeah it's
just harsh reality reality
movement is at odds with feminism what
has created that clash and that war
between each other
well
one feminism has spent the last 50 years
demonizing men which is sort of one of
the problems feminist scholars have
characterized men as inherently violent
inherently bad inherently predatory
inherently oppressive they have
postulated that masculinity is a disease
feminists aren't the only problem
they didn't the problems didn't start
with feminism
so when i start criticizing feminism i
want you to know
you're just
part of the problem they're just part of
the problem
you calling
men oppressors and women oppressed
demonizes men
and i believe diminishes women at the
same time it's a way of telling men to
shut up it's a way of telling men that
their experiences don't matter you tell
a man he's privileged
therefore anything he's gone through or
anything he has to say doesn't matter
his lived experiences don't matter
because he's privileged
[Music]
so how old were you when you started
calling yourself a feminist or how many
years ago
oh it's probably about
three years ago i guess you can say i'm
relatively new
yeah but i'm pretty loud so
violence only helps the oppressor not
the oppressed
a lot of mra say that feminism doesn't
fight for the rights of men
what would you say to that
primary river
really because feminism is a movement
about the
discrepancies when it comes to
women's equality because we're not up
we're still not there yet you know so
don't don't even start with that whole
oh but you don't think about the men's
issue well then you know what start your
own goddamn movement which they have but
maybe make it a little more about
legitimate issues like custody and
alimony and things that you think are
unequal which all stem from patriarchy
not from oh my god feminists are trying
to take away our kids
no [__] that's not what we're trying
to do we're not trying to do that i mean
if they look at the root causes of
why
for example
you know women get custody more often
than men do
women are supposed to be the mothers
they're supposed to be the natural born
caregivers so obviously duh you has a
vagina so obviously you're going to be
able to take care of the kiddies
that's that's really what it is it all
steps
miss andrey
no just because you have a freaking
vagina doesn't mean that you can take
care of a child
a lot of these mothers out here just ass
trash so trash that they shouldn't
their child themselves taking care of a
child
it's like just because you have a vagina
you can take that is the
dumbest thing just because you have a
vagina you can take care of a child
so we don't need men
to have children we don't need men to
make children because we have a vagina
we could take care of a child we can
make a child by ourselves too you know
that bro
yeah you're right we just don't need men
at all i guess
yeah i just
let's just you know not have any firemen
police officers just yeah and it's like
they minimize the value of the dads when
they do they actually like you don't
need a frickin dad in the home yeah
especially when okay i think doing the
in vitro [__] is selfish and i know
someone that did that and i literally
think it's selfish
because especially if you don't have a
dad because why would you put your kid
at every statistical disadvantage
because you didn't choose to prioritize
dating in the last 30 years
i i only
only scenarios i've seen than vitro
is in a couple relationship yeah no i'm
talking about like the girls
yeah
comes from sexism against women
it's just the oppression
dialectic needs to go
it's so hard
to convince people
to look at men's rights activism and
support it without first allowing them
to at least
escape the stranglehold
that feminism has on their minds
i do believe it is dogma
it's zealotry
there are good people in a feminist
moment
[Music]
there are not good people in the radical
feminist movement
[Music]
that system is based on hate
and hate is pr in my opinion hates most
destructive force in the world
they're so quick to call us man haters
or sanders
miss andrew knight no
like they're so quick to say that when
we're all we're doing is talking about
like patriarchal societies and
structures that we want to dismantle
um
nothing against men in particular but
just saying hey this is a system that we
live in and this puts men above women
and it's not necessarily their fault but
hey recognize what's happening here and
let's work together to dismantle it the
omnipotent ever-present patriarchy
the invisible force that
directs all of our lives
right and causes all oppression and all
suffering
right
our devil
and
the beautiful
wonderful force for justice feminism the
way
it's the way
it sounds like religion
and oh my goodness for a a movement
that's only about equality
and isn't blaming of men
they name the force for evil after men
and the force for justice after women
and this being a movement is very very
very concerned
little girls from aspiring i don't want
a firewoman if i'm in a burning building
and a girl comes and saves me i'm going
to tell her to leave because now we're
both going to die
only way i would want a fire woman to
come and save me if it was like a butch
bolo type chick
so if i'm in a building we're tall
they ain't carrying us if it if he was
tall and
bolo
yeah okay you can take the butch lesbian
i'll take the man i was saying if
if
that was my last resort between life and
death i'd be like
girl
sir ma'am whatever you are you better
drag
firefighters
and sometimes just discourage grown
women from aspiring to be firefighters
right by calling them firemen what we
can call the force for all oppression
we call that
essentially men hatred
right and we can call the force for good
injustice women
and that kind of language
that has no implications
we're not blaming men
we just named everything bad after them
they're really angry and they're angry
at women they're angry and feminine
swimming there um
but yes men have gotten a crappy deal
but it's not the fault of women or gay
people okay when feminism says that they
have no part in any of this i think
they're not being honest about it i
don't blame feminism for all of it but i
think they've had a role in it they've
written laws that discriminate against
men they fought to protect those laws
particularly in domestic violence areas
and for many many years second wave
feminism
would go through the statutes and change
everything that was gender specific to
something gender neutral unless it was
something that benefited women like the
domestic violence laws they didn't
change those other types of areas like
fathers in prison their statutes that
specifically give mothers certain
benefits that fathers in prison don't
have and i challenged that as well
legally but we didn't win on that one
when i wanted to get a commission on men
like the county has a commission on
women the feminist fought that tooth and
nail
when prop 209 was before the california
voters
which was to end affirmative action
every feminist organization opposed it
every time men's rights groups tried to
pass joint custody legislation feminist
groups fight them they fought us on
paternity fraud the biggest opposition
that i have faced
has been from the radical feminists that
said we don't want truth to be the
standard because if we did
they wouldn't oppose automatic dna
testing at birth
pass smash
and in countries like france they're
saying well
dna should mean do not ask his accent
because it's now illegal to even get a
test and if you get a test without the
mother's permission you will be
criminally prosecuted that's
that's insane
they just banned them in france because
too many dudes were figuring out that
the kid wasn't theirs
they like banned it apparently according
to the chat anyways
a paternity test yeah paternity tests
that's
disgusting
that
yo what
in sweden they tried to create a man tax
man
the men's rights movement is trying to
get the rape laws to include male
victims and the feminist groups
apparently are fighting that
i'm not saying all feminists are this
way but i think the ones who are
affecting public policy who have the
lobbying power i think they are if you
just look at their actions they don't
want equality for women
they want special privileges for women
and girls and even though they know in a
lot of areas men do not have equality
they are silent
the commander of the marine corps said
that he thinks and i quote all eligible
and qualified men and women should
register for the draft talking about
selective service do you think women
should also have to register for
selective service like men
i have to think about whether
good old hillary
uh i think it's necessary to go
as far as our military
officers are recommending
the idea of
snoring the paint off the wall
yeah annika
blessing
okay you're snoring bud snoring the pain
off the wall bruh
having everybody register
uh
concerns me a little bit unless we have
a better idea of where that's gonna come
out
he said the 24-hour stuff is mad
blessing how's it going
you've only been here for a couple hours
you come the first half have ish come
the second half
yeah why'd you let ish give you the
night shift
[Laughter]
oh he picked it
this is what happens when you're built
different i'm built different yeah
where i want people to register i want
every young person to register at the
age of 18
to be able to vote automatically and i
think yeah
when is that coffee shop opened
the one over there
yeah i think ten
no way
i think so a coffee shop
is in london
sunday
i feel like that's the most busy day for
coffee no no no at nine no
what yeah we're still watching it
we're almost done
[Music]
what's the motivation people don't ask
what's the motivation do we need a men's
rights movement no we need common sense
no but if there's what
uh you could you could switch it with
the pink one
you got six more hours
there's no more people coming today it's
just me and jess
yeah you can just swap them there's
going to be nice chairs in the new place
thank you
you're a little bit clumsy today
are you always clumsy or is it just
today
[Laughter]
yeah
okay we are almost done
there's going to be this woman's
movement and this is the movement that's
going to do all these things
then maybe we need a counterbalance they
call the men's men's rights movement or
a men's movement
but i hate to see either one of them
i think it's a shame i think it's
destructive
i'm hearing what the men's rights
activists are saying
jesus and i'm finding the sources to
support what they're saying
men are just as likely to be victims of
intimate partner physical violence
men have little to no control over their
parental destiny especially when he's
tricked into fatherhood or he's raising
a child that he later finds out isn't
his
the sentencing disparity between men and
women is six times larger than the
sentencing disparity between blacks and
whites
so while a black man may be sentenced to
10 percent more prison time for the same
crime as a white man
a man is sentenced to over 60 percent
more prison time than a woman arrested
for the same crime
boys are falling behind in education
they are enrolling at lower rates and
earning less college degrees
and while not all mras agree on the
issue of infant male circumcision most
mras do believe it is a human rights
violation what do you think i spent
what circumcision
is that like bad
because they're saying it's like they
shouldn't be forced to be circumcised at
a baby um
i mean i don't know if i have a right to
talk about it but i hear that if you
don't get it
a lot of bacteria can get up in there i
don't know
yeah i couldn't talk it's just
because it's like it's the
it's the fold of the
it's the foreskin essentially and if you
don't
if you don't get
it sniffed off you can get
a lot of stuff underneath there
is that correct chat or yeah let me look
at the chat section okay
that's that's my knowledge of it
i would say that
yes
yes you
you should get it done because something
can get up in there and you can get it
infected possibly i may be wrong but if
you don't want to get it done you know
that's
that's real different than
anyways i don't know i could i like
literally have no idea
once learning about infant male
circumcision
but it only took me watching a
five-minute medical training video
to convince me this is a barbaric
practice that needs to stop okay so
first thing make sure he's well
restrained oh god look at this
okay and we repeat the process with just
all that was left a partial penis and
his tiny testicles rhodes says ashton
urinates through a hole in his penis she
says she can't imagine now what she'll
say to her son when he's old enough to
understand what's happened to him how
could you explain it to your child that
you don't have a penis or you might
never be able to have kids
oh a botched one
jesus
if a dude's a 10
but he has a botched penis what is he
i mean if you still
work
you know damn near santa town it's
you can barely have sex
that i'm not gonna be with them
i know that could see like that could
ruin that dude's life
i mean obviously sex isn't everything
but if i decide
i would say seven
that's so sad
yes men are the majority of workplace
deaths and injuries
war deaths
suicides
they have a shorter life expectancy
warren farrell makes the argument that
prostate cancer and breast cancer
mortality rates are similar but funding
disproportionately supports breast
cancer research and awareness over
prostate cancer
the red pill
is about
looking at these issues in an honest way
even when it's i think it's genital
manipulation in the chat was it really
that's i mean that's what they're saying
hmm
wow
that is not what i
imagine 75 of 150 million men having
genital manipulation done on them
because of fashion
i'm pissed i got cut at birth
how is it
even if it's not botched it's still
torture manipulation
how
you lose sensitivity i guess
my goodness
is it more than just like the foreskin
then
i'm asking the chat
mutilate they're saying mutilation
horrible anyone that harms a kid
deserves a rope
imagine cutting off the hood of your
labia
it desensitizes the penis
the hood of the labia i mean
okay
um
that's interesting
pearl it's mutilation i don't know guys
i don't know anything about
just keep it's uncomfortable and it
these things are uncomfortable but
without
the willingness
to set aside the program and to set
aside the false beliefs about what power
is and what women are
and who women are part of what we do
is a pretty serious critique of both
sexes
it's brutal
but critiquing the sexes is a real
valuable thing
feminists don't want you to do it though
unless you're portraying women as victim
and men as perpetrator
the red pill
is about understanding
men and women like everything else in
life it's a mixed bag you've got victims
and perpetrators on both sides of the
fence
and that's all it's it's real simple
it's just not easy
i'm
i think i agree with everything you said
but there's there's still some kind of
unsettling
doubt and i don't know where that's
coming from
i'm recognizing all of these very
serious men's rights issues
but what i don't understand
is how
i could be agreeing with men's rights
activists
is this the same misogynist hate group i
originally discovered online
the southern poverty law center has
classified that group and men's rights
groups as hate groups
i looked into what i was hearing from
feminists and the mass media about the
men's rights movement
i've read a lot and i've heard a lot
that the
the men's rights movement has been
labeled a hate group by the southern
poverty law center is that correct
that's not quite true no they got it
wrong no we this was somehow written up
on some kind of anti-men's rights uh
websites as we us have listed them as
hate groups
he
wrote a piece
declaring the month of october to be
bash a violent [__] month
jesus
i mean literally to grab them by the
hair and smack their face against the
wall he wrote
i mean if they're being violent towards
you i then discovered that paul elim's
famous basha violent [__] article was
written in response to this article by
jezebel called have you ever beat up a
boyfriend because uh we have
the article cited a study that revealed
70 percent of non-reciprocated violence
was perpetuated by what i always quote
the women the author
you see this that's crazy
when i found out this stat i was like
shut the [__] up
but it makes sense because women don't
get in trouble for anything of course
they're gonna hit men
yeah
to say that she conducted an informal
survey at the office and the gist of her
findings was that many women had
physically assaulted their man
and it was interpreted as either being
funny
or he was asking for it
i couldn't help but see the hypocrisy in
a major feminist website making light of
abusing men
and mras stinging back only to have the
media paint them as the abusers
something else to think about arriving
on campus
boys
will also see the effects of women's
studies programs now usually termed
gender studies programs
make no mistake about it however they
they are still women's studies programs
um i teach
in the gender studies program at wagner
there are about 900 such programs
worldwide and about 400 of them are in
the states if i compare
uh
this is horrible this is like the
order should we order starbucks
i don't even i don't drink starbucks
they have a matcha latte i'll take that
all right
let's
let's go
should we finish this we're almost there
okay this is never happening again
never
this is the last one
i'm not even gonna say anything pro
you make the decisions around here
hey
i have a feeling that it's not
can you pass my
phone for me please
can you pass in my phone please
thanks darling
got a little bit of juice
and sometimes i go out by myself
and i look across the water
[Music]
blessing blessings you got a girl right
how's that going
you in love
yeah
oh
we love love oh
[Music]
funny
you don't know she's just different
how old are the freak is doing a 48 hour
live stream a million subs
no
no whoever said 48 hours
no no no
absolutely not
but
i mean
i mean i think hear me out
by then i'll have
talent hear me out hear me out okay i'm
crazy by then
i'll have signed people
and i can have people switch off
love sorry
auntie do eight don't look at me because
i ain't doing eight
no
they say do it do it shh you know that
if y'all say do it she will hush
show the puppy
pearl's taller
please patrice o'neill elephant in the
room that's been requested
haven't we listened to that
is that the
comedy we're gonna finish this video
order starbucks and we can do patrice
sonia
it landed on you okay i was like
my room is like a war zone for
mosquitoes
you thought i was just grabbing you yeah
okay mike you do it
what you do it mike
calling us a coward you do it let's see
you go live for 48 hours on your channel
and we'll watch they call me a [__] now
i mean
no no no no
no this is the last one guys this is the
last 24-hour live stream
i shouldn't have promised you guys this
last time
i shouldn't have did it the first time i
knew it was a horrible idea
check
i said show the puppy or else 48 hour
stream ellie
show the puppy or else we're being held
hostage now do you feel like we get
closer to each other because of this
i think so like we went through
something like we went you don't have
like
you know some guys like go to war
together yeah this is our war
see we went to war guys
women's rights
[Music]
women's rights yeah
ellie
ellie betty okay honey pikachu you said
ma matcha come here
are you so matcha
[Laughter]
that's all you want to do is play
see we showed the we showed the puppy so
we don't have to do a 48 hour live
stream um
bro
dog
did
couch i feel like it's about that time
ellie
ellie ellie ellie
forget those quartz under here
it says
at one million sub swirling just have to
get a radical feminist haircut
no it's taking me like three years to
grow up my hair taking me my whole life
too so no i mean we can get wigs
oh my gosh
got me ready
come on there she is
she has to go on that side because the
thing is in the way what's in the way
that's in the way
so nobody wants to oh this okay
i was just kind of trying to get her to
stop being annoying
i do love you though dawg
you gotta fix your nose i got
50 hours at 5 million subs
y'all are interesting
to those who did say we did like
no no no no hear me out for real say we
did
a party at a million subs
who all in the chat would fly out to
wherever pearl is
and attend that party
put a what number should they put in the
chat
put a mill put a mill in the chat if you
would come to wherever pearl is brothers
overseas or in the states for that party
okay ellie you're doing the most
is that it
i think she's gonna go out
you know it's okay i got her
okay
chill out
okay sounds good
sometimes i go ill that's nasty
and i look crawl i don't know why i had
that song stuck in my head
all right wow
pearl is gone
it
yeah
y'all the writer dies
ah
daniel
don't say that
akubano
i haven't had a cubano and years of
cuban sandwich yo
some things are
delicioso i have one in miami oh my days
i miss it i mean if you want to send me
one to london
that would be great
as long as the puppy comes with a puppy
i'm pretty sure the puppy will be there
if they allow dogs at wherever we are
oh
that's begun
a torta cubano i don't think i've had a
tortoise
bilber
we've heard him i mean we haven't
listened to him but someone told us that
i think earlier
kimitanga
ah daniel yes they are
i think i had one before i had one
before um i went to miami at this place
in georgia
but then
i had it in miami and oh my goodness i
about cried
um
my ethnic background i've said this so
many times on here i'm just i'm just
black from my knowledge i haven't taken
an ancestry
my family doesn't know
our background
we just blit
mom's from michigan no my mom's from
ohio that's from michigan like i have
like
relatives that are from the south like
that's where they were at and they
migrated north
but um other than that
oh
tacos
those ones
yo
so good
no stop stop i can't talk about mexican
food
because i love it and i miss it they
have it out here but it ain't the same
as in california
i won't be back there for a few months
so
oh
i will lucas i promise you remind me
rhyming when she gets back i will i will
i will just as soon as she sits down
put it in there and then
once we finish it i will
uh
i will watch him call it i will tell her
check out patrice sonia women are just
wrong
or looking between the new shark theory
okay
we'll do that
uh
jeezy on 250k
just in pearl
looking to male circumcision is
absolutely insane
really i'm so
i'm so
[Music]
my whole life i thought male
circumcision was one thing and
i think i might be
scarred as to what it is
um
okay i will screenshot these
oh i had a
house oh
marcus i was about to fire on you i was
like how is this what's this culture
appropriation
i speak i speak a little bit spanish
and we're just it's food we're just
talking about food
um
okay free agent i've never gotten that
before
what is a woman matt wash okay
my name is jess or jessica but people
resort to just after i tell them hey i'm
jessica they're like oh yes
so
yes
um someone asked if i had a youtube
channel i do
it is the name of it is it's your girl
just not just it's your girl jess
um
yes i'm from l.a i wasn't born in l.a i
was born in loma linda but raised in
michigan
but now i
moved back to california
so that's a little bit of my life
um
bye mark oh
have a good sleep thanks for coming
i know doug isn't it crazy she's came a
long way it's grown so much
i don't know what that means i left
there
goodness
i'm a woman on a mission
all right
you are
okay
you ready yeah
900 programs worldwide there is one
men's studies program
in four years center for men and
masculinities is to be established at a
state of new york university the one at
stony brook
it will be headed by professor michael
kimmel a sociologist
its advisors will include probably among
the advisors are our funders as well the
actress and fitness expert jane fonda
gloria steinem
and steve emsler the author of china
after my year of filming men's rights
activists and feminists
my descent into the rabbit hole was not
slowing down
my education on gender politics was
really just beginning
i learned about other sectors of the
online manosphere like mgtow men going
their own way
and a forum on reddit called the red
pill which is separate from the men's
rights community and they do not see eye
to eye
i'm told an easy way to remember the
difference is that while mras want to
change the system
reddits the red pill want to take
advantage of the system
and mgtow want to leave the system
there are so many perspectives on gender
and i believe they are all worthy of
listening to however
the conversation is being silenced
for a society to accept anything said on
behalf of women's rights
and then to shame any dialogue about
men's rights and call it hate speech is
precisely the problem
i don't know where i'm headed but i know
what i left behind
i no longer call myself a fella
oh
i guess that's
it does it cut out
yeah that's it awesome
amazing
all right blessing
i'm gonna need you to type
what are we watching next patrice o'neal
y'all i know i only have a few videos on
my channel i am stepping it up it's just
because i got me myself and i like it
when we move it's gonna be a game
changer yeah and i'm in the middle of
dissertation
um
lucas i got you
um someone said
hola mami estas
i don't know if that was for both of us
you know what that means
he said
hello
mommy
you are very beautiful
okay
okay so lucas what what are we reacting
to next
um a lot of people have been saying
uh patrice o'neill have we done the
elephant in the room is that the first
one we did
i don't know
it was like
for true so neil savage moments or some
[__] like that okay so people have been
saying patrice o'neill elephant in the
room that's been the one that a lot of
people have said okay also we need to
rate lucas who's lucas um i
screenshotted his uh super chats on
type in does he have an instagram yeah
he does that's what i'm saying i
screenshotted it on your phone
the super chat
oh well what's his instagram it's on the
super chat
okay
um
right there
uh type in
elephant in the room
it's coleman
okay it coleman
okay
nah it's not for uh
it's not for a doctorate for a master's
degree
so you won't be calling me dr jess
ah
see lucas i told you he doesn't have an
instagram
he doesn't yeah i looked up the name
yeah i think we did this top one
i think we did elephant in the room
that's not i don't think that one's
elephant in the room
is it i think so it's the top one that
came up patrice o'neill elephant in the
room we watched it then they said um
the other one they said was women are
just wrong
or sharp could you add women are just
wrong
y'all what do we got to do to get you to
be members
hear me out we're trying to pay our rent
with this membership money there's been
quite a few people that have um
signed up today i know i'm trying to get
some more
let me guys i just want to know what
what value can we offer you
what when you pay five bucks a month
what do you want to get out of that
it coleman 83 i'll look him up
i i tried it didn't come up
okay women are just wrong
[__] better have my money you know i
always said i know i know why um i i
know exactly why michael richards and
pee wee herman
why their careers suffer
is because they have put themselves out
there
as these people who were like fun-loving
their carrot clowns are just yay yeah
yeah so when one goes ah [__] and the
other one is jerking off
um he has a kids show it's like he was
living a lie and when people expose you
for lying like the tiger woods thing i
always thought he should go hey man look
my wife if he hadn't said this my wife
won't lick my [__] yeah i love it
licked yeah
this waitress licks my [__] yeah
i should be able and when should he have
said that exactly as soon as they put
him in a corner as soon as i noticed
something about this is talking about
comedy yeah i noticed when i'm i noticed
a long time when i'm bombing yeah
uh
when i'm bombing
the worst thing to ever do is try to not
bomb the best thing to do is take
everybody
to die everyone dies
i don't i'm not dying yeah you're gonna
die yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not gonna
try to win you back because i notice
about people yeah people are hot when
power corrupts when the audience sees
that you're struggling and then you're
trying not to struggle and you need them
not to struggle they get worse they
don't get better to try to help you dig
yourself they wanna they said we didn't
watch elephant in the room we watched
clips
oh okay
okay i'll get the thing
um
oh
i swore we watched that but we watched
clips we watched a compilation okay
let's stand up
[Music]
is this it guys
[Applause]
thank you
i'm thinking one in particular
fed titties in the front row
thank you so much
thank you audience coordinator for
putting those titties up in the front
row god bless you
[Applause]
that was distracting me i was supposed
to come out
man
[Applause]
yeah oh y'all here
by the way yes you do you should do
congratulations my friend i'm glad y'all
here it's very good yo congratulations
to you
my friend look at that white woman
you're with god
[Applause]
yo
for real
that white woman's amazing isn't she
telling the truth
he's with his black girl for like no oh
no but that she's high level that's a
high level white
look at sikadelo
okay
he doesn't answer he's dead to me
he just texted you
yeah i'm like i know you see me calling
oh my god the audacity
bruh
fine white woman right there that white
woman is that is man oh man oh man
black women get mad at that but that is
top shelf white woman right there
[Applause]
you know you can tell how pretty a white
woman is
the value you look at her and then you
wonder how long they would look for she
was missing yeah you get my text
you guys look like you're both about to
fall asleep hi koby
don't stop it i look great now anyways
um
my eyes are so open um
now
did you hear me say that you're dead to
me on screen
yeah okay
um
because you just texted me i was like
the audacity i didn't get your i didn't
get your call it was a facetime audio
that's not a real call
whatever okay um can you give me jordan
peterson
no
why not
maybe he's coming in september
oh yeah yeah
what are you guys watching right now
patrice o'neil
oh
what is he doing
he's a comedian
he's like a red pill comedian yeah
i don't know he died so
what he did yeah he's dead
he died a couple years ago a couple
years ago
all right
did you see the clips with auntie were
were great they're so good
yeah this that show was uh good today
oh my god
i think chris we gotta clip this whole
thing
i know the
that one girl kept trying to overtalk me
i was getting so irritated
yeah did she uh
was she salty when she left or what
not really i kind of just like don't
care after we're done
so she might have been i just like
didn't care
yeah
um
what do you gotta say um
but for real though i think like he's
coming
why wouldn't he do it we're the fastest
growing up yeah he's coming to london in
september he has a tour let me let me
see he has a tour that he's doing
right right right
very good
yeah but uh
i don't know he's not he's not red pill
you know
i don't know if he's gonna like you i
think he's gonna think that you're uh
you're
maybe i'm wrong he reposted our video
posted our video tweeted it that's right
that's right that's right yeah but that
was just one video you know he hasn't
seen you destroy the 304s
yet fully
he'd like me
i'm positive he'd like me
all right
very good okay uh it's one again here
i'm going to bed um i'm playing airsoft
tomorrow i'm going airsofting oh yeah
instead of instead of doing the meeting
so oh that's fun
wish me luck
all right have fun enjoy the stream
don't fall asleep what the i don't
why can't i fall asleep on the street
[Music]
he said it's one o'clock i'm leaving bye
one am it's light work here
where's your about to fall asleep it's
six foot seven
go take a nap pearl no no i'm built the
fresh
[Applause]
come on take a look take a look look at
this [__]
i saw you look mad sweetie how long if
he was missing how long do you think
they were
how long did they do exactly she don't
even she went
if you know the deal i ain't saying
nothing wrong white women's life is
valuable
what's his name you're in uh vandersloot
right
we find out he was a serial kill man he
kills women that's what he do he do it
well
you know what i mean we know the girl
that he that he you know supposedly had
uh what's girl in aruba
natalie holloway
right
but the one he just killed a girl in
peru what's her name um
exactly
[Applause]
look how fast you say now you said
natalie natalie
holloway
y'all said that like family feud all
right name a white girl been missing for
five years in the room lily holloway
survey says
name a peruvian girl that was killed
yesterday
[Applause]
what is that big head third world
peruvian bitch's name
it has to be yotis or something goofy
don't get mad at yourself i gave it to
you you saw how fast she said natalie
holloway
diana ross right here said she knew her
name
that white girl with natalie holloway
man you called yourself uh whoa
god bless you man that is high level
right then don't be ashamed of it
gorgeous
she mad as hell [__] that white [__]
you know come on come on
ain't nobody looking for you i might
look for you but the news ain't you
[Applause]
you think fox is reporting you missing
let's be honest nancy grace she leads
story on nancy grace
for the next six months
i look at her because she's mad as hell
black we don't like that [__] but it is
what it is let's be
i don't want to be like that let's just
let's be honest
that little girl that went missing um
she was sailing little girl was saying i
forgot damn it but she was she went
sailing and went missing in the indian
ocean okay
and
they spent
good lord her mask broke and she was
floating around and she gave out her
little signal her beacon they look for
they spend 500 thousand dollars like tax
money to search for her
now that's my daughter i want that to
happen too but
but
if you go sailing
let's be honest how long you think they
gonna spend five come on remember hey
remember football players in miami went
missing they went sailing they looked
for them for eight minutes
maybe they just sent somebody at the
edge of the beach
i don't
i don't see them we have to call off the
search because it's too much sun
uh
the sun the conditions are abnormally
difficult
if i go sailing i'm taking a white baby
on a key chain with me
if my boat go down they gonna find me
i'm gonna have it hook right to the side
of my belt
and i'm gonna dress the baby real white
too i'm gonna uh put sweatpants on it
and
a pair of ugg boots and i'm
gonna take a picture
[Applause]
and look at this white baby you don't
come get me this white baby going down
with
[Applause]
me i hate how much fun black people can
have racially man it's just
i can say anything i goddamn want
racially and why people have to sit
there and take it
i am evil yes he's like come on man
i don't even say it because of that i
like i i love i love a little ratio yes
look man you know
let's be fair i mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game i
mean it it i like to talk to you know
white people about being honest about uh
obama
you gave it a shot
you did
you gave it a two year shot like oh yeah
i tried i tried to
we tried to
but you not it's not it's just it fell
apart it really
it really did and i'm gonna tell you
something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side
uh then talking white we would be on
your side a lot more if you would uh you
know just not ever talk
about how you feel
about anything
racial we'll catch up to you not serious
because black people are on the edge of
going what the [__] is obama doing
but it's too many white people outwardly
hating him so we can't we go if you shut
the you shut up
i'll be against them like stop
i'm running rallies and all kinds of
stuff
i'm telling you i'm this close to
i'm mad at him cause i thought i would
have a white slave but i thought
i thought it was vengeance
i dave to have me a white family oh big
old fat white girl go warm my bed up get
upstairs susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and
i'm gonna go outside and stare your
husband in the face and decide whether
i'm going to sell them or not
you know your wife's upstairs warming up
my bed you know that right
philip
[Applause]
that's uncomfortable in it that's
something that's uncomfortable i
apologize
can't we move on we'll move on we'll
move on to something
they don't even like that and play
that's uncomfortable right to think
about that but
what you gonna do
i like it look dave my days are numbered
so i just want to have as much fun as
possible you know what i mean i'm 40 and
uh and that's that's
that's young in everyone else years but
uh
in black years i you know high blood
pressure
diabetes i am uh
if you do the black to white life ratio
i'm a hundred
and seventy seven-year-old
[Applause]
i'm old as a mother i'm old
and i want to live
but here's why i messed up i messed up
my young years and i realized something
i'm gonna tell you if you're over 40 and
you're trying to better yourself
just
just stop it's just
you're not going to better yourself and
when i say you're not going to better
yourself i mean better yourself like go
back to when you try to
capture
the things you used to do when you
supposed to had did it but you didn't do
it you feel me so the stuff that you
were 18 and didn't do now you're 40 and
you're going i'm gonna make a trash just
it's not make me sick more than somebody
40 and say they're in school like what
you doing i mean i'm going to school
you're never too young to never too old
and never do
a bunch of sayings you need to open the
older you all though
shut the [__]
the [__] up with your old horseshit
cause it ain't you're old
your brain don't work
your body don't work you can't change
your ethic
there might be two of you that changed
your ethic like these fat people shows
that on tv where they got people as soon
as that show is over get fat again big
fat
fats
fatty that's what you are
i went to exercise
recently and i tried to change my life
and exercise
after i finished i was saying to myself
i got to do this tomorrow
like nothing changed i should have got a
lump i don't care what it was something
should have changed nothing and i got to
keep doing this until
maybe i see
a change but i just can't i don't have
that epic
anymore i should have did it when i was
18 years old
like i can't type
but i didn't realize how important
typing was till right now
i [__] up all my good typing years
calling people gay
who was going to typing class he was
just like
me and six other dudes like what you
doing tell you want to be a secretary
fire [__] man
come on man let's go uh
steal bread we should go steal bread
and lunch meat from the supermarket
make sandwiches and sell them during
typing class
[Laughter]
and now i can't type
if you can't take and you try to be in a
world with people who can
you you feel irrelevant you stop you
know
you just say hello to some woman on the
internet hi and she come back with the
seven page
memo like hello whack like really for
real
all those words you saw me type
hello
and i yelled it evidently in big letters
it was saying hello really seriously you
think i said hello hi
[__]
hi you know what you think i did for
real yeah really
i'm just sending smiley faces that's all
i do
i know smiley emoticons i know i love
those
like i can't spell if i had to spell
restaurant
to this day right
to save my mama's life like if
like if somebody held my mom a hostage
she had a gun to her
it says [__] spell restaurant you know
shoot your mother in the head i'll be
like i would look at my mother like uh i
love you
you gotta look at me mom she's crying
understand that i
i love you with all my
heart
stop stalling [__] okay all right all
right
all right
all right all right all right all right
r est
oh my god here's where it gets
oh jesus christ
[Applause]
right
give me a no give me another word man
give me another word one more word
just give my mother a chance to live
tomorrow
probably god
banana all right banana banana b-a-n
b-a-n-n
a-n-n-n is it anything like seven ends
in banana yeah yeah and
a
[Applause]
i'm uh irrelevant how old are you bro
35 five years yeah
how you feeling you feeling
you feeling all right
you feel like these young guys of you
know your football fan
all your whole life you notice how
football is whack now things are
changing it seems like look this this
may be old thinking okay
now when i came up your football fan no
that's something like
he's not like what dude like
that shocked me like dudes aren't a
football fan oh i don't just a little
too violent like
like
football
it's not like the game
it when i came up dude football was a
gla it was gladiator it was angry it was
angry it was just like when we hit
somebody when i played if you hit
somebody
and he didn't get up
like we didn't hold hands with the
with the other team and pray like whole
hands and all
everyone prays for him to get up we used
to do a indian
like sell a hump dance circle around
like really look at something
and our crowd's like he's paralyzed
that's right
we be looking for his mother crying be
like that's right lady that's what you
get for letting him out here with
killers
he can't even wiggle his toes take his
socks
take his socks
we would tie his socks around our helmet
for the next weeks
like the next team they knew all that's
the team that'd be
tying paralyzed digging socks
around their helmets to scare them next
week
and then
like
we were thinking about harming somebody
it's just that's
what we did
right
look at this guy just
look at this [__] crew right here you
guys are hilarious you okay guys all
right
you late for some tests you're gonna
have at one in the morning
uh intelligence face are you a big
football fan
you like football yeah you are sorter i
don't think so i think you saw me tease
this guy
[Applause]
i'm just trying to get us to understand
man that you're the future okay
i'm done
but they're taking away
i'm a neanderthal
okay they're taking away what i used to
just automatically think and feel and
now they're just taking it away from you
so that now even you look at dudes like
me like older dudes and go oh you're
it's like self-policing men go oh that's
not you shouldn't
like inappropriate is a vaginal word
like that's not a word
that is inappropriate like is that
coming from a man like women say that
that's when his job is like that's just
that
like that's
men are supposed to do we're here to do
foul things
and have you go but now what's where's
the balance see it's it's it's ying and
yang the balance you you gotta liven up
you gotta
be a little more is that your woman
right there see she got see how
comfortable you are you shouldn't be as
comfortable as you are
you just you can see him sitting up
straight and you're just looking and
he's just like
whatever you laugh at i'll laugh it's
not a good thing brother i feel it don't
get mad at me now he's like [__] you fat
boy
can't type or read huh fat man
i'm just saying man
i don't know how to type but i do know
i'm telling you this is uh
[Applause]
like ladies let's discuss
even look
let's discuss harassment
for a second
let's just see you feel it a little bit
like let's just discuss it
why can't
i harass you
sometimes
[Applause]
i can never harass you never and i'm not
talking about
like i'm talking just
at the job
it's unfair that i can't harass you at
the workplace like
you look at how you looking
and i can't just
a little something that has to do like
you got to be careful just to say hey
you look beautiful today that's how
messed up the game is
i think you should be able to comment on
any part of the body
that you see if you
i'm serious
what's your name
what's your name genie now genie no
disrespect but if i work with you
i should be able to walk in and go oh
genie beautiful uh titty meat you have
there
and because i see that but
whatever the scientific term is i'm
looking at mr
a 4.9 grade point average what's the
what's the science term for uh the titty
meat what's the actual
and it's not the cleavage i mean the
cleavage is the space in the middle i'm
talking about the meat
the meat the titty part
and i'm not being fouled just you know
whoa
you know what i'm saying just
so i can go through the rest
of the day without
pretending that i don't see
which which you understand what i'm
saying i mean let's work out a deal
don't get me
fired
[Applause]
having women work with men right is like
having a grizzly bear work with salmon
dipped in honey like so
now you dip the salmon in the honey
right grizzly bears and the salmon get
to walk through comfortable with honey
and fish
and
good morning grizzly bears
and the grizzly bears is like
hey
he can't even he didn't even growl like
ah what's up fish
oh my god human resources the grizzly
bear just did grizzly bears
so
like i can't even go hey good morning
good morning fish good morning
oh i can't touch you like oh look at
that
oh let me just get a little bit of that
fish a little bit
get that honey oh my god
fish and honey man that's my favorite
usually i kill fish and eat them and
stuff but i just wanted to just rub that
rub a little bit of that
god
damn
that's oppressive like you shouldn't
even
and there's cameras everywhere you can't
do
like weird stuff
behind the back like
why would it be disrespectful i said
what's your name
tyrell if i go ty tyrell we work
together and i go tyrell hey do me a
favor let me know when you're getting up
to go to the bathroom so i can sniff
your chair
[Applause]
that's disrespectful because it's sexual
but that keeps me from being
like i think look i think this should be
a holiday
uh for lack of a better word harassment
day but not that sounds whatever but i
mean a day where i
get to
find out like because and this is why it
should be harassment day
because women get to be inappropriate
sexually
all the time you get to be inappropriate
and when i say inappropriate i mean
say hello to me
too close hi
or some weird massage because you
think we're friends and you've good
morning little kiss and he's just like
oh oh boy oh boy boy boy boy
and you think in your head man i wonder
if i could i wonder you know
but harassment day allows you to be able
to ask
all year i say the tuesday
before thanksgiving
and it's and it's a beautiful day
flowers and everything you buy flowers
you just real cool you walk up you're
respectful you say hey how are you
you know good afternoon to her happy
harassment day
and you just like say listen i was
wondering
all year if you would suck my dick in a
broom clock
[Applause]
and you just be like no thank you i'm
not and you play i'm thank you keep the
flowers i just thought
i made a mistake i thought you was a
whole all year i was confused i thought
you was a hoe but you're not
even animals man animals smell it on us
they do animals smell
something's wrong like with the dog
whisperer he got animals
and i'm an animal but
let me say this man i i might what they
i don't know what the term is for uh
extreme animal lover like i i get sick
when i see animals suffering and i know
that's contrary to popular belief
somehow
somehow it's spread out that black
people we
we hate animals
like we can't stand dogs and cats and i
don't get it that's the news doing that
because they only show dudes that hate
dogs like when the vic stuff was
happening what do you think of michael
vick and the dog they just show every
dude they show us like
dogs man [__] dogs
i drown a dog in a bucket right now we
give me a dog where is her mother
where's a dog at i kill him i hate dogs
i hate dogs
and then they'll show a white woman like
tongue kissing
a dog in the mouth
just to prove white people love dogs and
then they go back to him and he's mad
like look at this dirty white [__]
tongue kissing
devil
devil [__] tongue kissing up
a jackal in the mouth
[Applause]
devil licking jackals and then she's
like sad there's like
some weird
war they always want black people white
people to be at war man for some reason
how can you hate it i don't people who
hate animals
like i i'm not gonna go i hate you but
it's it'll be hard it takes away a piece
of how close we might if you go i hate
animals
like somebody look at a baby ceiling oh
i can't wait to hit this [__] in
the face
[__] hate baby seals all
cute
the [__] you looking at babysit like
you ever seen them sad animal
commercials that come on like during
like four in the morning during threes
company reruns
and they catch you out of nowhere you'll
be watching three's company and then
like
and that's so
it'd be a
like it'll be a kitten in a slow motion
the kitten up and the kitten
and it's a
team got a pencil in his head like
somebody stuck a pencil in his face
there's a pistol sticking out of
[Applause]
it they put fun facts 15 000 kittens are
stabbed in their head
with pencils each year you'd be like who
is stabbing kittens
in the face
with pencils why
it's a pencil sticking out of his
face
then they'll show a bunch of puppies
shoved in a container or a cup
puppies in a cup
missing their feet it's wrong
[Applause]
hi i'm white lady
i'm here to say [__] probably did it
[__] you [__] jackal kissing hoe
but i'm not saying that dogs should be
equal citizens either
i love my dogs man but i i can't
you know it's wrong
to train them and they're out of control
and i'm not really a seasoned milan
understander i try
i try with what is my i got i got a
westy a little westy uh poodle and i
love my dogs man i let and i let them go
to bathroom on the wee-wee pad in the
house man i don't care
and everything's good when they do that
cause they got a little baby
you know when they eat right
they'll be nice little blue
you know
i don't have they don't have to scratch
they just do they think and when they do
they think everything's beautiful like
oh good boy good girl bow and
everybody's happy but sometimes they
just decide they're going to try me and
go like they have a meeting and go you
know what
let me see what happens with my piss on
this good rug daddy boy let's see watch
it you want to piss on i'll play we're
going to do it you guys come on one two
three i'll do it i'll do it
and then the other one
can you hear me now chad
let me know
yeah she gotta
hold on let me see if i can do something
real quick
okay
yeah that was so much fun
i wonder
how do i do this
y'all didn't get to see this one hold on
i'm gonna show y'all in a second
literally everybody's asleep
besides me is me and y'all
she's not going to but i'll move it
[Music]
yeah that was fun i'm about to about to
post it to our story
okay
it's inner story
she ordered starbucks
i just don't know where it's at
i'm going back y'all are funny
did you guys enjoy it
i hope you guys enjoyed that it was fun
for me
who said they don't get me forget flew
down
but no she's really not playing she's
really
out everybody's out isha's out
blessings out pearls out
i'm the last one standing
no cause
earlier i was like
asmr and people were like no no so
nah
you know you always got to clean up your
mess i always got to keep it clean
it's like second nature to me to like
just clean up after a mess
what time is it where you guys are
that great you have to be like i i enjoy
just like sitting here talking to you
guys y'all are so much fun
i'm the captain now
period
um my arm's fine i got burped by a
hookah cole a few weeks ago a lot worse
if i just keep the band-aid on it so it
doesn't peel
um i'm good
i don't know i'm not here when pearl
sleeps but when she falls asleep on the
couch she doesn't really snore her
just just just justly things
just jesse things the fun show
hey guys welcome back to just jessie
things
y'all are typing so fast i can't even
the just i like that
y'all already
i'm built different
lucas i tried to look for you on ig
your name wasn't popping up
um if you guys want to follow me on ig
uh
let's see what super chats
okay but what about chess asmr and
espanol um
i was 11 20 in la
yo i would i would literally go get
tacos right now 11 20 that's not even
late
there was this place up the street from
me back home
called um
oh my gosh castaneda's
it was the best and then it closed down
right before i came out here and i
almost i literally almost shouted here
um
i speak a little bit of spanish guys i
can't
i can't speak if you guys give me
sentences i'll probably read it in
spanish and do
asmr
hola
estas
[Music]
how would i say that see
only know what i know i only say what i
know
um
you want to hear her breed just
y'all heard her breathe earlier when we
were watching the thing
y'all could hear her breathe
i'm telling you
there's a period where i'm like i'm
dying i'm dying i'm dying i'm dying i'm
going i'm out and then i'm like
something happens and i'm like i'm up we
in this thing we're going
we're here for it
you guys are really giving me sentences
to say
there is a taco bell numerous but it's
not the same like not at all
i'm american i'm not i'm not british
if you start doing something
no not a recovering simp
how long have you been
recovering aaa meeting
[Laughter]
uh
mike uh last time i fell asleep around
friends i woke up to 16 pairs of
trainers stacked on me i love how you
were clearly to betray pearl it's not
betrayal she was talking about at our
next
uh the next place in the next studio
she's like yeah we're gonna do pranks so
i just started early
um
carnitas
okay
so do you i don't
y'all just let me know if you want me to
stop doing asmr i'm just going to read
the ones that they sent me i have to
whisper anyways everyone sleep so
don't esta not
y'all are funny
see i can read it oh hold on i didn't
even put my thing um
yeah girl
here's my ig and then
[Music]
um
i just put my ig and
youtube
in the chat
no sorry didn't come he was on ig
a video call
he punked out
now i'm playing at work
no i'm that's something i'm not gonna do
i'd be upset if someone did that on me
i'm not gonna do that especially not on
live
maybe like if we're by herself and she
fell asleep and
you lots couldn't see it
okay first of all y'all don't give me
nothing good
don't give me
nothing weird to say in spanish i know
spanish
i mean i know but no but i know it
um
let me
i am i'm very tired
spanish course asmr spanish which yes
i need to know spanish fluently
to be able to do
a course
yeah i know it's called the second wind
secondly
i'm from california
i'm just answering aliyah's question
oh someone asked me earlier
[Music]
is the starbucks guys hold on
oh
[Music]
so
ellie ain't nothing
[Music]
check
um another super chat thank you guys
thank you guys for really for all the
super chats
we really do appreciate it is there any
way
you'll share my gofundme
i cannot do that because this is pearl's
channel and she is um
she's asleep right now so that is not my
jurisdiction to do that sorry about that
i hope
that you and your daughter do not get
foreclosed
she'll get up in a minute
no i haven't visited italy yet
it's one of the places i do want to go
i know y'all are y'all are evil put her
in and
chris
it is 7 31 right now in the uk
what's happening um we are doing a 24
hour live stream to celebrate
um just pearly things hitting
um
in terms of what's happening right now
right now i'm the only one awake and so
i'm just chilling with the chat
um
and talking to y'all answering your
questions
she is sleeping right now
and so i'm the only one that's awake
from the team
pearl is knocked
out she can hear me because she saw her
headphones on but she's still knocked
out when i tell you
it's a graveyard in here
[Music]
no
i
i could
but
phoenix
um
seven
about
about five five hours four and a half
five hours
no i didn't
i did not promise that at 500k i did not
i did not promise that at 500k
look
i don't i don't mind doing these i
actually like doing these they're pretty
fun it's just like giving getting over
that hump
ellie this is not food chick
but it's just giving over that hump and
then once you get over that hump
your gucci you guys wanna hear
some asmr
okay i'm done
wow
you heard it with your own eyes
i don't think you can hear things with
your eyes
starbucks is all right
read the man pranks
yes it is matcha matcha is good
uh jessica or just based on current
trends what do you think the future of
sexual marketplace will look like
i think the future is what do you mean
by sexual marketplace
like
in terms of
just like
men and women
okay cool
y'all want pranks no quiero
nah nah michael rejoining the speedo
at this time this time you actually you
guys actually get to see her sleep last
time she left
and went to sleep but this time you get
to see your sleep
yo i'm gonna screenshot that i'm gonna
use that
i identify as a houseplant
and espanol i'm gonna say that
oh
okay that's what i thought everyone was
saying patron i was like patron how did
we get on this subject
[Music]
patron
patron is how you say it did i say right
oh and this is
is it heffa
see you guys
i didn't know what y'all was saying
i just saw the same
the same word and i was like who is this
person
just tell us about what you think about
i don't know i don't know much about
taiwan to speak on it
i literally just heard about it today so
i can't really speak on taiwan
and what's happening there
would be funny if we could make a whole
idea story with some other pranks
sensible pranks
give me
we do have to pull it we had it earlier
it's not it's not
it's not like the states
but it's good
the um
the chips they ain't chipping
i need the lemon
and the
salt
[Music]
thank you for the membership wow y'all
coming through with these memberships i
don't even know how many we've gotten
since we've been on
do i prefer usa or
i mean
right now it's where i want to be
the uk
i've been in thanks for the super chat
i've been in the us for
my whole life so i just want to be over
here as long as i can
okay first of all
this is a
thorough thought out plan
no
no no
yes
can you ask pearl and both the awkward
reaction
yeah yeah yeah i screenshotted it so
once
um once
she wakes up that'll probably be one of
the ones we do once we get to the new
studio
well we haven't been able to do
a lot of reactions because um
just pearl of my schedule has been so
busy with
the show and everything in school so and
then she's been looking for a new studio
um
so yeah but
i've screenshotted it and i will
definitely let her know
that that should be one that we react to
but be y'all be on the lookout
for more reactions and whatnot
videos once we get into the new
um studio
as right now
do y'all want to because i'm gonna be
here until i'll be here till 12.
rather these lots wake up or they stay
asleep till 12 10 i'm gonna be up
so um
do you all want to just keep asking me
questions back and forth
or y'all can um
y'all can give me videos to react to and
i'll
reactor i'm not about to put the mic in
here but julio
y'all can give me um videos to react to
and i will
react to them and watch them
so yeah
let me know
[Music]
right now
it's
i don't know i don't know when i find it
is that a bad thing
where'd you finally make some completely
hawker tie and say omg i thought
i liked that one
i'd have to
it'd have to be like very like it's for
the moment
when she wakes up and sits up i bet
here's your coffee and i'm like
omg i thought i lost you i like that see
that's a good one that's a sensible one
um
what course i'm in sports psychology is
the
my major at my school right now
oh she's waking up she's waking up
hello
do you want your coffee
oh it's right here
what
your coffee
do you want a blanket
oh [__] oh
um
maybe like
20 30 minutes how long has she been out
chat
yeah
it is 7 43
hi pearl
okay
was it really that long good thing i
moved the mic
close the youtube window what does that
mean
i don't know what that means close the
youtube window we can just ask questions
oh
but
if i close that
pearl had a whale nightmare
oh y'all tell me what the time stamp is
what is it
i can't see it
no we're not trying to raise 258 we're
celebrating her getting to 250k i mean
if y'all want to race for 250k for me
go right ahead i'll put my cash out
paypal venmo
all that good stuff in the description
if you want to raise 250k for me
um
but we're not raising money
give me one second i'ma figure that out
i'll go
yeah
if y'all got 250k on my channel i think
i would cry
i'm trying to get that thing up but it's
so hard just by myself oh no wrong thing
i'm trying
i'll be on the once i have seen it
before see my videos i hope you enjoy
them
it took me forever just to like
do youtube or just post videos
so i hope you guys enjoy them i enjoy
editing them and everything
is that what i'm supposed to do
let me hold on let me get up the people
that know what to do
one second sure
new
we'll see how it looks
what does it look like with the other
one
no i like the other one
oh my gosh
all right chat it's just me and you
ish disappeared to his car i think
i'm not out
i'm here we here we right here we right
here
i think i have like
not 18 like i think i'm 1800 or
something so it's almost 2 000
which is crazy
um
so yeah
if y'all want to go see a little bit
more
of
me and what
what life is like on my end you guys
want to check that out
i have a lot of
i can't disclose that
y'all nosy
i mean i have long legs
i don't like i like putting them up
to serving legs for
eat breakfast up beat it up
so for anyone joining we are doing
we were doing a 24 hour live stream um
to celebrate 250k
at the start it was myself pearl and ish
and we were watching a documentary on
red pill
um it was called red pill documentary
and then
we had some people come in we just
finished up the documentary not too long
ago
and then
in between we had an actual like podcast
show
which um pearl led and everything we had
guest and all that and so once they left
we continued the 24-hour live 24-hour
live stream
and it's for celebrating 250 cakes we
did it at 100k
and then the people wanted it again in
250k
so this is what we're doing but
currently at this very moment
i
am
the last one standing i'm a survivor i'm
not gonna give so
you're tuning into that um little church
announcements make sure you like the
video like it up like it up like it up
um it's good for the algorithm
i don't know how it works pro does but
like the video if you have not
subscribed to the channel go ahead and
subscribe
if you're just popping in you're like
what the heck is a 24-hour live stream
and you see someone if you see me
with my
legs on the couch and you see
this girl sleeping on the couch
it's pearly just for anything's channel
so go ahead and subscribe she has some
great content
good contact great content already and
great stuff coming
um if you want to follow her on
instagram just pretty things or just
pearly things we're trying to get that
up and
popping i mean it's already popping we
probably get to pop it more
if you want to become a membership if
you
see the stuff and you like the stuff
like the content that's on her channel
like the
clips that you see
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
and also become a member because you
will get exclusive stuff um
in the membership if you want to sign up
for that
also
if you don't want to watch full videos
or if you just
see stuff on her instagram like clips
you can always go onto the new clips
channel and check that out as well
and
i think that's everything
yeah um subscribe to the new clip
channel we're trying to get up to she's
set some goals for y'all y'all just been
crushing it with the subscribing to the
clips channel and
you can
go ahead and subscribe to that the next
goal is 50k
yeah 50k yeah
that's the next goal
and so
i'm a woman we don't ask for raise that
is not us
i'm kidding
nah i enjoy doing this
like a lot
that's why when she was like we're doing
it again when we first started i was
like dang i'm really doing this but then
i was like all right we doing it this is
this is probably my favorite part to
just chill
and just like talk to y'all i think it's
fun i enjoy it
um someone asked me
a question
no is
are you asking if i do it if i can do
asmr or if this is asmr
yes i'm glad these streams help you make
it through it
no i do not
i'm not
no i do not have a
novio
sorry if i'm breathing in the mic i know
that can be annoying just here
[Music]
trying to read all your
ooh super chat thank you
hey what made pearl decide to move to
the uk
great work
surviving the night thanks um i think it
was just a new opportunity
y'all my knee is hurting so
this is the new that i just got surgery
on and keeping it locked that long kind
of started to hurt
um
[Music]
sorry someone said thunderstruck isn't
that dynastrok
my ig is your girl jess if you are old
old hair you know i had a complicated
one and now it's just your girl jess
sorry your girl jess lee i don't
remember that
yeah instructions i'm sorry instruction
is unclear now it's stream
stream is now
just 200 we're raising money 250k for
chess
oh alyssa yes
it was so great to have you guys here
i'm so happy that you are able to
come all the way from wales that's crazy
and drive up i hope you guys made it
back
safely
hope you and your husband enjoyed it
because we definitely enjoyed y'all it
was just a treat and it was just so cool
to see the impact that pearl has made
since she's been here that people will
drive to come to a 24-hour livestream
just to be on the show and to be able to
talk with pearl about things and just
want to have an impact like pearl does
so we just enjoyed you guys coming all
the way from wales it was awesome
i'm gonna have that song stuck in my
head
no doug i didn't see batman
i didn't i didn't i didn't
oh
sorry i'm gonna
my knee hurts i don't
yes
we gotta have that dedication
and that's going to play guitar solo
nice
where do the iro interviews take place
usually
i'm
i'm not sure
take place usually
oh oh um sorry
irl i'm thinking completely something
different um
they
one has been in lesser square before
some have been one has been in stratfor
that was the one they did the other day
and then a chunk of them have been
shorted and i think that's where
a chunk of them are going to be or
they're going to be from now on it's in
shortage lester lester square is also a
good spot um
so it's wherever pearl decides to go but
if you're in the shortage area they'll
typically be
in shortage on fridays
friday yeah fridays that's when she
usually does them
i'm
i'm comfy guys and it just so happens
that the camera thought that way
i can put him down i could take him out
the shot i can put a blanket
i could put a blanket on
you guys won't see him at all
i hope so time to wake up i hope so
i should put it on
member only stream
yeah she's sleep melissa i'm just going
gonna let her sleep because she's had a
long week and whenever she can get some
sleep
she deserves it so i'm just gonna keep
the stream going for you lots
yeah she is
[Music]
doug are you leading the games for us
again
are you leading the cavalry for us doug
90s karaoke trivia
is that what we did last time doug
will you give me a song and see if i
know it
i have a song stuck in my head
i'm going off the rails on the crazy
[Music]
is a genius
if y'all get to one million subscribers
will you do a four day stream who
who gonna do a four-day stream
that
is
how's that copyright
i'm singing it and it's not even the
right notes
if i was playing it
do i follow you guys on instagram
i don't know who i
i haven't went through to see who's a
member who's not a member
hey jess
yes i think that they're gonna clip it
um our eclipse guy
i think he's gonna clip um
different segments here and there from
the live stream
um
so it's not just like one it will i
still have the big
the 12 hours and the 12 hours
but for the most part
it'll be clipped
from like
the
what is it called
from the podcast from the pre-game and
then from other sections as well
um
rumah i'm not sure
i don't know that is a
good question
ask god for me and see what he tells you
jess have you considered other sports
than basketball i used to run track
and cross country i love track track was
like so much fun it literally was the
best
but i chose to continue in basketball
um
[Music]
once we're done with the live stream i
will definitely check it out i know
that um
someone messaged me on instagram
[Music]
interesting um
no i haven't
i haven't fallen asleep
you know
the grace of god in the second wind is
how i'm still at
but yeah
i
um
either
alyssa no i have not slept
no
i didn't go to lausd
i was raised in michigan
and answer your second question no
no latinos
[Music]
um
oh goodness
oh thanks a listen you guys are the best
[Music]
what do you mean you knew it ulysses
gomez what do you mean you knew it
you knew what
thanks for the membership thanks for the
membership
no i haven't been to connecticut hey
michigan and our
gang gang i'm from holly
if you know where that's at from my
michiganders
it'll be this way i'm boop
i know there's someone from detroit
holly's up here
you know what
everyone just fly out to london
i'll do speed dating
speed dating and we'll get it everyone
just fly out to london
okay riverside
gang gang
what's the biggest difference between
the us and uk cultural why is lifestyle
i would say even though
the uk is
like big or just like london is big and
there's a lot of people in london
i feel a lot more like
like
calmer here
and in la's just like busy busy busy
busy busy i don't know how to explain it
but it feels like you have to be on the
hustle and bustle all the time and if
you're not you're not making money and
if you're not you're not grinding
here it's like okay
we know we need to get done we're not
gonna rush we're not gonna stress it's
just gonna be like
calm
and also cultural wise
yes la has
culture of the y zoop here
it's
od but like in a good way like you have
so many different people from everywhere
the islands
africa
spain portugal
paris greece i've met so many different
people
and i'm like wow and it's not like oh
yeah i'm from here
and they just chill
it's like no i'm from here this is my
people i wrap it day in and day out i'll
show you the music i'll show you the
food this is my culture this is me so i
i love it i love hearing about people's
bloodlines hearing about where people
are from
and just getting to know
them
it's
it's weird it's like exciting and sad at
the same time so i'm like dang
i wish i knew but i love it that's the
difference between here in the uh us
y'all about to get me right with spanish
como
me
michael dojo you're gonna have to
michael dojo you got to translate that
for me because that's too
it's too much is too much
real man from new orleans
new orleans
from louisiana baby
[Music]
y'all getting a show
louisiana baby
i know
i know with the tongue twister i'm like
translate please
i mean for content i don't mind just as
long as y'all ain't crazy
that's the only thing what is the point
in this i have to tune in yesterday and
so
the
idea
of this mr simon
is to celebrate 250k right now everybody
is
clonked out and wanted to keep it going
for the members and
just to
have a live stream for 24 hours it's fun
for certain people and it's just a cool
thing for um subscribers and people to
come in as you can tell there's still
people here that enjoy there's still
people here talking and chatting even
though i'm the only one on they're still
interacting and it's still enjoyable for
people
so if we decide to do it again we
decided again if we don't we don't
so yeah
thank you for your input we appreciate
it
dad
i don't know what that is kenneth
it's the benefits of time
very young and they had no idea they
were signing up for i mean we did this
before so hopefully they would have
reconnaissance you just described is
exactly what i thought
india
in an hour this will just be just
conjugating in spanish hey i mean if it
helps yo necesito ayudar
i need up with my spanish call me
espanol
just needs a young mega child pastor
peroni's
one of those lonely
millionaire farmers what'd you think
a mega church pastor
lord have mercy
yo taco bell
a mega church fast do i give off that
vibe
a mega church faster that's the first
time i've ever heard that thank you guys
for the super chats for real i want to
hear some jada pinkett smith goes chris
yes
i love jada peek and smith
quote they are the best i think they're
very well said and they just pertain to
her life so much
and she's just her clothes are just so
great
i'm not contradicting at all
chris what is good yo
how can i get on
email on my email dm eddie it's in
pearls um uh
ig bio and it's also in the description
of this video dm eddie and if you're in
london
he will
you guys will set up a day to where
you're able to come on the show and you
guys are going to be able to come on so
if you do want to come on the show dm
eddie
in the description box or in pearl's bio
of her ig
y'all i'm not drawing first of all her
face is covered right now so i'm not
about to draw
just let's be honest you could carry a
24-hour livestream
why you think we all stay
the bad guy 93 000 i'm the burn
guy
i appreciate you guys staying because
it's not my channel if i didn't care if
i didn't want to be here i would be i'd
be asleep i'd be like you know what i'm
a dip out
at x amount of time but i appreciate you
guys staying i appreciate you guys just
interacting and being on
pearl's live i really do appreciate it
it's fun talking to y'all
you're already great
not another tongue twister
all right let's see if i can get this oh
it says if i love you and you don't want
for me to love you
as i want you to love you
oh
[Music]
oh thank you do i have a good like
spanish accent
i appreciate it
thank you guys for doing this we'd love
to see you on more just
i will be on more it's just been
busy busy over here in these parts but
we plan on doing more reactions and more
things in the future with the studio the
new studio that we're moving in so
frank's ross pairs up that we get the
one that we um put in for because if we
do y'all i'm telling you y'all are going
to be amazed it's about to be
bomb.com and there's just so many new
things coming i cannot wait for you guys
to see it
and i'm not just hyping it up i promise
you
jess and kirk franklin go for bid
oh no yeah
i know i said earlier that short kings
was in
in my brain but not kurt franklin
it's your boy no not kurt franklin
okay
[Music]
oh no
yeah
you did not just say jada pink is myth
shakur y'all are funny
tupac in puerto rico somewhere
i promise you he is living his best life
right now so is michael jackson
y'all when they pop up
y'all heard it here first
because i built earlier when you were
planning to go home for 15. how long
were you actually going for i think i
was gone for like maybe 20 minutes
um
i walked over to my dorm and took a
shower maybe like 20 30 minutes but i
came back everyone's like you didn't
think you were coming back i was like
boom
i let my haters be my motivators
i prove you that's wrong i proved your
love's wrong
let's see i wish i had like a stand i
didn't have to hold this
[Music]
just i don't believe
oh
yes i do not believe in life after love
griez
once you love somebody just there's no
more life is that what you mean
i appreciate the distraction from my mom
you're welcome from the destruction
uh
are you down to b
i have a doppelganger
where
send it to me on instagram i've always
wondered if i had a doppelganger show me
or it's cap
[Music]
your girl justly on ig
send it to me
so i can see
my doppelganger
bars
bars busy bars
for us to go to the end yo i know
i didn't get any sleep i've been up
a padilla
song
[Music]
i told you i i know i know spanish but
i'm not fluent
yeah
lo siento
i just
run
stop nah what is okay
for y'all who know who kurt franklin is
what is the best kirk franklin song and
y'all better say the right
what what is the
hands down
the best kurt franklin song
ever that he has written
i wanna i wanna hear it
portuguese
oh portuguese is
harder
i don't plan on learning portuguese
i have to
i can do asmr where it's very quiet
but i have to talk quiet i have the dog
gotta whisper but this is a lot more
quieter
because everybody is sleeping
so if y'all want asmr
i'm just
why are you saying just conspiracy
i don't understand
ulysses guess what is the conspiracy
yeah if i wake pearl up right now
she ain't gonna be able to function
so i might just carry it out to the end
i learned spanish in school
no that's what i'm saying i have to stay
up for the rest if i go to sleep
we're done
at least one person has to stay awake
fav food
death faith food favorite restaurant in
london have you been to this room
i have not
taken note of that
um
fake food
i like las iguanas
that are probably my favorite place
okay the melody's from heaven
stomp stomps on silver and goes okay
super and cool
she can totally be a hannah who can
totally be a hannah
doug what did you say oh i thought you
were talking about me
if you don't know who kirk franklin is
it's okay
smile okay i said explanatory smile is
the reason we have
oh
that's so sweet
that's probably my favorite pickup line
yo
i'm gonna
time to wake up put that in the chat
again and then i'm gonna screenshot it
that's my favorite pickup line
um
i promise the stone
the whole stone nothing but stump
yeah aaron i gotta stay up
hey jessamr
um
just do you think me putting i don't
date fat woman or astrology as a turn
off on my tender profile
is a good approach
to finding a nice girl i mean if you
don't
want fat woman if you don't want
girls who believe in astrology
it's hard
because
i would say put it but also would say
oh
um
someone would be like that's that's fat
shaming even people that aren't fat and
they'd be like
that's
star ism you're against the stars or
whatever they would say it's just like
no this is
i what i don't i don't prefer that and
females don't look at it like that
um can't you curate
um on
tinder
like what type of people you want
i'm not sure i
haven't been on tinder many years i
sound like an old lady i haven't been on
tinder in years
i mean you can try it try it out for a
week see what it gets you
see if it gets you results or if it
doesn't and if it doesn't
word it in a way to where you will
uh get what you want so if it's not
saying if it's saying like oh i don't
i don't want fat girl say i'm very
athletic and i like to work out
typically fat girls aren't gonna
swipe on you and say um
as i just
i
am not into astrology is that what you
said
and astrology turn off
say um
i'm spiritual but not in the astrology
way or
not spiritual and you won't get the
girls that are
a quote-unquote spiritual if that makes
sense
hope that's hope that helps that is
dating 101 from jess
that would be 500 pounds i'm kidding
um
i'm not about to get into that
conversation ulysses
um no people are pretty cool out here
in
london
you get the limo
don't get me started with hannah montana
i grew up on her i'll sing all her songs
how to styles every shoe every color
and when you're famous it can be kind of
fun
it's really you but no one ever
discovers
pro will wake up in a bit and be very
confused check if jess is still carrying
the stream and then go back to dreamland
that probably will be will happen y'all
didn't even say the the real
the kurt franklin song
did nobody say
how much does my submission cost
a million dollars so if you ain't got it
move along buster
buster i'm kidding
um
i don't know i've never really thought
of like how much it cost
when she when they did the pregame show
for that i was like um that's a good
question i never really thought about it
like
what is the max and what is the min or
what is like the min that
act right what is the men that a guy can
make for me to submit
so
i don't know i'll get back to you on
that
there's gonna be one day where i have
answers to all these questions but today
it's not that day
doug i'm surprised you didn't say it
what song it was
doug sir
the best song
the best song that kirk franklin
has ever made
michael's dojo chill out he was not he
was not about to pay nothing
y'all ruling chat y'all what up john
rule
oh goodness
see
thank you sean
sean you know what
thank you
sean sean ain't remember he the member
of the week for the rest of the month
sean you
you already knew what i was talking
about
book of revelations chapter 7 verses 16
and 17 yes sir they shall hunger no more
neither shall they thirst anymore preach
preacher for god shall wipe away yes i
every tear from there
get ready for the revolution
i'm really in here by myself y'all
having the time of my life okay
have you seen the clipper a guy asks
women their astrology and pretend
to be disgusted and they say never mind
girls get offended no i haven't seen
that i have not seen that that's funny
though
i don't even go off astrology
i just
i like mine because it's cool as a
gemini if you go off astrology and
you're like oh gemini cool
i would say gemini's are the best
because i'm on
um
i found
drop
him i don't know what that means drop
him
i don't want to be an alias
so imma let you
be like jesus there you go
question would y'all be with a man that
doesn't believe in god gods or god
i
personally i couldn't
pearl might have a different answer but
i know i couldn't because that is
something that is a foundation for me
um an 80k a year
hello
huh
you can you can go back to sleep
we're all just chilling in the chat
back to dreamland she goes
about 80k a year
i don't
i don't think that's bad
what's like
in america what's the like
average like
household stuff maybe i should know this
stuff
i just don't
ah
help me educate me chat
uh
ja rule left
strawberry got kicked out because he was
talking reckless
hello good morning i don't
i do not
bobby yes i am
i don't know nothing about no capricorns
so i don't know
so gemini's don't so i want to tell
y'all a little epiphany i had
one day
y'all are funny about gemini's
actually
never mind it's okay i'll keep that
little epiphany to myself true word of
god is written on our hearts of all of
my family for all my family divine
queen bee i like the light again can't
wait for the typewriter
260k y'all are crazy
y'all are crazy
what's for breakfast yes
no
[Music]
no pearl does math i don't
i don't do math um what's for breakfast
matcha latte
that's what's for breakfast
um
i should order something for myself
but so i want y'all to
um
i want draw to
what should i have i'll do
[Music]
give me one question
and
[Music]
something actually i don't
know hmm
yeah one what is something one thing you
want to know about me because i need to
use the toilet put it down in the chat
and i will be
right back
um
uh
okay
oh 37k okay i guess 80k isn't bad then
um
scorpio what year is a scorpio born i
mean year what month is the scorpio born
in
for full-time argument grapefruit juice
mix
okay
okay keep up the stream thanks
read the old testament find out
i mean i don't follow it so
and i've read all the old testament but
i've read some of it i don't follow it i
just
[Music]
geminis
um
oh no
make sure you put your sunscreen on guys
keep yourself protected
good night
thanks
what's your favorite basketball player
run
my favorite basketball play to run
[Music]
oh
i love a good press
like a full court press oh yeah
a diamond oh
that is probably one of my favorite
basketball plays to run
dress size
two
100k starting salary good job
number one or two
oh
i was like what do you mean number one
or two that's for me to know and you not
to find out
devon that is a question you can answer
um most entertaining part of the stream
most auntie she's the most entertaining
part of this dream like yo
i felt like i was talking to a celebrity
when she was here like i've heard so
much about you my gosh i'm the biggest
fan
um
set up for a scary movie
oh
this
bro jermaine
i cannot answer that you don't have to
ask her that to sell
uh i think religion's starting to lose
itself
that's a complex question a lot can go
into that be for chicken all depends on
what it is
i'll depend on what it's in
if it's
a taco
beef
if it's a salad chicken
who's the goat jordan
jordan
or lebron
i would say they're the goat and both
their heiress
now kobe
he at the top of the pyramid he had the
top
that
yo
he
built
different the way he
analyzed the game played the game saw
the game love the game oh my days he is
built
different
built different and touched
every single era like people that are
alive today he's touched every single
era of basketball there's not a person
on this earth that has played the game
of basketball that does not know who
kobe is
like kobe
rip rip
i don't know kyle
i don't know
hmm
interesting
i am five nine and a half rounded of
five ten
um there's not really a scar there on my
knee
but
if y'all wanna it's
i can't really show you it's like right
here
i don't want to get too close up into
the camera
but
it's
if you guys zoom in on
it's like these two
boops right there
so it's not really scars
just if there is one skill you would use
you would be able to have
what would it be
skill as in
i say negotiating
negotiating that's what i was saying
god bless cryptocurrency right now
hey sam sent some my way thanks
what is my ideal man
an idea
[Music]
um
when's the last time
you complimented a guy and why
you know
i get nervous when i compliment
dudes
i don't know i just get nervy
i think it in my head i'm like wow he's
very nice looking or while i like his
fit or man shoes are fire
or just like ah he seems like a cool
dude but i don't say it do you guys like
that you guys like that stuff to get
compliments
i don't know
[Music]
is that is that a thing that guys like
because if it is i'll be like hey yo
cutie how you doing
not like that but
i'll get more compliments
and not be nervous
um
just you're coming to america
i will
be back there i'll scorpio is october
november
hmm
who said i don't follow it bobby
um
no i can't dunk i can't
[Music]
i can't talk
oh thanks thanks jay
i don't auntie aunty jenny's in the chat
yo what up auntie
i don't know my uk
dress size auntie
um
i'm like a
i don't know what i would be
i'm like uh
six eight
i'm like a six eight in the states i
don't know what that would be here
in the uk
jordan all day ripco yeah r.i.p
my major is sports psychology
hey you got your opinion you say jordan
i say kobe some people say lebron
it is what it is they're all all great
players
all great players
so
hmm
no i'm not sleepy drunk
i'm just
thumbing through the comments
name three people i admire
the father son and holy spirit
y'all know i gotta play with y'all um
three people i admire um
my
older brother
like for real he's one person that i do
admire
one of my
mentors in california
and
hmm
that's a good question
i don't know who the third one would be
so you have to go shopping to find out
your easy size
y'all trying to take me shopping
y'all ain't about it i ain't bout about
it
y'all ain't bout about it
i really don't like shopping
who would you most like to have dinner
with alive or dead
besides jesus i mean
i would like to have dinner
with
either
my
great aunt um we called her on baby girl
from my mom's side of the family
or
my
grandmothers
so my great-grandmother on my mom's side
of the family
those are the two people that i would
want to
or my
gran my great grandfather my dad's side
those are the people that i would want
to
um
have lunch with
because
my grandfather lived to be a hundred so
i would be able to get so much
information
from my great grandfather if he talked
about it
and um
[Music]
my
baby girl she
had all the information
everything about my mom's side of the
family she passed away and i never had a
chance to talk to her about it so i
would have a little bit more insight
about
who i is
struggle is real yes it is my favorite
candy my favorite sweets
snickers
i love me some snickers and then out
here some squishies
some things are addicted they put they
lace them things with that cocaine i
promise you
they lace it
that stuff
i'll be feeding it for it
oh thanks i'm sleep deprived so i
appreciate that
um thanks i appreciate you guys i
appreciate you guys sticking around
even though
everyone else is asleep and thank you
guys for sticking around
and keeping me keeping me entertained
and occupied
um i'll give you guys a little bit of
insight on what i do on my channel
um on my channel is mainly just vlogs i
have vlogs upon vlogs upon vlogs that i
do
that i'm editing right now that i'm
trying to post and get out there quick
um so it's not like a big gap in between
time
so
i have a vlog finishing up for my
trip to back home
keep watching a certain somebody's gonna
pop up
here
soon
and i have a vlog from when i came back
from sports awards and then my birthday
vlog
and i have my recovery vlog so it's a
lot of things coming up just so you can
see
um
just so you can see me
and just like
another side of me i'm very i'm i'm like
this literally in my vlogs
and it's just
me doing me
so if you want to see that check that
out
you can go to my channel it is it's your
girl jess
um on youtube and go ahead and subscribe
if you would like to
and
check it out
there's more stuff coming here soon just
let me get this degree done and i
promise y'all
it's going to be only pizza
[Music]
um
he
auntie he
we called him on
ig livestream
so
um we
yeah we caught someone there
10 push-ups
my arms are sore from
snc all week
i can do
give me a living basketball oh thanks
loving basketball
let me play for your heart
quincy
is that your girl yeah i'm a girl girls
can't play basketball
i don't know nike made dresses
[Music]
nine i'll fall asleep on y'all i promise
you
it's almost nine o'clock
we got three hours y'all
y'all we gonna have the we don't have to
do something in these next three hours
either give me something to react to and
i'll pull it up or
give me a song i'll sing it
give me an exercise and i'll do it to
the best my ability because i am in
rehab so don't do nothing crazy
um
ask me questions
my favorite pizza is hawaiian pizza
no it's hot in here y'all calm down
y'all funny
bill
bilbert okay everybody's saying
billboard
wnba
you can dunk your loving tomorrow is it
that's all jess for the next three hours
yeah rehab i had surgery on my knee
for all you people that didn't know i
don't know if i can do jumping jacks jg
oh
craig this past season for the lakers
trash rubbish
it was horrible
on paper later at the beginning of the
season on paper i was like lakers from
the west
nyx from the east
boom i was like that's going to be the
final because on paper
outstanding teams
star players
but in game situations
they were not a team and so
yeah it was a horrible season
bill burr pilper wnba
i don't know if i can do music
okay we're gonna do how much time is up
about
uh
i'll say four hours in
20 minutes
um
yeah four hours and 20 minutes
no
[Music]
don't even listen to me a little
over three hours a little over three
mm-hmm
you know what
do you all want to do the call-in
i'm gonna see
our i'll react to bill burr
right now and then
and then we'll see i'll see if we can do
the calling
that's okay roma thanks for coming
get some rest
bye thanks for coming to the live
we do appreciate you guys coming no
matter
how how long
how long you can stay you can say five
minutes ten minutes
twelve hours um some white guy all day
long yes imma make it i promise you
okay um
[Music]
is she turning red
y'all can see better than me
i'll turn in the ac
i think it's just because she's her body
he is making her hot too
but y'all care about her so much i felt
concerned
but i'll see if we can i don't know if
y'all want to do the calling or try it
um
someone that was a
no i never dated this guy but i
talked to him for a few months
and it was he was
probably
i'll say five five seven five six he was
a little bit shorter than me
that's the shortest guy i've ever like
talked to
but like dated
maybe
someone might hire maybe
an inch or two taller
my favorite soda baja blast
from taco bell
it is almost nine o'clock
huh
goodnight people who are leaving
i figured you could watch more of that
comedy show you think you just watched
me
what did you say you'd watch more of the
comedy show
oh
i did and then i did something oh
where's your phone at
here you go
i'll have you look at it
you realize it's up
there no no no
go to your story
i was watching it and then i just
started talking to
they're like pro check your id protect
your id
i'm going to put on bill
bill bird wnba
[Music]
are you hot pearl
okay chad i don't know which one it is
[Music]
there's people like coming in like
what's this what's this
so i've just been telling them what it
is
what it
is was
got your ain't good or what it is oh no
okay chad um
i don't know which one it is i don't
know if it's the two minute one
or if it's this one
which one is it y'all i'm gonna let
y'all help me out
we've been going for
17 no
no
oh i'm stupid we've been going for 21 21
hours we'll be done at like 12 10.
okay okay okay okay i got you
thanks bobby appreciate it
ah
you smart
you loyal
oh shoot
oh my these
is the mouse not working
no i'm just grabbing the wrong thing
i don't want you
we go
ah they're smart
okay
there we go um chat which one is it
help you gear that please
so i know there's people reacting to it
it might be that one the second one
craig i'm a little nervous to say that
you played yourself
i haven't played a video yet the second
one okay
thanks
okay
let's
give it a
look i saw a woman a couple months back
professional soccer player right she
goes on to espn on one of these sports
channels and she starts bitching
going like i don't understand how come
female athletes don't make as much as
male professional athletes
right and all of these men had to sit
there and act like they didn't know what
the answer was
they had to sit there like dumbfounded
like oh
why is that
[Applause]
that is a conundrum i have i have no
idea
literally i'm sitting at home screaming
at the tv because you don't sell any
[__] tickets
[Applause]
nobody is going to women's soccer games
you're playing in a 20 000 scene arena
1500 people show up that's not a good
night the promoter lost his [__] ass
on that gig
[Music]
i'm not saying no professional female
athlete serena williams the women in the
ufc you know but nobody's watching your
[__] sport
and then you're gonna come and you're
gonna get mad at [__] men they keep
doing that [__] why are you yelling at
us
it's not our [__] job
it's not my [__] job to give a [__]
about women's soccer okay i have men's
sport to pay attention to this is
it's your [__] right
[Applause]
the funny thing is
growing up i always thought
yeah
why do women get paid less
they should get paid the same as men
and i didn't
i didn't realize that
the way the reason why they make so much
is because of the tickets they sold i
saw this um
i saw this
tick tock or something
and it was saying that essentially well
he'll probably say is that
if women
want to have equal pay and women want to
support women
why aren't women supporting women in
sports women aren't going to
women's sporting events women aren't
going to the only reason we go to
sporting events is to look at the
basketball players and try to
date them women don't even like sports
yeah exactly and so i was like why are
you pointing a finger at the men like
you should do something about this point
the finger at your species and say that
women get it together
dude look at the
wnba dude nobody in the wnba got covered
nobody
they have been playing in front of three
to 400 people a night for a quarter
of a century
to mention it's a male subsidized league
we gave you a [__] league
none of you showed up
where are all the feminists
that place should be packed with
feminists
is painted wearing jerseys slashing
their titties
going [__] nuts like the guys do in
the upper deck with their big beard
titties
am i on the jumbotron am i doing it
[Applause]
none of you
none of you went to the [__] games
none of you you all you
failed them
not me
not men women failed the wnba ladies
ladies name your top five all-time wnba
players of all time come on
that's it name five wnba teams name the
wnbc team in your [__] city you can't
do it
you
don't give a [__]
about them
they play night in and night out in
front of nobody it's a [__] tragedy
right
what i don't understand is they gave
a way to essentially women's basketball
is not that entertaining to watch
because it doesn't have all the
theatrics of
male basketball or the nba
and i i can understand that i play
basketball and i understand that when it
comes to
just men's basketball is more
theatrical more exciting than women's
basketball so they gave them
an option to
lower the rim so that
some of the females are able to dunk
and
do more theatrical things to make it
more exciting
for
um
for people to come watch so they can
sell
more tickets not first when i heard that
i was like how dare they lower the rim
and then i thought about it i'm like
it may not be that bad these women that
are
six foot seven foot still can't dunk
won't have to
essentially
do plyometrics now they'll be able to
reach it
and dunk normally
but as before even though they're six
foot seven foot
and they still not duncan
um they would have to do more plyometric
stuff to be able to jump that high to
dunk it
and one of the players were like oh
i've been shooting a 10 foot rim my
whole life
and so lowering it would just mess up my
shot i got used to shooting on a
10 foot rim
honestly i don't think it would be
that hard to adjust your shot to a nine
foot rim i could see if it was like a 10
to five foot rim then to be like okay i
can't shoot as high my fall through has
to be a little bit low and i have to
i won't be able to jump aside because
shot will be off you just adjust it real
quick as to a 9 foot rim
there's not that much
adjusting in my eyes that you have to do
you also have to get used to shooting on
it but if you have a rhythm in your shot
and you feel and you know how to feel
your shot
you'll
essentially be gucci to shoot a knife
over him
let me know what y'all think would y'all
watch the wmea more
if it had
the basket at a nine foot at nine foot
and they were able to dunk
do all this other fancy stuff would you
watch it more
and then meanwhile
you look at the kardashians
they're making billions
you know those real housewives shows
they're making money hand over fists
because that's what women are watching
the money listens
you don't want to watch this [__] you
watch this [__]
they just shoot it over there drowning
these [__] and money
and purses and shoes and botox
it's just raining
it's raining money
yeah so
the money listens you'd rather watch
that [__] real housewives bunch of women
just tearing each other down well maybe
that's why your husband left you maybe
that's why your husband left that's why
you can't have kids [__]
that's why your ass is as flat as your
titties [__] right
that's the message you sent we would
rather watch that than see a bunch of
women come together as a as a team and
try to achieve a common goal we would
rather watch them actually [__]
destroy each other
yeah
no no no and then in the end
you come back
and you [__] yell at guys like and
it's like all right so let me get this
straight i have to buy you a drink stop
the ax murderer from coming through the
[__] window
and i have to watch wnba games for you
like when are you gonna pick up your end
of the couch
[Applause]
all right that was billberry buddy
what show i like to actually
what should i react to next
oh no
oh no oh no no no no no okay okay
what's the problem here
huh
thank you for the super chat hello
do y'all want me to try the collins here
we have it set up i think
um
and i can try it but
in the meantime in between time i'll
look up no reason to hit a woman
by bill there
now it wants to work
smear
all right chad let me know which one it
is
um
yes sir j blade we still in this thing
top one all right
[Music]
thanks
zach e
i can't how many minutes is it i can't
even see
oh well
no we have these huge battles
you know what the matter she ever got me
was one time she was watching this show
was like a poor excuse for the view and
they started talking about domestic
violence right for the nine millionth
time this year they're talking about
domestic violence just in case you know
you didn't get the memo
you know evidently you know just some
people didn't get it it's not okay to
slam your wife's head into the cupboard
drawers
because she didn't dry the can opener
off properly you know
gonna [__] rust right
how do you not know not to do that [__]
do they really have to keep talking
about it
it's like wife beaters watching for oh
[__] ah
now i get it up so daisy sweetheart here
we go there you go
[Applause]
so at the end of the hour they come to
the logical conclusion they're like
there is no reason to hit a woman there
is no reason to hit a woman and i was
just like really i could give you like
17 right off the top of my head
you could wake me from a drunken stupor
i could still give you like nine
what would you guys say is
a reason to hit a woman
i say if she hits you
like like auntie said she said it best
said it that one time put it in check
put in dirt dirt dirt put in dirt
plenty of reasons to hit a woman you
just don't do it
but to sit there and suggest that
there's no reason
dude the level of ego behind that
statement
what are you levitating above the rest
of us you're never annoying
women how many times have you thought
about slapping you you [__] guy in
the head this week
[Applause]
there you go
every day
you didn't do it right
oh dude it drives me nuts there's no
ethan there's no reason really no reason
how about this you marry a girl you fall
in love you buy her a house you go to
work every day paying off the house you
come home one day she's banging the next
door neighbor hands you divorce papers
you gotta move out sleep on a futon and
still pay for that house that she's
gonna stay in no reason
come again
wait what
wow
as a man i'd be pissed i'd be like
no
find your own place baby girl you ain't
no no no no you ain't about to put me
in a worse position than i met you
when you was nothing when you met me
but you get everything now nope
you better go back
no ma'am no ham no turkey
i'm not saying you should do it but
there's plenty of [__] reasons
in that arc of a story
all right that was a hypothetical
you want an actual story
i'll give you one i'll give you one all
right i [__] up my foot playing drums
trying to get my bass drum foot as fast
as uh john bonham's because i figured
that's a good thing to focus on 43 years
of age never married no kids i figured
this this is going to lead me to the
light right this this this is what i
need to do
so i don't know what i did i i felt like
after i played for like an hour and
afterwards i felt like it literally like
there was some [__] stabbing me in the
bottom of my foot right like had
lightning coming out of the bottom of my
foot
so i did the typical guy thing i'm like
i'm not going to the hospital i'll sleep
it off i'll be fine right next morning i
wake up my foot's even worse and i got
to walk my crazy dog
so i'm like i can't do it my foot's
killing me so i wake up my girl go
sweetheart sweetheart can you do me a
favor can you do me favor can you walk
the dog for me can you uh just take the
shift you know i'll do your afternoon
shift can you just do me this all i can
do this for me and she's just like oh
you know i had a late late night last
night i'm tired i have a big day and i
just go [__] it
she goes what do you mean [__] it it's
like why can't you just say no
why do you always gotta like waterboard
me with like a 20-minute explanation
that eventually lines its way around to
go [__] yourself just say no
so i'm just limping out of the room
whatever go back to bed you got a big
dave right
so now i'm like limping down the street
i got like tourette's [__] goddamn
[__]
guys i'm starting to get sleepy but
ain't nobody falling asleep you want to
stay up
but i if you see me nothing don't nobody
say nothing don't nobody say nothing
okay
everybody sleep
ellie sleep
pearl sleep
blessing sleep viciously
girl's the only one that's up
and it's almost 9 30
10 30 11 30
10 so like two hours or 40 minutes
two hours and 40 minutes
we are almost there guys like up the
video
i get up like it up like it up
i get up like it up
oh
jesse lee peterson
compilations
okay
yeah
doing it again i'm gonna get back to
this live stream and then i'll
i'll look at the chat again
it's ellie snorin that's who's snoring
yeah
dogs walking next to me
[Applause]
i gotta admit i got a little childish
i did i got a little childish you know i
was just thinking about my relationship
i'm like this is the relationship i'm in
you're just gonna do whatever the hell
you wanna do right and [__] me fine i'm
gonna do whatever hell i wanna do i feel
like listening to my ipod on full blast
walking around the house that's what i'm
gonna do
so that's what i did turned it all the
way up and i just my whole plan was just
to walk by her like i didn't even know
her that was it she came down the hall i
just ghosted her just walked right past
her
just trying to piss her off i gotta tell
you something work like a charm
worked like a charm
yeah hung my coat up turned around by
the time i turned around she was already
yelling at me but the music was so loud
not only could i not hear her it
actually looked like she was singing the
song that i was listening to
ah it's one of the highlights of the
relationship
so i knew what she was saying i was like
whatever i don't want to talk about it
leave me alone i'm going onto the
computer right so i limp over and i sit
down and unbeknownst to me she's like
now we're going to talk about this right
now comes up
and slaps the headphones off my head
why
why is it that one woman when i talk
about something talk about it right then
and there but when a man wants to talk
about something like no i don't want to
talk about it i don't want to talk about
it and they won't allow
him to actually
help
them process whatever it is they're
going through but they'll be like nah i
don't want to talk about it i don't talk
about it
but the man essentially is supposed to
tell you what's wrong or talk about the
situation right then and there because
you want to
that's so weird to me
i got a big i got big ears it [__]
hurt
so like honey leave me alone i don't
want to talk about it put the headphones
back on she comes right back up again
slaps them off a little harder this time
they spin halfway around my head
caveman dna starts coming up
talking through my teeth honey leave me
alone don't want to talk about it right
put them on third time she comes up
slaps him right across the room and i
snap i'm like fine you want to have the
fight let's [__] have the fight she's
like we will discuss this later when you
calm down
ah right there i just wanted to roll her
up on her yoga mat and stuff her behind
the couch
just leave her there until she got
thirsty come on let me out of here i
have a spin class you've made your point
this is this is ridiculous
[Applause]
no that's the thing
really is that's the thing i hate that
saying there's no reason obviously i'm
not saying it hit a woman you know
but saying there's no reason i think
that's crazy
when you say there's no reason that
kills any sort of examination as to how
two people ended up at that at that
place
you say there's no reason
you cut out the build up you're just
left with the act how are you gonna
solve it if you don't figure it out
look how awkward it is in here right now
i said you shouldn't hit a woman i'm
just saying how come you can't ask
questions you can only ask questions
about what the guy did you can never ask
about the woman why is that
why is that what is
that is what does answer them write me
what the freak she said answer my answer
right
you barge into the room you said no
we're gonna talk about this right now
and he's like no i don't want to talk
about it
and then he's like all right talk about
it no we'll talk about it when you calm
down you just said you want to talk
about it but i don't want to talk about
it
if he would have went to her i'm like no
we're talking about this right now she
would like no i don't want to talk about
it she would have got irritated as well
he's like he would have been like no
we're going to talk about this right now
how can you tell me when we're going to
talk about something you can't control
me blah blah blah blah blah and she said
answer it right
what's the right answer
everybody like okay sweetie we'll talk
about this right now
i'll sit down and hear what you gotta
say go ahead sweetie
express yourself does she does she want
him to do that what do you mean anthony
right that is the dumbest thing
y'all women are
an interesting species it's an answer
right i wanna i wanna hear what she has
to say answer me right
answer right know
respect his choice
of not
wanting to talk about it right now and i
say that about men and women if someone
doesn't want to talk about something
right then and there give them time to
process it give them time to think about
it and then if they want to talk about
it with you they'll talk about it with
you and if they don't they won't
but you think
at first you say we're going to talk
about this right now
he got irritated he was like all right
let's talk about it
i will talk about it when you calm down
you don't get to decide
it's like you want it on your terms
anyways
it's getting to that point i'm getting
i'm getting a little heated
heated
what does that mean are you the idiot
who got up halfway through the special
during the bit and you're like walking
around like i'm not [__] taping a
special here what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you
[__] had to ignore all of that and
now you're gonna like yell out and not
only that yell something that makes no
[__] sense whatsoever
answer him answer him
[Applause]
every [__] special i do there's
always one
always right down the [__] middle
talking about hitting women sweetheart
and i think you just added another
reason
jesus [__] christ
[Applause]
i feel like if more people hit women
they would
they would know their place
because from what i've seen a lot of
women just think they can walk all over
people walk all over men
and this is before i was ever that i
ever met pearl i was ever in
um ever being
red pilled or whatever
time to stretch guys
but
it um
i always think about this like why why
do women think like that why do women
process stuff like that
it just doesn't make sense
and it's like
how come
a woman can hit a man but a man can't a
woman
and he's like you shouldn't be able to
and i always thought that i'm like well
man i should be able to hit back but a
man can't because
he's a man
but he should
because if someone hits you
you gonna
bop him back
so
yeah
i just feel like more common sense would
be knocked into women if they got hit
moving on
i love this i'm not even in a
relationship with her and she's [__]
nagging me
look
i understand hit and was a bad thing
okay
how come you can't [__] ask questions
i just don't understand like if i get
bit by a rattlesnake wouldn't you guys
have some questions
right how did it happen did you not see
it were you [__] with it
how did this snake get so mad it almost
killed you
firemen put out a fire they don't just
drive away afterwards they sift through
the debris
how did it start here's an oily rag
right
look i realized
yes auntie pearl is asleep right now
a little sleepyhead
coming off pretty ignorant right about
now
i realize that
let me extend an olive branch then okay
i realize that there's some animal guys
out there okay horrible guys you know
have a rough day at the factory come
home tune a casserole and just start
swinging all right
i'm not trying to say that those people
don't exist i realize they exist they
should be buried underneath the prison
okay
so if i can admit that ladies can you at
least admit that every ass kicking
doesn't just fall out of the [__] sky
really
even hockey has two minutes for
instigating right
they understand that some back and forth
happened before that [__] you know
you know what it is is every case is
handled like that rihanna one well they
just say the guy's a piece of [__] [__]
this guy blah blah blah jail then they
never ask anything about that you know
i'm not saying he should have done it
but i'm just saying
just say it dude in your heart of hearts
what do you think was going down before
that happened you think she was just
sitting there going oh my god baskin
robbins you want to get some ice cream
[Applause]
you know or do you think maybe they were
having some epic end of the relationship
fight and some crazy [__] was being said
maybe she was screaming in his ears some
crazy female [__] like oh [__] all your
friends i don't give a [__]
[Applause]
maybe that's why i sell more albums than
you [__]
right
to be fair she could have just been
sitting there going i need a tissue do
you keep those in the glove box oh my
god i'll bring my house
now [__] that because you know what it
is they never address how women argue
which i think is a core of a lot of that
[__]
you know i gotta tell you something man
like i never knew how women argued but
after 20 years of losing every
significant battle
in a relationship i finally figured out
how they argued i'm going to tell you
something i'm starting to turn this
franchise around
i have begun
a winning tradition
this is how they argue as far as i can
tell all right if they're right they
argue the point and they stay on point
and make sure you stay on point until
you're down on your knees apologizing
begging for forgiveness all right no
problem with that totally respect it but
here's the thing if they're wrong they
go rogue they go off-road
they start thinking of [__] you're
sensitive about maybe you don't get
along with your dad and in their head
they just start concocting this evil
statement
totally designed this desperate
hail mary attempt
to make you so [__] mad you just call
him a [__]
that's what it is and [__] trumps all
the [__] they did to start the
argument now it's not about that one
there's no reason to call me a [__] and
then that's it you're in this room now
right
my girl knows my big thing is my big
fear in life is to be that dude who
grows old you know grows old alone has
like that basement apartment
just screaming up at the younger couple
turn it down
that isn't music
so i noticed that any time she was
losing a fight i don't know what she
just feels but that's why you're just
going to grow old and be alone then
i'd lose my [__]
the next thing you know i'm in the
kitchen washing dishes for the ninth
[__] time in a row this is what the
argument was about i was so right what
happened
so if you learn anything from my
ignorance tonight
just know this next time you're in a
battle with your beautiful woman your
wife girlfriend whatever and they start
out of nowhere okay you're winning and
they just start saying that crazy [__]
out of nowhere just know in that moment
you've won the fight okay
all right don't get mad bob and weave
slip all of that [__] maybe because you
got a little dick just let that slide
stay in the pocket of the argument
that's so interesting because that is
exactly
exactly how women argue they know that
when they're wrong they gotta cut you
somewhere to get you to detour off of
what actually
was
um
was the argument or was the point
and
it's like a man will tell a woman
something in secret
and
uh like
confidentiality
because it's expressing it and then
they'll take that and be like i got a
weapon now i can use that whenever i
feel like it and they take it
as a weapon
to whenever they need it and they just
like yeah like him that's why you're
gonna die alone and be bald or whatever
he said
and it's just like yo that cuts deep
because that's a fear
and is literally the worst
the worst
it's so annoying i'm like
get women's deeper darkest fear i'm
looking at
get women's deepest darkest fear get
something that they are terrified about
i don't
i don't condone an eye for an eye tooth
for two
but if they do it why can't man do it
get their deepest darkest fear
put in your back pocket whenever they
start detouring and they say well you're
gonna be bald and die alone
well
you're going to be
45 year old childless living alone by
yourself homeless
how about dead
susie
um
oh
thanks
thanks madeline
i'm not a coffee drinker but
um
i appreciate it i appreciate it
[Music]
y'all during that first one i was like
i felt like i was going out i was like
i can't hold on look at y'all okay oh
don't wait long
i'm trying to hold it as much as i can
biggest
the biggest relation argument
why the bell whatever tell my woman
i'm not saying do it i'm saying men
do sometimes and then that's when women
use it as a weapon
i guess people are jumping in and
hearing me speak spanish
um
i know y'all saw me over there
that's so embarrassing y'all saw me go
i've always wanted to see myself do that
because i always think my eyes are open
i'm like
but no i was like
falling
i'm stepping on my legs
what does shoot your shot mean oh shoot
your shot means like
one slide into someone's dm
or essentially
approaching them and telling them like i
think you're attractive i want to go out
with you i want to take you out xyz
shooting your shot
i take the ball
i bounce it
i shoot it
either score it or it's gonna be a miss
just shoot your shot
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
you don't take
michael jordan everybody give it up for
mj one of the goats
um
is it i don't know where doug is i think
doug left
woman
y'all are funny
y'all are funny funny funny
um is there anything else that i should
um
is there something else i was gonna do
anything else that i should react to
we're gonna leave this guy right
here and i'll be right back
talks amongst yourself in the chat
send me a question or a song to sing we
might do some karaoke might do some
songs
um
any era any genre i may know it so yeah
go ahead and do that
[Music]
ah
uh
um
[Music]
all right welcome back
um
who fell asleep ain't nobody fall asleep
that's crazy 5k
that's
that's crazy
um
dwayne wade am i offended wayne wade i
haven't reacted to andrew tate yet
he was cool i liked the way d wade
it works all the time
30 of the time
i can't react to music
cobra tate who's cobert is that andrew
tate's brother
if y'all have some
videos that
won't get
essentially copyrighted i'm not trying
to get this
yeah she's gonna dream of
dream a dream i've read pills
everybody is just
snoring
close your eyes shut your mouth drain my
dream and get it down
my girl likes to party all the time
party all the time party all the time
y'all thought i'd try to throw a party
y'all try to throw a party without me it
is 9 43.
i can't do music because it will get
copyrighted eddie murphy eddie murphy's
music loki's labs
uh parliament i met
i want to be me
we met like
in
i would say like january
actually no we met before the end of
last year
she would come to basketball practice
every so often because she was here for
volleyball
um
and
she would come to basketball practice
every now and then and then come and
play and then
sorry
i found out she did youtube as work so i
was like cool that's awesome
and then we ride back home from a game
we just talk chop it up and then she
needed
people for a podcast so i was like yeah
i'll come on
and then from there i was on x amount of
podcasts
did a reaction video for her that blew
up
then now i'm here and i work for her
yeah
that's how we that's that's our that's
our story
[Music]
bobby you know it close your eyes shut
your mouth dream a dream and get us out
dream dream dream dream dream dream
get the hay fast asleep dream my dream
you little bleep dream dream dream green
green green
is you single
uh
jessie lee
peterson who is that
who's jesse lee peterson watching from
australia
6 14 p.m
good day mate
i don't even say i think they say that
over there
yes that is pearl sleeving
okay
how did i not hear any murphy music
before
you've never heard eddie murphy's music
look madeline putting y'all on
hey everybody just like like it up like
it up like it up like up the video if
you're in here it just helps algorithm
thanks naseem
washington state
you must say you will say
okay
oh it's a he
okay i'm thinking it's a
anybody has a song with michael jackson
and snoop dogg
hi if you're just joining we are doing a
24 hour live stream for just pearly
things reaching
um
250k
uh for school right now
after that it's
whatever we choose
i'm i'm not sure what she's gonna do so
i can't speak in it
thanks
take a hike
appreciate it
y'all are great you're all so much fun
to hang out with i'm like can we stream
every day
can we all be best friends
ah good day mate
australian too
brinsby prince p way yo i watched this
um
it's like instant uh yeah it's called
instant hotel on netflix and it's all in
australia
oh my gosh the place is there beautiful
i'm like
so i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna go to australia
just for those
um so you said jesse lee peterson
oh i don't know what just happened
um
one pros not contaminated my mind i have
my own thoughts and everything
um what kind of content i like
um
sorry i'm saying i'm a lot
no we're not
yes
south africa
um it's something that we've talked
talked about
uh
jamel something we talked about but
can't
obviously do right now because it's not
anywhere near that
but it would be
cool
y'all this is not this is not my not my
channel
so it doesn't say anything to reckless
this is still pearl's channel thanks
i'm just being comfy because i need to
be
so i can stay awake
um
uh
jessie lee
um
i hope this doesn't get is this gonna
get copyrighted
which one is it guys
i don't want this to get copyrighted
would this get copyrighted
are you asking jenny are you
saying
is the dog snoring everybody's not pearl
we are going on our
21st
22nd yeah 22nd hour
we started at like 12 10 ish
so
almost down to the last two hours
okay
well thanks for migrating over we
appreciate it
we appreciate all the support guys
um
let's see
trying to think
who could we react to that we react to
already
holding down
what do you say
i was getting there the chat saw me
wobbling
it's just like oh and then i gotta hold
this slap slap slap and then i'm awake
my height and my weight you know you do
not ask a woman that
[Music]
if you were here earlier i would have
told you you would have known my height
i've said it like four five times
wait one of them
that's all good they can they can sleep
sleep
oh thanks thanks alyssa
i appreciate it
they're just her page
huh
oh no i took i did take it i did take it
off well i had to take it off and then i
put it back on yeah i just been reacting
to videos
i know once i get home i'm out for the
day i'm out for the count
2056 y'all this is ridiculous
my goodness
we're about to be at 260k guess i'm
going another 24 hours
you're funny
happy sunday everybody
if someone's in the super chat of like a
thousand would you do another 24 hours
right now
who said that
oh if so if someone sent a super chat of
a thousand
the 500 is the as a cut off
no
no i would not
blessings was asking if someone
uh sent
500 for
a 500 super chat would i do another
um
24 hours i it new
no it's not ish it's just sleep in this
car
300k let's go 24 hour live stream nope
y'all are funny y'all are funny funny
funny thanks bobby bobby remembers
yeah correct that's about right
i'm like a 3-4
i played like four or five my whole life
um this last past season it was like a
three four
i'm not talking about that
monkey monkey junk monkey jumble
uh
i'm not sure let's see what's the
temperature going to be like in london
today
oh
i don't have it switched
i was gonna be hot today
high of
90 degrees
fahrenheit
i don't know what that is in
let's see if i can change it there we go
it's going to be 27.
and i'm gonna be asleep
but it's okay
that's all right that's okay
i know two more hours
yo auntie
yeah
yeah i was telling pearl one thing about
and cardiff you're from wales
cardiff is 32. who's going to be a hot
one today
bonnie i was telling pearl that there
are some
women that will
say their point
pause wait for
wait for somebody else to respond and
then before that person finishes
they already have what they want to say
in their brain and they'll just say it
instead of waiting for that person to
finish their response
listen to it
and then
respond because what they're saying the
other person might be answering the
other person might be explaining it but
they're too impatient to
to do that
to actually sit and listen
and
take in what they're saying that you're
just like i'm gonna say my point and my
point matters and it's just like yo you
you really can't you really can't talk
with people like that
and it's just like
it's annoying oh hello from japan if
you're just coming in
hi
i'm jess my actual name is jessica but
everybody calls me jess i
am i'm not just brilliant things this
sleeping beauty right here is just
pearly things we are live streaming for
24 hours
and we're coming up on the last two
hours of the live stream
we're celebrating 250k we did it at 100k
and the folks wanted 250k so we're doing
it again
if you were in here and you know all
this stuff
um
bear with me
i'm trying to think follow pearl on
instagram
just.pearlythings
we have a clips channel go ahead and go
over to the clips if you want to get
clips from today they're going to be
there auntie says some awesome awesome
things today if you don't know who
auntie is check her out she is great
um there's going to be some clips from
today clips from all of our other shows
there so follow the clips channel follow
this channel subscribe to it to see the
live um
shows
also i don't know if
i'll put this in the community post as
well for the members and subscribers
that are on this channel
everything that has been filmed up to
this point not pearls like old old stuff
just yet but from pre-game on from the
first episode of the pre-game show on to
now
all of these shows and everything are
organized into playlists so if you want
to go back you don't have to thumb
through all the shows to try to find it
you have the pre-game uh show you have
the clips that were on this channel you
have the gray area you have the street
talks you have the coffee thoughts all
of those are in playlists so if you want
to go back thumb through those and find
the episode that you want you can do
that oh and the reactions with me as
well
um
if you want to come on the show
dm eddie is in the description box below
it's also on pearl's instagram
um bio
like the video subscribe to channel also
if you would like to see more content
behind the scenes stuff
what our new studio is going to look
like go ahead
and
become a member the second tier is more
behind the scenes stuff the first tier
is just the basics you have access to
remember only chats remember only live
streams that are going to be happening
right now once a month until we get a
rhythm in and we want to be able to do
it either twice a month or once a week
to be able to connect with the members
we have the
call-in set up now so we will do a
call-in here soon for members only and
that could possibly just be a certain
tier or all the members so the first
tier is pretty much you get access to um
not everything but the basics second
tier you get access to everything in the
first tier but you also get behind the
scene footage
third tier you get to connect with pearl
moore in the
fourth tier you get to have a one-on-one
call with her every single month
so
um those are some things that are on the
channel
trying to think if you want to follow my
stuff i have an instagram it is your
girl justly
and then i also have a youtube channel
that is it's your girl jess i do vlogs
and stuff i just
just me that's all nothing
too
crazy you just get to see who i am a
little bit more
what's a blessing
um
so yeah
that's
i think that was all the announcements
that's all the church announcements
um
what else what else
everybody have a big fun party down get
on it
as that blue pill sleep i see
um
[Music]
yeah i think that's everything
subscribe like
yeah this is that's for everybody who's
just now coming in if y'all have been
here don't know the gist you don't know
what to do
um
uh craic i don't know what that means
i'm sorry but i don't know who this man
is
i know she's sleeping like a baby
oh bye the bad guy 93
bye
have a good day good night wherever you
are thanks for coming
i am not pearl's manager nope that is
not me
and not me
yes we're still awake
if you want to go lay down in your room
you can
go ahead i'll wrap it up
bye pearl
all right
thanks i appreciate it
we appreciate all the support you guys
give
and we appreciate all the super chats
that's been coming in today it's been
awesome
yeah what are some things y'all watch on
netflix i need some new
some new docs and some new
um shows i watch crime docs i've been
watching
a lot of them i just watched i killed my
dad and i was like how what come again
you said bye pearl thanks for coming to
the show
um
bye alyssa
i will i'll tell everybody said bye
thanks again for coming
we appreciate y'all thanks again for the
camera and we can't wait to see the
books coming out soon
yeah
then there was one for real for real
it's just me
yes football first i still on here we go
right into the wheels fall off baby
right until the wheels fall off
i wish doug was awake somebody wake up
dug so we can do some karaoke
nah he sleep
mama says
mama my mama my my mama said netflix is
the devil
i think
okay
that'd be cool
just jessie things now the show is just
jesse things
shoot the ball
oh okay
i got you
um
yes vash for netflix
i would say slash the rim i'm trying to
get into the mode of shooting the ball
but i've always been a slasher always
been a cutter
always been a rebounder
defender
but i'm trying to
up my game like i have it it's just
i never really used it
should i
what time is it is it bedtime for a lot
of people
is it bedtime for a lot of people
what bedtime story i want to hear
should i go on the couch i think i might
move to the couch
yeah i've seen shutter island
i've seen day shift
1805 in japan 4 a.m in chicago
is it really before it oh it is
i see i like anime
i just i just don't watch it a lot i
can't
i can't sit down to watch it like my
brothers and my cousin some of my
friends
naruto only anime i get this next this
one i'm about to say is not
is not considered
anime um
oh sorry i was reading something it's
not
anime it is
is avatar the last airbender
untouchable
oh
um
what is that one with dracula
castlevania i think it's called
that one was great
thanks jada slug
jada slug
look us looking
yes sir craig i sure is
oh yes i've seen dragon ball z
oh okay bobby that counts for me food
wars
no i haven't seen that
yo see money let's talk walking dead
i
i used to be an avid walking dead
watcher like
a big big fan of walking dead but once
they killed glenn
i was through i was out and once i
killed um
what's the redhead guy i cannot remember
his name
oh
i was out
i was like how dare you how dare you do
that i was like i hope somebody kill him
slowly
i wanted i just
i couldn't my heart was broken
yeah vash i love baki i can't wait for
them i'm like i need y'all to finish it
finish it please
um
the original baku series is that be is
that the series that just came out so
like the prequel essentially to the baki
that's there now
because i saw the
i saw the baki
like the tournament one i saw that one
and then the new baki came out
um
sydney another mortar of australia
lord have mercy jim get off the get off
the string get off the stream jim
i don't want no problems i want no
problems
get off
and get off the stream please
we're done fun fact
for your where'd chris go chris never
sent me
no um
jada pinky quotes i was looking forward
to those
fun facts for your morning the first
influencer or a group of socialites in
england hired by edward
bernays bernards
bernas
we're going to say that
to smoke in public it was part of an ad
for cigarette talk
secrets talked about in a book
propaganda huh
walking dead feels like walking dragon
balls
different day
interesting
jack wig
i saw the guy
huh
the matrix i've seen the matrix great
great movie
i haven't seen jessica jones
correction the socialites were in new
york
okay
another original bucky series isn't on
netflix
oh no i haven't seen the original baku
series then
um
i haven't yeah i haven't seen the
original bucky series
bakihan mai oh my gosh
when he was
yo the final fight he had and he's
literally
knocking on death's door i was like
pocky
come through bucky please come through
bucky and he did
i was like can't nobody stop him okay
nobody stop him
oh
i feel bad i feel for will
people can say what they're on about
square games it was
it's quick games
it was
i say it was hyped up
it was cool
but it was
hyped up how would i do it
if i didn't die possibly
what i like about london
it's
it's not like
i like so early i was talking about how
it's like there's a lot of people here
and people are moving and grooving but
it's not like a fast-paced feeling it's
like a like a calming feeling
but what i've been what i've been
telling people like what makes london so
great for me
is the people that i've met here if i
wouldn't have met the people i would not
have had the experiences the experiences
that i've had here
and
they're just like i've just met so many
great people from so many different
areas and so many different walks of
life and it's just so awesome i love the
public transportation system here it's
so easy to get around feel like i
have to drive somewhere yes it takes
long to get places
but
it's like i can walk to the train hop on
it and just ride and it's just so just
like
yeah
that's why i love
i just really like london
you know
i love my men's from everywhere so
there's no no discrimination i love my
mans in the us i love my mans in the uk
i love my mans in
everywhere
i just love my means
90 frito pie i'm doing good everybody
saw me wobble a little bit but i'm doing
good how are you doing how are you
it really is
what is the compound answer oh
it's not a cop-out answer go ahead if
you miss pearl leave i'm kidding
okay good question pocky
yo
i
i'm gonna keep it 100 with you bash i
don't remember the character's name i
haven't watched pocky in a minute
and so i'm
look here a little foot fetish i ain't
taking my socks though i haven't watched
baki in a minute so
i don't remember the character's name
uh patrice o'neill the black
philip show
oh goodness
that seems long
um
oh
90 free drop i was at the club living it
up
what club you go to 90 free to pie
what type of music was they playing
there
yes goku black i do
thanks for pointing it out
i've had these my whole life
so it's nothing new
the boondocks
show
okay has anybody ever seen the episode
of the boondocks where uncle uncle
ruckus goes with that country singer and
makes that song
if you know you know the song
anything you figure
that one
anybody
i can't say it
i can't say what it is
no
i'm not a fighter
i don't fight nobody if i need to
i don't box
liam you know exactly what i'm talking
about yes sir
yes vash
uh if you've never seen the i
90 free topic i'm not about to say it
you say it since you know what it is no
don't say it this is pros chat
uncle ruckus is hilarious
i can say it
i can say it but i'm not gonna say
because it's not my platform
on your red pill journey has there been
a singular concept that you have changed
your mind on that's been the hardest or
most dramatic
i won't say
hardest or most dramatic it's 90 free to
pi stop it stop it right now
do not type
[Music]
someone get get your boy someone get
your boy in the chat right now
i mean i have been lifting
no
um
i wouldn't say something
it's just been
taking what i know
and deconstructing it
and to the things i know now and being
like okay
how do i take these two things and
sifter out
the stuff that
i i've been taught my whole life
and then stuff i have
just learned that
is mind-blowing but i've also like kind
of thought about growing up so it's just
that and it's just like sitting there
and like
rethinking like how do i process this
and also
understanding the male species more and
how simple
it is in certain situations when it
comes to relationships how simple it is
to
be in
relationship with them what they expect
and
if i
wanted a high volume and what
could possibly come with that and if i'm
in that
setting to
obtain that and so it's just been a lot
of stuff that i've
learned so everything has just been like
what
what in the world
and um
i've just had to
really think about everything and it's
very educational very insightful
and just
cool at the same time
do you find that people outside the us
like london harley's edward echo america
a lot as a black man and always
yeah
um
here they don't they really don't use it
that much
um
i rarely hear people use it like i ask
somebody i'm like do they say the word
here and they're like
yeah but not that much i was like
interesting in america
it's used
anywhere everywhere
anyhow
so it's different
um
y'all asked me some uh
ask me some
questions about red pill i want to kind
of keep it
uh
oh thanks noelle i appreciate that
yeah like i jc i i knew that
and it wasn't
it wasn't like i didn't
understand
the male species at all because i grew
up around i grew up around guys my whole
life and just like hearing how they
talked hearing how they operated in
situations with women what they would
say about women i
understood it in a sense
but
obviously i'm still a female and so
there's still concepts that i would
always think well a man likes this a man
wants this
to hear
more so like what they wanted but also
just how
they see the world how essentially y'all
see the world it was it's interesting
and
i
like i said i love
love my mans love my mens but to have a
like a new appreciation for them to know
that i want i want them to have
the same
same opportunities yes they have
opportunities in xyz areas
but i want them to have
opportunities over here that can benefit
them as well that women also have so it
was just like
let's all get along no not like that but
it was just
it's just insightful
[Music]
yo
yo i'm about to get a blanket and just
cover up my feet
what if i had corns on my toes and y'all
didn't know
i just had hip toes
um this is just what were your first
impressions after being on the show for
the first time be real
my first
impression it was
it was interesting i've always been
the type of person to
be
open to what
other people
other people's ideas and what they have
to say
i never was the type of person that was
like no i believe this so you're gonna
have to believe but i believe and what i
think is true or you're wrong it was it
was cool to be able to sit down i forgot
what the topic was but to sit down and
like talk with the group
but to look back on it now my thought
process was so different
then that it is now and i watch it i'm
like shut up jessica
but the first time i was on i was like
that was cool
that was cool and i told pearl i was
like look if you ever need somebody i'll
be on it i know this is like just the
beginning so if you ever need guests let
me know and if i'm free i'm there
and so i was one of the ones that were
that was consistently here and now
we're here where it's at so it was just
cool to see it
from
literally the ground from the first show
on up and
i enjoyed myself the first episode and
every episode after that so it was fun
i do play ball
there okay i play ball but i try to keep
my feet
try to keep my feet nice
they ain't they toe up from the flow up
i promise you that
we talked about that a little bit joey
about men and women sports we talked
about a little bit about that earlier
what pro-mentioned or not
it wasn't
max it wasn't hard to accept what pearl
mentioned it was just like a
huh okay
i never
i never thought of it like that like i
said earlier let me let me take it
and like chew on it digest it
and from there
see see how i see how i see it do i see
it the same way do i see it in a
different way so it wasn't like a oh my
gosh i'm going to take what she said and
i'm going to
essentially
adopt it and attach it to me because
that's what pearl said and
it's it's bible
it's essentially i'm taking it i'm
thinking about it i'm like okay
how how does this make sense in my brain
and if i don't agree with it i just
don't agree with it and if i
if it makes sense and i start agreeing
with i'm like okay because there's some
things that pros told me and i'm like i
can't unsee it now there's so there's
just things in the world and things in
my life that i'm like
is this why this happened is this
why this is like it is and i'm like i
can't see it now
so
yeah it wasn't hard to
say essentially take on what she said it
was just like a like a conversation that
i'm having with somebody and if i agree
with it i'll take it
and yeah
no
simon i was just playing i'm
i was kidding
with my response so no you're fine you
didn't sound overly critical
um he said hi jess just all your
response to my question i hope i didn't
sound over the critical but i was only
wondering uh why you guys were doing
this given the way anna was flaked out
oh
uh pearl was flicked out to you no
offense meant no none taken at all simon
i promise you i was just joking around
i'm a jokester and i'm tired i've been
up for
22 and a half hours so you're good simon
oh good
is that gwegoy yes ma'am
it's just back y'all
and he sounds like he's well rested
90 frito pie said my original red pill
was hearing jesse lee peterson tell
people to forgive their mothers and
return to their fathers
it changed everything for me wow that's
amazing
just do you find the submissive cons
submissive
conversation sorry
jess do you find the submissive con
conversation difficult with women
the world seems to always trigger them
yet they all work for someone they
submit to their boss
but never their
man um
uh mr
yeah
i'm not pearl i'm jess so pearl is uh
rose elsewhere pearl is in her room
taking a nap so yeah if you're just not
tuning in i'm jess i am on the team here
at just pearly things um we are doing a
24-hour
livestream we are headed into the last
hour and a
half yeah last hour and like 40 minutes
of it and we've been here since 12 10 12
15 ish yesterday
afternoon
so we are celebrating 250k subscribers
on the just pearly things channel we did
this at 100k and now we're doing a 250k
don't know when we'll be doing it next
there's a rumor going out there
don't believe don't believe the lies
don't believe the last someone may say
that i said it i didn't say not a dang
thing
but yeah so we're just here celebrating
i know it's just me
um everybody was taking a nap and i
decided to stay up and keep it rolling
because we wanted to make sure that you
guys got the 24 hour live stream with at
least one person so if you're new like
it up um subscribe to the channel we
have a cliff's channel if you've been in
here before i'm sorry that i'm running
through this again i just got to let the
new people know
subscribe to the clip channel if you
want to see clips from today
if you want to be on the show eddie in
description
yeah i'm just going to go through that
um
just pearly things
just um
there's a question um
so
i'll say before
i met pearl i wouldn't say it was hard
the submissive conversation it was just
like a well
why can't i do my thing as well why do i
have to not do
anything and submit to him only
and then i
slowly understood what it actually meant
and i was like okay
it makes sense and it's something that i
innately
do um
anyways if i'm
in a relationship i'll
it's hard to
it's hard to do it because
i want to like leave things here leave
things there and be like okay let's do
this let's do that x y z but it's also
like i i have to let i have to let him
do things i can't always be like
leading in a sense because the man is
ahead of the household and that is how
it is
so it's not
it's not a hard conversation to have
it's where
women
don't want to do it and it's like
why for the right man you will do it
and that's that's on period
i know donnie i'm keeping going i'm
keeping going what up skd welcome back
i know ish is up
um thank you i appreciate it
i i don't know if i
if
i like being on the panel
like i hosted it and it was cool but i
was thinking about that i like being on
the panel i like being in the mix
mix mixing mix
hey just you and pearl know about the
original red pill stuff it seems i know
about the newer stuff
not the side part
i'm not the one to ask about it i'm not
sure
i'm still i'm standing
right there when where neal was
with morpheus the pills in hand i'm
reaching for the red pill still
it's still
digesting in me so i i don't know
nothing about nothing in the red pill
i don't know nothing about nothing um
no
i'm i'm gonna leave pearl i'm gonna
leave pearl asleep
um yeah
the hive mind i don't know what the hive
mind theory is
can't help you there
what makes a great wife ish what do you
think makes a great wife
[Music]
uh yeah you just need to turn on this
mic
yeah because i have the one that goes
right there
so it's the second one
i have the third one right now
just the man in the
yeah i understand that
i'm just gonna leave my lid right here
do you do you want this one that i have
because that goes to you
okay i know how this works
here
everybody give it up
there's a sniper
not a spotter
um what was the question
what did i ask you
oh what makes a great wife
oh let me take off this
keep going
hello
i can i was like i can't hear nothing
come
ah there we go
um we are
live
trying to figure some stuff out right
now
you think i
these for a living but yeah um what
makes a good wife yeah what makes a good
white fish
i think there's many factors that go
into it
compassion being one of them
the willingness to
submit
but also
understand that we all have roles in the
relationship
accountability
but more so
holding your man accountable to being a
man that he needs to be or
you'd want
him to be and also be an accountable for
your own actions as well
um
cooperativeness
now she's been taken out
being a sexival
in the bedroom y'all want a lady in the
street but freaking the bear tell him
period um
i think there's balance and
you gotta be like that
and also
your man's gotta be that kind of
dominant man
for you to kind of respect him they say
don't forget the honesty and loyalty
we get in there people but i appreciate
you for
helping me remember you know we've been
here for a minute mm-hmm
feel the stump stomach and empty the
sack
period honesty
honesty is huge um
just an honest relationship with great
communication
um just adding on to the points that the
chat have put out loyalty
one of them
loyalty's huge because
as a man you want loyalty
and
in order for you to have a relationship
that kind of flourishes
loyalty is a key
it's a key point
um
[Music]
i don't think women understand how big
loyalty is to a man
that's why they ask questions like well
if he can go out and do it can't i yeah
yeah and it's like if you used to ask
that question it clearly means it's not
that important to you yeah
but yeah um
if there's any points i've missed out
chat put them in the chat let me know
i'll probably speak on them um but those
few things
i do believe to being
even saying something about them
all night
chat
sometimes they're funny
sometimes we've been right here chat
me and you
just been hit the whole way yeah
jess
gang gang gang gang remember to go
follow her on the socials yeah
it's
your girl jess lee
didn't know your girl jesley damn it
your girl jess leon
there's no it's it's just a girl your
girl jesse on instagram go follow that
and then it's your girl jess on youtube
it's a girl jess on youtube go like that
comment subscribe she got a video out
right now yeah i got a couple i've got a
couple
got coupled up
a couple double
trying to get more out but i need to get
this dissertation done
yeah anybody want to write my
dissertation for me dm me on instagram
it's about
um what is it about
i don't know she's joking guys
disclaimer
hey you don't know who's watching i know
i'm joking
now if anyone ever dm i'd be like i'm
playing my pride won't let me do that
i was gonna sing a song i don't remember
sing a song
my voice is gone yeah
are you lots are you lots left me up
here yeah yeah
yeah yeah all you lots left me here
hey
how long did i leave you out here for
hours cap
all right i know i left four hours ago
yeah
what so
how left four hours ago two pro
pro been sleep for like how long probe
and sleep y'all
probe and sleep
how do i how do i do that fan the bots
i don't know how to ban the bots oh yes
i do
report
i got you i got y'all
ban embankment
so tell me in a second how long probably
sleep i think probing sleep for like two
hours okay
[Music]
how long ain't i could have been
sleeping
sleep since you left
he woke up
every now and again but he's been asleep
it's been it's been me myself in the
chat that's all i got to the end that's
what i found out and it ain't no need to
cry i took a vow that from now on we
gonna be best friends me and myself in
the chat that's all i got in the end
that's what i found out and it ain't no
need to cry i think about that for now
won't we gonna be the best of friends
gee the funny thing i'm wearing
headphones i can't hear a damn thing
those ones are always low
no i can't hear a damn thing
they off
like they're not on oh
go turn them on it's all right um
we're having audio difficulties at the
moment our technical producer um
is asleep i'd love to show you it'd be
funny but
did you look at pearl's instagram no let
me show you yeah i'm gonna show him
pearl's instagram oh no
well he got caught slipping
who me no him no no no me no pearl did
i posted it
that is funny
uh
guys also go check out pearl's page
um
just party things
on instagram
content's fire you know what i'm saying
just that preliminating shout out to
everyone that's already following
wow powerful
pyramid baby
she was knocked everyone's like prank
her prank her finger and then i saw it i
said
and i did it slowly they're like
just
do it go
i got support from the chat appreciate
y'all
and if ever paul brings it up the chat
was on it
they supported the whole city oh she she
woke up a little bit and um
i was like look at your instagram she
was half asleep so she couldn't even
she's like i'm too tired to react is it
all right
[Music]
me
myself all i got in here
that's what i found out
you okay yeah goodness oh you were
throwing up over there
uh
no
we we troopers over here you ain't shut
up you're not a trooper
i don't know why she's being like this
like i ain't done nothing wrong
new york
huh
don't lie
i did not leave the i left the camera to
go to the toilet thank you she left the
camera didn't she
they said to go to sleep and i didn't
even battle eye clothes
how long has she gone for jess why are
you the most
resistant to sleep deprivation than ish
and pearl are they just weak
you think
yes
ish is weak pearl's not
pro works hard it is weak
yeah come for me again we're gonna have
problems we're gonna have problems
we have beef
questions see how she's on on camera
could you be submissive for your man in
marriage and what is needed for you to
do so i think i could be submissive for
my man of marriage
if
do you see the contractual part there
they asked me what
they answered
me
a phone
um
see i haven't
the question earlier was like how much
does my submission submission cost i
haven't even thought about that so i
really can't answer
that question but i don't
i don't want it to be like continual on
a dollar amount be like it has to make
this much i'm not enough
because i'm like
i just
whose phone is that
brothers brothers
wake
up wake up
okay
yeah that oh the answer goes
it was ish is a producer that who is ish
oh my days
it was a this is going to kill me
yeah guys um i'm a producer um yeah tell
them who you are yep tell me about it
part-time videographer
um we
do content creation over here
i'm trying to start something but yeah
no producer
bye day
go follow me
on on the moving wave that is on the
moving wave
it's my channel we getting started 121
subscribers at the moment
um gonna grow the channel on the
moving wave
go for a low down instagram too
um i will be putting the limps the links
in the description
uh
but yeah
we here we here we here
chat
what would you like me and jess to talk
about
we've got over an hour left
i think
if we can get through some topics we can
roll off some topics that'd be kind of
cool
um so
let us know in the chat if there's
anything that we haven't spoke about yet
once again just want to thank you all
for being here
wrote to 250 k
quarter of a milli we got there thanks
to you guys
um we're at 500k now
starts here
just party things the pre-game show
everything we're doing
it's because you guys you guys watch the
content we want to thank you for that
um
couldn't be here without you
of course
we appreciate you
and yeah we just want to keep it going
we want to keep the content going we
want to keep everything
moving
the girl's going to be moving to a new
a studio
within the next
i don't know like within the next
week to a month
as soon as
we can get a place secured we're moving
so
it gets quite hot in here
so we appreciate everything you guys do
for us
to allow us to do this
um
yeah
mr producer
what's good
if i had a camera on me i'd show
them you
but i don't know
okay apparently our producer
is running for office so he can't be on
camera
i'm usually the producer
but um
we we took shifts this
time um
this isn't to say i'm weak because jess
was talking a lot quite i don't know
where that came from
yeah bela
talking a lot of crud talking about how
i'm weak because
some of us work
different places
got places to be
and you don't think i work you don't
think i stayed
working on a dissertation hey
i'm living a lifestyle so am i
yeah where you go after this
sleep i gotta go work on a dissertation
she she says sleep really
work in a dissertation
in my dreams
jess's work life balance at the moment
isn't
where it needs to be it's not
she said i work disso
work disa rehab smc
and possibly sleep um
ish if you want to show the ladies what
it's like to be a man show just in pearl
the
animated version of bill burr helicopter
story
who plugged that
dragon stallion
1001. yeah yeah okay
bilbao
animated say that again
the title
uh
bill burr's helicopter story bilbao's
helicopter story well that get
copyrighted
appreciate
i mean i watched bill bird bill birds
earlier
yeah we can we can run it okay let's do
it wow
jess has become much more feminine since
she first appeared she actually has guys
guys go watch
the first video
on the first few videos
of poem jazz
on the pre-game show and you'll see the
growth the growth is incredible
let's clap house with jazz people
deservedly deservedly got it lee
that's crazy to hear people say that
cause i'm like damn
was it that bad
goodness it might have been a butch
yo
close enough
no i wasn't that bad chill out
chill out
anako
can you see if i'm clicking the thingy
correctly
the the the bring the box up
oh
it's there
oh no
don't move that one
um let me
let's see if it's and it's not showing
up there
just want to see something
i just want to see something
um
let's see what did he say
bilbao
helicopter story animated version
animated version
okay
can you put my headphones up please
there we go
[Music]
hey yo she said cover my face
i'ma make a smaller chill out
your headphones
i ain't gonna i can't hear nothing
um i'm on this is headphones too
of no so if that's eight i was never a
butch jess
this is
chatting
nothing
yeah i know he sure did
who did what
all right
chad i'm gonna need you to help me out
i don't think i spelled
is it the first one
let me go
[Music]
let me go get his face right
oh my days
just can you hear it
i've been able to hear mine
here i can't hit anything
are you sure can you just check the mix
buses
and that my team's not silent
the room no what's the room
but be gone
i think most start
two you may be
if that's eight this is seven
but seven might be two as well
no i'm saying this is sev this is seven
or two this is seven or two okay i'll
click it in a second guys thanks
appreciate you appreciate job
i'm telling you so this says seven
if that's eight this is seven this is
one that's both
this
uh
no because i can't change that's what
one line is it's an output i'm trying to
find out figure out what number that
that's going into
it means for eight headphones but one is
enough which i put one is this one
plugged up this one isn't is it not
plugged up
it's not plugged up that's why
wow
hey just just no no wait we don't do
that
i can't just leave it like that
sometimes they don't are not fully
blessing you don't talk anymore thank
you
nobody asked
okay we're gonna move it here
i can hear oh wow that is loud yo
these headphones that mic
over there is loud in it yeah bro was
talking and it was loud you know
sometimes the guests complain i just
ignore them it's really bad
no don't worry yeah you just it's in
your head
all right here we go
i saw this story down in orange county
right
then in orange county california this
guy gave helicopter tours for 30 years
30 years without incident
hands the business off to his son the
american dream
i built it up for 30 years there you go
son make the family and the family name
proud all right dad i love you all right
he's poor kid five days in
he's supposed to give a tour to a couple
only the dude shows up the kid thought
it was weird he's like i need the money
i gotta give him a tour right so he
takes this guy up ten minutes into the
tour the dude [__] jumped out
yeah
five days sick
five days in from the balloons and the
cake we love you son
keep the family tree going
the traditional live
five [__] days later this kid he
probably barely had the speech down just
sitting there flying the helicopter all
right if you look out the left side of
the aircraft that's orange county
there's over 27 miles of beaches put
your seat belt back on 27 miles of
beaches
was established as a county in 1903 sir
please don't open the door what are you
doing no no no
no
what the [__]
oh my god
oh my god what the [__]
what the [__]
[__]
air traffic control i don't know who's
on this frequency but you really need
something
[Applause]
so i read further into the story turns
out the guy who jumped out he was 61
years old terminally ill he was in pain
every day they couldn't figure out what
was wrong with them and he had had
enough at that point that guy
immediately became a hero in my world
right
you know what i love about him not only
did he make the decision he didn't go
out like some [__]
right a handful of pills watching a
romantic comedy
wrapped in an afghan that nana made [__]
that
guy went out like a man take me up in
the chopper i'm looking at the land i
love and then i'm jumping out like a
superhero i loved it
this guy
this guy should have been wearing a
[__] cape
[Applause]
i can't imagine how elated he must have
been on that helicopter ride up after
finally you know just taking back
control of his life like [__] you
disease i decide you know ripping tubes
out gets a burger shotguns of beer take
me up in the chop he probably hit his
[__] foot on the dashboard you know
he's not even listening to this guy
giving the tour right over over 27 miles
of beach just put put your seat belt
back on
established as a county in 1903 sir
please don't try to open it
[Applause]
but here's the thing
i left out one small thick there is one
small thing the guy [__] lived
yeah
there they were they were out over the
ocean 500 feet up you think that would
be enough so i'm thinking he must have
gone in like greg louganis like no
splashes
but witnesses said it looked like a
dummy was falling out of the air so that
sounds like a hell of an impact
i think he accidentally did the most
epic 500 foot belly flop in the history
of jumping out of a helicopter you know
but that didn't change what he was
trying to do
where his heart was i still love this
guy i just feel bad for him just on the
way down he's got to be thinking three
more seconds of pain two more seconds
wow
oh my god this is worse
this is way worse
it has a happy ending though he later
died at the hospital
that's right
go to him
god bless him i hope i have the balls
someday
[Applause]
yo that is hilarious
that is hilarious
i it got me thinking as i was watching
it i've gone
if ever i went through all that effort
to try and
end it right
i'd like to complete
the the mission
yeah i don't know exactly so to hear
that he didn't complete it i was like oh
that is the worst
god forbid guys don't do such things
yeah it's a selfish act
god forbid um
yo that was hilarious
there you go you guys had any other ones
yo we actually got a pause and
commentator
youtube
i can't
just watch content outright
with no pause or commentary
that's how we get straight
romantic
comedy
man said
i'm not gonna go out like that with no
[Applause]
it's the sun for me
hey put your seatbelt back on
all right you're here over here we got
the beaches what are you doing put your
seatbelt back on don't take it off
he's like shut up mom
sorry
don't open the door what are you doing
yes
uh
if you've got any videos like that that
was a good one yeah
hey how'd that freak can i hear ellie
growling yeah
good job raining stuff
for trees o'neill
it's raining stuff patrice o'neill oh
bill bird titanic is a horror film
i like that oh interesting
hey
we've just been put into billboard i
know
who is he
am i saying it right
that's what i think bill burr
it's cold in here
there must be some toros in the
atmosphere i said bird
it's cold in here there must be some
troubles in the atmosphere
ice ice ice break it down
what's the time jess
okay
it is eleven o'clock an hour and ten
minutes hour in ten minutes
okay guys we actually finishing at 12
o'clock um more so than anything we do
need to ensure the video saves on
youtube and youtube have a thing where
if we reach 12
there'll be no evidence of this video
ever happening on youtube so there'll be
no evidence
24 hours
uh
blessing
can you
see if i spell everything right
did i say titanic is a horror film
is it the first one chat or
the
i don't know if it's the second one
okay i'll
see what the chat says
what you got going on after this
oh i know dank is going on
is it outside
it's it's like
it's at la la land
no sorry
so it's like an indory outdoor venue
it looks like a rooftop but it's not
it's like yeah so it's kind of outdoors
man
just go la la land
you'll see very you'll see very
beautiful people
no it is
content creations
like did they get views
do you want views
[Music]
don't read it out loud
this chat is hilarious
i'm a loser people oh
huh which one oh yeah let's get that out
of the way you know 36 not married i
sleep on a futon
you know my back hurts
it's awful i'm at that age where
everybody i know is getting married
let me ask you a question why the hell
do people keep getting married yo i mean
isn't anybody
huh
chill out
he's reading the chat too
hey man
auntie look here auntie don't start
nothing don't start nothing auntie wait
aren't you speaking on the chat today
auntie was the first one to say
something hey hold up a minute i
miss that
i miss that auntie
auntie man i'm the only one that don't
have access to the chat right now it's
crazy auntie
someone said since i like black girls
myself i don't want ish to have what i
can't
get auntie
i love black women
nah he like white girls
nah she needs to draw that stop stop i i
don't discriminate i do not discriminate
but he doesn't prioritize either i'm
kidding
hey jess you go you go side to go get
off your chest
no it's just all right i've been up for
24 hours you know yeah yeah it's that
life it'll be like that yeah be like
that when you you don't take naps you're
a hustler yeah period
yeah shout out to me
yo what else did she say auntie
[Music]
yeah last hour
you gotta go i gotta go yeah you gotta
go who said that i did you're messing up
my flow
first book
so a man yeah super chat and i'll read
it out
[Music]
he said super chat
yeah you can super chat we'll read the
uh apart from that all right mr betty
all right yeah we got a video to watch
auntie i'm not going back and forth with
you with this ain't no bs i ain't never
said a bs thing a day in my life
stop the cap
that's your abs
let's go looking at the stats
what's it like three out of four
marriages go right down the drain now
people if you were going skydiving and
they told you three out of four
parachutes weren't going to open
you'd be like yo forget it i'm not going
i don't know i don't like those thoughts
i'm just kidding people you know what
i'll get married i'll get married the
day i see a married guy who actually
like looks happy you know what i mean
because every time you see a married
dude anytime you ask them what it's like
being married they always tell you it's
good but they have a look on their face
like they have like an appendicitis
what
is uh what would you say is
a relationship
like a marriage that you
have seen that it just exudes
just like
love and they're both happy like to this
day
um
so like an example of one yeah an
example of one
trying to think of
think of like a puppy one in it
i'm trying to think
i can't stand y'all y'all instigators
yeah i'm ruining it
big time crazy he got hoes
i got hoes too so yeah jessica rotation
guys
it's got a 15 girl rotation 15 yeah 15.
15 girls look at me
i work here
i think i've got 50 rotation the cap is
heavy
yo auntie did it look at the super chat
auntie said
mommy ain't raised no [__]
uh yo you're gonna read it out
yo shout out auntie man i'm gonna do the
two thousand stupid chat two pound super
chat come on we're in england i thought
i don't remember that
all right you're gonna read it oh yeah
i want jess and ish to go on a date
sounds amazing doesn't it
i'll be paying
we gonna wine and dine jess we gonna go
to our five-star restaurant
five-star restaurant
oh no guys
we got gotta do it low investment see if
she's real see if she turns up i'm a
gold digger
we'll go
get down girl go hit it down
hey madeline
i've been seeing you in the chat you
know you've been really advocating for
this
got a vested interest
yeah
nando's
no
hey
it is what it is
oh it's hilarious you're like yeah you
know nando's is
none of this peak bro
this is peak
she said she wants me to take her
gauchos
i don't even know what that is yeah all
right then that's what the cards
y'all are
we about to end the chat now
block the chat y'all you know what
answer the question that i asked you
jesus
i love it i love it what was the
question
what is an example of a marriage that
you've just seen like exude like love
like happiness from like day one to like
now um
it's it's it's weird because i wouldn't
necessarily have happiness as the
as a big
oh this is what makes a marriage good
i think it's understanding the roles the
dynamics the way in which people work
um
understanding that you will have
happiness within the marriage sometimes
there won't be happiness
but it's more so about status more so
about legacy do you respect that person
enough
because i've seen
i've seen a lot of examples of bad
situations where
one partner
it tends to be the woman like doesn't
respect her man
and so
you'll see certain levels of disrespect
going on
when he's not there yeah um
you can
tell signs of a good
relationship or a situation when
the woman asks
how
the man would want them to act
if that makes sense because the biggest
representation of
a man
is a woman when he's not there
so like if a woman's like on on her own
like they're at an event and then she's
acting in a way that
he would look at and go the old that's
respectful that
makes
him look good but also shows
the world that okay
their relationship whatever is happening
it's internal
and it's between them
and there's a level of respect that most
people would have for that
so they don't tend to
but also like showing affections you
know what i'm saying like maybe some
people are not pda so
um you find out
between you and your partner
who that is
or what works for both of you yeah
um i think for me
the best example that i've seen
throughout my life
has been um
my youth pastor growing up him and his
wife
i always said man i want i want a
marriage like that because
no matter
what it was
like
it's just like they just mesh so well
together and they just like
loved each other so much and you never i
don't know what happened behind closed
doors i don't know what happened when
they were at home but like when they
were out and about it's just like man
like
that
that was
that was meant to happen and um
[Music]
and just how he would always be like
yeah that's my girl he was just very fun
joking like
one of the the best people i've ever met
and
um he'd be like yeah that's my girl but
it wasn't like a pedestal thing and she
was very she was very just
i don't say submissive but she was just
a woman in his in his life and it just
it just worked and i'm like man and my
friend posted a picture of them the
other day and was like this is the best
relationship i've seen just of love and
i'm like man i thought i was the only
one that saw that and so for her to post
that i'm like yeah then that means it
has to be real that's amazing so yeah
i like that
so like being married like you know it's
good it's good
that's good you know it's a lot of work
but uh you know it's good
you know you me when you meet the right
person and you know it starts to click
you know simply it's a good thing you
know i enjoy it
you'll meet that person you know when
you know i can't feel my legs no you
know what you know
it's definitely it's a good thing just
i love women though this is my deal
i love women but you know what i'm
finding i'm not compatible with them you
know
i'm serious
women have like too much energy for me
that's what i've noticed you know like
you can't have a day off when you have a
girlfriend
they just like see that open day they're
like oh my god let's go fill it up with
some stuff
no no and then they just come at you
with one horrible idea after another
horrible ideas like you want to make
some sandwiches and go to the park
every one of the ideas involves like
walking around like looking at stuff
it's almost like they're trying to wear
you down
after like two or three stores you're
like leaning on stuff i don't care
i absolutely hate shopping like that's
the worst thing you hate shopping i hate
shopping if
if i'm gonna go to the
mall or shopping center i'm gonna go in
get what i need and leave i don't like
walking around window shopping oh that
looks cute it's just a drain it's long
it's long i hate it sounds like every
man's dream yeah i'm just like yo i
don't
growing up i'd be like i don't want to
go to the mall if i don't and i don't
know if it's just a
from me not being able to buy things so
i'm just like i don't like going to the
mall if i go to mom and i know what i'm
going to get i'm not about to waste
money
on xyz just to go in there and be like
oh i want this i want that
so it's just
i hate it and i see men just sitting
around i'm like y'all get him home
like get him out this door why you got
him in victoria's secret why you got him
in bed bath and body works
why get him out of here he don't want to
be here they'll be sitting outside on
the phone i'm like oh babies get him
home i can't lie to you i remember
having to
be in that situation
and
i said i'd never
i'd never go shopping with a woman again
oh my god if i can avoid that ish
i'm sorry jess
i don't wanna i'm not gonna say you're
capping i do believe you i just wouldn't
take that risk
i i wouldn't find out
no i mean because like your version of i
don't like to window shop could still be
long to a man yeah and i wouldn't i
wouldn't take you because you're gonna
be like oh
i won't go into the shoe store i won't
go here it may like
your version
and my version of uh
short mall shopping turns into a long
version because you want to go to where
you want to go i want to go to where i
want to go and it's just like it's just
long like no
do it on your do it on your own time i'm
going in there i don't know if this
would work but if it was like all right
we'll go in westfield because me
personally if i'm going shopping center
i've already got like three places i
need to go to get specific products and
that might have a slight variation
on what i get but i already know why i'm
here so there's purpose on where i'm
going and what i'm doing
sorry go ahead so um at that moment it's
a case of all right i know where i'm
going yeah
let's
split yeah and we link up at this time
let me know if you're finished or not
but yeah otherwise
i'm trying to leave get in now and it's
just sometimes it's just too many people
so many people
bumping up against you not knowing where
to walk i'm like yo move out my way i'm
on a mission i'm going in this door you
have people
looking at the stuff
and you're like move you ain't got to
stand here
i just don't sometimes i don't like
being around people and it gets the
point where i'm like you know what
i'm i'm gonna go home too many people
today
just buy something i don't care
you know what the worst one is
you ever get that one you want to go to
brunch
you want to go to branch on sunday
and inside you're like no
but you can't say that you got to keep
them happy right that's what you do
you're like yeah let's go to brunch
what a great idea
why would you want to sleep in on a
sunday when you can go pay 18 for eggs
now you're thinking
then we can sit around and listen to
your friends have moronic conversations
about the eggs like is that pesto
is that pesto in your omelet
oh it's asparagus
it's asparagus i
oh you just want to flip the whole table
over
and just run out of there
that's funny
that's females that's what they do i
said they like i'm not one of them
i mean i don't have
moronic conversations like that but
we'll have
you'll have conversations yeah we'll
have
conversations we have meant dude i wanna
never i will never
i'm gonna go over there making a mess
what you doing over there blessing
just tearing up the whole place
um
um she's practicing guys
look
anyways it's a lot bro i'm tired i'm
tired
i'm crashing
yeah no um
these are conversations the moronic
conversation you're not done oh
you should stop talking usually when
people pause
it's a sign to say
you're done i'm not finished talking
though
i'm glad this is a 24-hour livestream oh
desert give me strength give me strength
jesus shout out to the guests yesterday
yes she saw us give me strength
level of delusion was
deeper different
go watch the last live stream the last
12 hour livestream or the first
half of the 24 hours um
what was i saying
i probably would never if i asked my
husband or boyfriend out to brunch it'd
probably just be us too i would never
take him out to brunch with my girls
that's the dumbest thing ever unless
it's like a
oh
my girls are bringing their boyfriends
or their husband as well it's like a
couple type brunch but other than that
no because that's going to be hell i
would never
an all and all female thing and i'm just
like i'm gonna be my boyfriend i'm gonna
be my husband for him to suffer no
no
that's stupid
yeah i can't lie i was
never going uh
actually no genoa because in the crux of
a relationship i'd have to understand
could this be a small win
in the grand scheme of things
and then i'd kind of make my decision
but really i didn't i would not want to
go
there's bread at home
charles you're back what's up charles
wow you left me said
i'm out i'm going to sleep
and we're still here
nice you to join us again
yes jesus walks with me
90 free topi
i'm not i'm not an introvert
i wouldn't say i'm an introvert because
i don't know
sarah sarba-gavi
[Music]
pretty much max move get out the way get
out the way get out the way
beast
is this yo is this like the beast
yo chill out
is it
i'm trying to find out
no it's not
no
yeah mr beast is m.r
beast i thought it was i was like i
watch too much youtube guys i'm a fan
okay let's
we'll
give us a patrice o'neal one and we will
probably finish out with him i mean if
it's a long one but
yo have you seen his um
no
you haven't seen any oh my gosh
the funniest part
is when he's spelling and it's so funny
because i'm that person he's like quit
stalling
all right all right all right he said oh
hey i have to show you it's just funny
it's funny i bet
so
i was dating this girl recently this
girl's like really like into like
women's issues
she got me his book on women's lib one
time right so i'm reading this thing i
think women's live was a great thing
like back in the 70s i thought it was
cool you know over the last couple of
years though i think that whole woman's
movement it's really starting to morph
into kind of like this reverse pimping
kind of thing you know because every
time you see them on tv they always say
all we want is be treated exactly like
guys right but if you listen to them
they don't they only want the good stuff
of being a guy
they look at a guy's life like it's like
a buffet
like you just can start picking out
stuff like same amount an hour we'll
take some of that pay for the movie
that's okay you can keep that one i like
that one
this is nice that's yucky that's icky
come on people you can't choose this
girl give me a rough time on time she
goes well why does a guy make more an
hour to do the exact same job i go i'll
tell you why because in the unlikely
event that we're both on a titanic and
it starts to sink for some screwed up
reason you get to leave with the kids
and i have to stay
no that's why i get the dollar more an
hour
you know if there's a house fire it's
always women and children first i got to
stand there with like the back of my
shirt on fire go let's go people let's
go let's go
so that's how i look at it
no it's a dollar an hour surcharge
yo i never thought of it like that
what
that they get they get paid more because
they're expendable or people see them as
expendable
how he's explaining it
that makes sense
wow
yeah but dangerous jobs in it yeah yeah
um yeah but in his scenario like if
someone
is working the same job and whatnot why
does a man get paid more
it's interesting because essentially if
a building was burning down they won't
be like everybody out everybody else
they'd be like women first and then
men
true true
seriously that if something screwed up
happens either i can't leave or i gotta
like get in the way of it to give you a
head start like rabid dog run honey one
mississippi two mississippi
you hear a bump in the night i gotta go
check it out like yes he does have a
knife
no i don't i don't think a woman should
make a doll less an hour to do the exact
same job okay i'm not saying that all
i'm saying is if you're going to make
what i make when the boat sinks you
better be standing right there next to
me listen to that guy play the cello
then you get the corner office
i don't got a problem you got all the
benefits
oh sorry that's why i didn't like that
movie the titanic you know you know i
hate about that movie every girl i meet
thinks that movie's romantic like my god
that was so romantic don't you think
no
no i don't it was a horror film
and now he's like why why because all
the guys die
see you're sitting there watching it
going who would i be in that scenario
you'd be that chick floating away in the
big piece of luggage i'm watching it
going who would i be i'd be that dude
when like the boat breaks in half that
dude who like falls straight down bangs
off the stuff and goes into the water
that's who i'd be
i'd be wearing a tuxedo not cause i
wanted to but you wanted to dress up
that night right
and i'd just be falling the whole way
down i should have humped that chicken
first class
all right i'm out of time you guys a lot
of fun thank you very much
that was a good one
yeah
he said you better be right next to me
people don't women don't understand that
like if you want equality you
essentially want everything that
a man does and doesn't get
that's true
so if you want equality
you go into war
where did that one go
we can't love like you patrice o'neil
okay
we'll watch that one and then but first
we're gonna watch patrice o'neill
ciao bilbao
bill
burr
i probably spelled it wrong
an echo
patrice don't know we get it right
it doesn't matter this is the one that i
want
so essentially he's talking about being
held hostage at gunpoint and having a
spell
like i can't spell if i had to spell
restaurant
to this day right
to save my mama's life like if
like if somebody held my mom a hostage
she had a gun to her
it says [__] spell restaurant you know
shoot your mother in the head i'll be
like i would look at my mother like uh i
love you
you gotta look at me mom she's crying
understand that i
i love you with all my
heart
literally it's so funny because
the way he spells he's about to smell it
i'm spelt it that way
and the first time i saw this i was
crying and we watched it earlier and i
was crying
it's
it's just so good
stop stalling [__] okay all right all
right
all right
all right all right all right all right
r-e-s-t
oh my god here's where it gets
oh jesus christ
uh i don't want to spill it
resting
[Applause]
that's how i say it to remember how to
spell it a res resturante
he's like there's an idiot
that's an e he's like all right all
right
oh he said r yes
[Applause]
it's an a oru or you
all right give me a note give me another
word man give me another
probably god death banana all right
banana banana b-a-n
hey
[Applause]
i'm excited to see this one what time is
it
you know god bless me for good eyes
chat help me out first one second one
third one fourth one first one second
one third one fourth one first one
second one third one fourth one first
one second one third one
what what what what
what is it what is it
oh no somebody's about to leave
somebody about to leave i want to
understand subscribers
but remember we don't even
[Music]
thanks char
charles charles charles
velasquez
this is for jess and sarah i appreciate
the strength and struggle
during the stream i know i normally
ninja watch but watch
the show i love you guys and you're
definitely my favorite people on the
channel
just on top for real
thanks charles
gracias we appreciate you thank you
yes yes
i'll be extending thanks from sorrow
sure shout out to sarah
mr garvey mistake okay first one wait
it's just
what is what is one pumping me
what is one pumping
the last one
i don't know what that means
but it's best not to say out live on
stream
you've been talking mad in the chat
wait why why is everyone putting ones in
the chat because i asked if it was
the first one or second one they're
telling me first one
like you watching the news and no matter
what's on you just you just can't
you can't care like you tried to but it
just
30 000 chinese people died in an
earthquake
what's that
i can't shop online auntie i have to go
into the stores to try on things uh
ex 30 said i can't wait for
the day pearl thinks that's her name uh
to get married she deserves a good man
yeah auntie i when i tell you
i have to go into the store because my
body is so disproportionate that i have
to try on shirts and stores because as
someone pointed out earlier
i have broad shoulders
and then
i got small waist and thick thighs so i
have to go into the store and guys save
lives you know
it is the hey you do what it is but i
have to go to the store and try it on so
i can't i can't shop online
so yeah
um
it's justin pearl you guys are troopers
i appreciate what you're doing the
channel is amazing channel is like a
loving family oh thanks sarah thank you
sarah sarah cavi appreciate you boy look
at that profile pic styling and
profiling
sarah garvey everybody
he has to put in his bid
running out on your time sarah
yo yo
yeah like it like it up like it oh my
gosh
we have a 2
7 6 5 i don't know
guys jess is struggling to count at the
moment i don't know what she's trying to
count
oh how many minutes we have 27 minutes
left guys 27 minutes
let's get it
27 minutes and then we'll do outros
mentos
quake and you're like
oh my god
wow
i could care less oh my god
a missing mother of ten hasn't been seen
in two weeks you're like all right i'ma
care about this i know it i know i know
i oh wow
i don't give a damn
is he talking about how men care
is that what he's talking about
you know i don't know but like all i
know is
i've been in this kind of a situation so
it feels
i feel it
okay okay
you ever feel like a terrible person
when you're watching the news okay it's
just a terrible person yeah okay maybe a
terrible person yeah
forgive me chad
of ten
hasn't been seen
i oh wow
i don't give a damn
like i mean i believe in god but you
know like i'm not deep into religion
like i'm too afraid to not believe in
god you know
like i'm not an atheist i'm like before
that like but like
like i believe in god when i'm in on
planes like i really believe in god
you ever try to make a side deal with
god just
when i get on planes i look at some old
ladies struggling with her bags having
trouble putting it in overhead i'm like
wait a minute lady let me get that for
you man
let me put that heavy bag up there for
you cause
you know
look god
look what a great guy i am helping this
woman with her bags you ain't gonna let
the plane crash how are you lord jesus
cause i'm a good person
and then when the plane lands the ladies
looking at me like you want to get my
bags i'm like no like what
i kept that
i kept the plane in the air you selfish
[__] i
[Applause]
i don't even believe in ground karma i i
kept us all alive let somebody else
handle the ground i'm done
he said i don't believe in ground karma
there is unlike
no other podcast on youtube we are
unique period
best channel ever
yes
is
he says something in spanish
i don't know
resilient
reformed you're allowed your second name
is reformed the first one i cannot what
did you say
someone translate for me please
okay um
do you ever feel like that on planes
[Music]
i'm not afraid of heights um but no i
don't really feel like that one planes
to be honest i'm like
i'm about to go on an experience it's
gonna be fun okay i get the pre-jitters
off of take-off okay and landing but
part of not
i enjoy being here okay
and then in my head statistically
planes are like one of the least likely
places you'll die
yeah that gives me even more confidence
and if i die
i if i'm able to jump and i'm able to
land in water
i can swim
hey that's good defeating the stereotype
out here hey yo there you go
auntie says dennis dinner is finished
i'm going to bed after this we coming to
your house for dinner auntie makes sense
we come everybody's invited andy's house
with dinner
we're trying to eat good we're trying to
eat good good
free agent very true it brings together
cross sections of society
is um
probably sleeping and we gonna leave her
sleep
she says she appreciates you all so much
appreciate all your
um donations super chats memberships
everything we appreciate you guys
sticking around for this 24 hour live
stream can't believe we did it again
um and we just appreciate you guys for
all that you do y'all are the best
ever
like the if you're about to head out
like the video on your way out we are 20
minutes away from being done
uh [__] this
give me your like
can you count
in spanish oh
okay
see i knew i knew it was light because
le loose and i was like
give me your light can you count spin
see
oh no i can count up to once i get to
30.
it's like trenta
i think 50 is where i'm like
i can't remember how to say them i know
that is you just add on the number at
the end and then
hundreds
that has
gone on my brain
uh for spanish anything above 100 i'm
like okay
but um yeah
we
are
yeah
shout out to the 366 of you are still
watching us on live chat we appreciate
you you've been here for a minute even
if you've just come thank you don't
forget to like comment subscribe
we appreciate you lots come on
oh the best um
i don't think i've ever been afraid of
planes
even when all that stuff went down in
the states with 9 11. yeah do you know
it's crazy when i deep it right i'm like
well growing up yeah
getting on a plane was a privilege yeah
you think i've got time to be scared of
getting on a plane yeah i was just happy
to be at the airport yeah i remember the
first time i'd go to see your family
members going back to zim yeah
got into the airport again
you are so lucky you get to step on that
on that plane yeah i like
i wanna be there
so then
when i finally got the chance age six
i was i was prancing about i was packing
my bags i said yeah we gonna roll to the
airport with my little suitcase
i couldn't even carry but
is what it is
i jumped on that map i was happy i said
the first time i felt that liftoff i
said what's this this feeling right
i said i don't like roller coasters so
this is something else
yeah i i i like to weather it and then i
learned to kind of embrace it more so
than tense up with it but apart from
that
yeah i was excited to be on a plane
yeah happy days i love flying i
literally love flying it's the best i
get on that thing i'm out i tell you i'm
out
i don't even i've been on so many planes
i don't even wait for them to tell me
the safety features i'm like i know
where the exits are i know the life
jackets are
i know what to do in the exit row
let's get this thing off the ground
exposure
would you love just to open the blinds
can we just fix them sorry
it's blown up
hey yo
i'm not getting it
it's hard to be honest man honesty is
not the greatest thing to be
it's not it's just no one wants to hear
yeah
especially a woman you know she don't
want to hear that
you ever have your girlfriend or your
wife call you from another room and
she's like sweetie and then like
immediately you go your stomach just
goes oh
what does she want
oh this is gonna see that's something
that i don't want in my marriage i don't
wanna be like man what this dubois like
what do you want
i know there's gonna be times i'm just
gonna be like don't talk to me
because i know i get like that now but i
don't wanna be like annoyed like man why
are you calling me like why do you want
to talk to me like what i don't want to
ever have that in my marriage i don't
want them to feel like that about me i'm
like
what what she want now she calling me
i'm here doing stuff like she's so
annoying i don't i don't ever wanted to
get to that and i don't know how to
prevent that because i can be annoying
sometimes i know myself i think it's
just communication and like having that
conversation with each other being
to some extent real with each other and
being like okay cool like this is what i
expect these are my expectations
yeah can we
can we live up to the expectations or is
it a case where we're gonna have to
compromise meat in the middle because
what you want you want things to be done
out of love do you know what i'm saying
um
and to some extent out of g like
if it's a case where it's like all right
me and my partner said yo
i'll we want to get said item or we want
to
renovate the house
yeah
then i may have to pick up a few shifts
for example
to make that happen
i'm looking at it as more so a duty not
so much of a oh i don't i want to do
this or i don't really want to do this
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah and
so
get me
no i mean yeah
is it it is a question right
and like this is to to the chat really
and also jess but
if we as men would in an ideal world
require and i think we should
require sex to be a duty to
for our woman to give us
does that mean
attention
is a duty of hours to give to our woman
it depends on if she wants attention
like that wait what woman doesn't want
attention i'm saying like
extra attention because obviously you're
gonna give her attention okay so
that's funny how you say it so attention
is already mandatory
i mean
like attention is just
so my point is in the dating market
women want attention men want sex
and i'm talking about from the
what do i want first off
so like as a guy
if i had it my way i'd have sex straight
away mm-hmm but
as a woman more time than not you want
to be wined and dying or like somewhat
like okay yeah yeah you know what i mean
yeah let's spruce it up
a little bit give me a little game do
something before we can get to that
point okay
the game is to leverage attention for
sex okay and the person who does it best
tends to be the winner hence why you
find the guys at the top
percentile of in the dating market are
able to leverage
as little attention yeah as possible
before they get the cookie
yeah whereas guys at the bottom are
giving out all the attention and not
getting anything
that makes sense i would say
yeah then
that would be a duty because that's
something that women need just like many
sex women need attention it's just
it's
sex in a different in a different way if
you want to put it like that okay pearl
is sleep
don't nobody ask me
for the sleep jesus my
i can feel myself shutting down
shutting down let's get into it
suck i know it's not gonna be good
because it's never good you want to hear
what happened to me today he'd be like
oh not really i make
i always make my girlfriend tell me the
end of any story she get ready to tell
me first before i invest in the whole
i'd be like shut up what what what
what's the end of the story like
somebody got shot
all right go ahead try to tell story
she starts off wrong all the time
you know my friend diane right
and here's why i mess up i go uh nah i
don't know diane you know diane
i
chat
if ever that statement or that question
is asked like a little caveat
to give you the full story
just go along with it because you you're
gonna prolong your time
in that conversation
yeah
and here's the thing it's not so much
that
most in most of these stories right the
guy doesn't actually need to know who
diane is
in order for the story to make sense
yeah that's a big so that's big facts
big facts just you want a man to be
um
yes
do not want
do not want your man to be that way when
you call him
don't always call him when you want
something call him when you are giving
him things he likes
ha
thanks
thanks for the
for the
advice
at ish yes i have a child so us three i
call us the unit my job as a man a
partner as a father
um is to lead and protect the unit i can
also do this if i give them everything
they need so they're answering
your question love that thank you
um
thanks for the support i'm up max i
promise you i'm up
my body's just like yo we in the final
into the thick of it
[Music]
my boy you're making sense
but
we was in the clear nobody was saying
nothing we starting to pack up so i can
forget
now i'm going to tell you an hour and a
half side story about who diane is
because i can't keep going with the
story till you know who diane is
remember three years ago i made you go
to a party that you didn't want to go to
or was it two years ago wait a minute
was it two years ago
that was three years ago i made you go
remember i introduced you to a bunch of
women you didn't care about
one of them was diane
you remember now don't do this
uh yeah yeah i remember you don't
remember you're just saying that
so i could tell the story faster why
don't you tell the story faster
who got shot see they say
why'd you ask me why'd you ask him
if he remembered you know he doesn't
remember just tell the freaking story
like yo get to it
get to the point
i do that sometimes but sometimes i'm
just like i'll tell myself like jessica
shut up you're talking too much just get
to the point i'll be like sorry let me
just get to it now
because i know that i tactic yeah if i'm
with my girl she's dead now i'm starting
to kiss her neck just to get distracted
toxic
toxic how so toxic hey
want to listen like how dare you i
listen she wants to talk to you she
wants you to listen
she wants you to hear her heart and
you're just going to
sexualize her how dare you see that's
what the problem with men today they
just sexualize women all the time they
don't listen they just say sex sex sex
sex sex
i can't stand this misogynistic world
the purpose of this dream was to do to
repo jess you think she's been red
peeled after hearing
so much that i'm able to go on that rant
i know exactly okay sorry sorry 90 free
toe pie here you go
did diane get shot she didn't get shot
did she shoot somebody she didn't
why'd you say diane
cause she don't like guns
why would you say that finish the story
who got shot never mind now
you won't let me tell the story
so i won't finish because you won't let
me tell it with diane my friend who
doesn't like guys
[Applause]
hey
i'm sorry ladies that's not y'all that's
some other ladies that's not in here
i don't even know what women that could
possibly be
you want to know how to
because men is hard for us to love you
and like you at the same time it's just
it is what it is once a man loves you he
no longer likes you usually so
i'm going to give you some advice ladies
on how to keep your man liking you once
he loves you if that's possible this is
what i think
men want to be alone
but we don't want to be by ourselves
does that make sense at all
meaning
really
look at this guy looking at his wife
like
not you sweetie but sort of you kinda
be we want you
somewhere like
in the dwelling just not here like just
like around the corner in the vents you
can sit in the vent i don't care
if you want to watch me
in the bait on the roof anywhere but
just not in front of me
trying to be my friend what you doing
what you doing
watching baseball why are you watching
baseball by yourself
how come you didn't get me up you snuck
out of bed why'd you didn't get me i
want to watch baseball with you what you
doing why are you wearing it
why are you down here by yourself move
over move your leg off that ottoman
where it's comfortable so i can sit next
to you and wrap my leg around your leg
and some weird i love you
hot vine move oh give me your arm give
me your arm give it to me let me get it
come here
give me a
kiss mean it mean the kiss
that sounds like torture
that sounds like torture my god
because i know when i'm alone don't
touch me don't talk to me i snuck out of
bed for a reason
i'm down here doing stuff by myself for
a reason
not because
i don't love you
i just need me time
me time
meantime someone asked
espanol
that's it
do i sing
oh thanks i don't
you love me say it say mean it
what you doing
what you eating a hamburger you
shouldn't be eating a hamburger at 11.
it's too early to eat a hair
let me go make you a better sandwich a
turkey sandwich on 47 grain bread with
no mayonnaise and bean sprouts
tastes like rat turds and and twigs
ain't that better
ain't that better a dry sandwich you
don't want ain't that better
why is the tv so loud turn it down
ain't that better can't hear the tv got
a dry sandwich you don't want it
why is it so cold in here turn it why is
the ceiling fan and the air conditioner
turn it off ain't that better sweating
wrapped up into a hot vine can't hear
the tv got a dry sandwich
why is it so dark in here let some
sunlight in ain't that better
can't see the tv can't hear it hey i
gotta go man y'all take care of it thank
you very much
lord have mercy special guy that's a
special guy lord heaven
ain't that better
oh
maybe reminisce you know
times when i was in situations like that
y'all we are approaching the end
let's go
y'all have been
the
what did auntie say auntie in here still
cutting up
what's all you saying oh no that's a
real one
oh she said something
i don't know what she said blaze i see
you appreciate you
oh we won't alyssa we won't lose the
video we're gonna make sure we save it
yeah now guys i've i've i've left the
10-minute buffer yeah
we're gonna do like a countdown do
little couple outros yeah um
yeah no we appreciate you though
appreciate you
lastima
[Music]
go to sleep say the stream say the
stream say the stream how many hours
does it how many what's the time on it
everyone's saying save the stream say
this
what is it
oh okay we're good
say the video just ain't take them no i
did not i'm keeping my socks off no
freaks
freaking it
say the video y'all cutting it close nah
we didn't start we didn't start right at
12. well we just had to end it at 12 to
make sure we
uh
get it
guys we in the 24th hour
we appreciate everyone a minute last
minute 30 seconds
make sure to follow pearl on um just
pearly dressed up pearly thing subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out
um follow ish on his socials you can
follow me on my socials
uh if you want to come on the show
uh dm eddie follow our clips channel
we're trying to get to 50 subscribers
what else
um
what else we got guys membership sign up
for memberships new videos coming out
we're going to show you behind the
scenes of the new studio that we get we
appreciate you guys for going through
this 24 hours with us again and we just
appreciate all the things that you guys
do for the channel we literally could
not do what we do on this channel pearl
cannot do what she does without every
one of you donating super chats becoming
a member just being so
dedicated to getting the message that
pearl
is trying to spread out there for
everybody we could not do it without you
guys and we appreciate you guys so so so
much again thank you for being on the
stream thank you for keeping us
entertained giving us great questions
and just wanting to grow with us as well
so yeah i hope everyone has a great
night great day wherever you are in the
world get some rest and we will see you
guys next time